GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. SENATE
WILL COME TO ORDER. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO GILL. ARCHULETA. ASHBY.
ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. CORTEZ.
DALLY DODD. DURAZO. EGGMAN
GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES. LAIRD LIMON. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN. NGUYEN
NILO. OCHOA. BOGH. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. RATH RUBIO. SEYARTO.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. STERN
UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER WILK.
MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS PRESENT. I
WANT TO INVITE ALL MEMBERS TO
COME TO THEIR DESKS. PLEASE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
WOULD THE MEMBERS AND GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY, PLEASE RISE. WE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER. THIS MORNING BY
OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELLE.
AFTER WHICH, PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG. WE
GATHER IN GOD'S PRESENCE. O GOD
OF GIFTS, QUICKEN IN ME A SENSE
OF HUMOR BRIGHT ENOUGH TO HELP
ME FIND MY WAY IN THESE
TARNISHED TIMES. FRUITFUL ENOUGH
TO BE MADE THE WINE OF HOPE. TO
WARM THE HEARTS OF THOSE I LIVE
AND WORK WITH. MAKE ME GLAD TO
BE ONE OF A KIND. YET ONE WITH A
KIND CALLED NOT TO BE MORE LIKE
OTHERS, BUT MORE OF MYSELF. A
GORILLA OF GRACE THAT IN DARING
TO BE AUTHENTIC, I MAY BECOME
MORE OF A HUMAN KIND. O GOD OF
GIFTS, LIBERATE ME TO SHARE
WITHOUT APOLOGY OR ARROGANCE NOT
ONLY THE GIFTS I HAVE, BUT THE
GIFT I AM. AMEN PLEASE JOIN ME
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, SISTER MICHELLE. MEMBERS.
IF I COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION,
LET ME TRY TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF A RUNDOWN ON THE DAY.
TODAY WE HAVE AN EXCITING DAY
AHEAD OF US. BEFORE WE ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO FIRST
MOVE TO PRIVILEGE. I'LL GIVE YOU
A RUNDOWN IN A MINUTE. BUT
FIRST, BEFORE WE BEGIN, WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. MEMBERS, CAN I HAVE ALL
YOUR ATTENTION, PLEASE? CAN I
ASK MEMBERS TO RETURN TO THEIR
DESKS, PLEASE? THANK YOU.
MEMBERS, I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR PADILLA, PLEASE GIVE HIM
YOUR ATTENTION. MEMBERS. MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
THIS MORNING, THE SENATE OBSERVE
A MOMENT OF SILENCE IN MEMORY OF
SAN DIEGO POLICE OFFICER AUSTIN
MACARTHUR. I TAKE THIS UNUSUAL
PRIVILEGE SIMPLY BECAUSE NOT
ONLY WAS HE A YOUNG HERO THAT
DIED NEEDLESSLY A LITTLE MORE
THAN 24 HOURS AGO, HE WAS
SOMEONE WHO WAS NEAR AND DEAR TO
ME AND TO MY COMMUNITY. HE WAS
FAMILY. OUR HEART IS BREAKING.
HE WAS A HERO. HE WAS A
BRILLIANT AND BEAUTIFUL PERSON
INSIDE AND OUT. AND HIS LIFE'S
JOURNEY WAS TO HELP AND TO SERVE
OTHERS. AND HE WAS TAKEN TOO
YOUNG. AND I'M GRATEFUL IF WE
OBSERVE A MOMENT OF SILENCE IN
HIS HONOR.
THANK YOU. SENATOR PADILLA,
WE'RE VERY SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS
AND OUR LOSS. MEMBERS. WE'RE.
SENATOR GONZALEZ, FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. WE WILL BE
CAUCUSING DEM CAUCUS AT THE MADI
LOUNGE NOW FOR ABOUT 30 MINUTES.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. DEMOCRATS
WILL CAUCUS IN THE MADI LOUNGE.
WE'RE. WE'RE ON RECESS FOR
CAUCUS.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS. THE SENATE
WILL CONVENE IN 60S.
MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL COME
BACK TO ORDER IF MEMBERS CAN
RETURN TO THEIR DESKS. PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR PATIENCE TODAY. IT WILL BE
A LONG DAY. WE'RE HOPING TO GET
THROUGH BETWEEN 150 AND 200
BILLS. WE WILL. WE WILL TAKE A
LUNCH BREAK ASKING MEMBERS TO
STAY HERE IN THE BUILDING. AND
THE SAME WITH DINNER. ALL RIGHT.
LET US BEGIN OUR SESSION.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO
MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE 29.10 B,
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON RULES BY
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. ASSEMBLY BILL
2243. I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE
MAJORITY LEADER, SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I MOVE TO
SUSPEND SENATE RULE 29.4 FOR AB
181. PLEASE A MOTION TO SUSPEND
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ. SENATOR
DELYLAH, WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU
RISE? I'M SORRY. I DIDN'T HEAR
WHAT THAT MOTION WAS. IT'S A
MOTION TO SUSPEND THE SENATE
RULES. SIR, I OBJECT TO THAT
MOTION. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
GONZALEZ IS ASKING FOR A AYE
VOTE. SENATOR NEAL IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE. I WANT TO READ THE
RESOLUTION. YOU WANT TO READ THE
MOTION? OKAY, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. NØ. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. NÓ. DODD. AYE. DURAZO
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. NO HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. NO LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MIN NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. NO.
NILO. NO OCHOA. BORG. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE
ROTH. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO NO.
SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN DURAZO. AYE. LIMON AYE.
MCGUIRE MEN. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 9, THE SENATE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO JUMP AROUND A
LITTLE BIT TODAY, BUT LET ME
JUST LET YOU KNOW THAT FOR THE
NEXT FEW MINUTES AT LEAST, WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM 278.
THAT'S A COMPACT. SENATOR GROVE
IS GOING TO PRESENT. WE'RE GOING
TO FOLLOW THAT BY ABOUT EIGHT
DIFFERENT BUDGET VOTES THERE.
FILE ITEM 270 THROUGH 276. AND
THAT'S OUR SCHEDULE HEADING INTO
LUNCH. SO WE WILL BEGIN WITH
FILE ITEM 278. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 2656. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2656 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. AN ACT
RELATING TO TRIBAL GAMING AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
GROVE, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
IT IS MY HONOR TO STAND BEFORE
YOU AND PRESENT AB 2656, A
COMPACT FOR TABLE MOUNTAIN
RANCHERIA. IT'S A CLASS THREE
COMPACT. THE COMPACT, ORIGINALLY
ENTERED INTO IN 1999, WAS LED
HAS LED THE TRIBE INTO AN AGE OF
PROSPERITY AND SELF-SUFFICIENCY.
A GAMING COMPACTS CAN RESULT IN
HISTORIC LAND. IT WAS A GAMING
COMPACT. EXCUSE ME? AS A RESULT
OF THE HARD FOUGHT STRUGGLE TO
RECOGNIZE TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY AND
FORGE A PATH FORWARD FOR
SELF-SUFFICIENCY FOR THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITY AND ITS PEOPLE.
EMPLOYEES ARE TEAM MEMBERS OF
THIS TRIBE. THEY EMPLOY 1200
PLUS PEOPLE AND EVERY ONE OF
THESE EMPLOYEES IS TREATED LIKE
A TEAM MEMBER. THEY'RE GIVEN
EXCELLENT WAGES, BENEFITS, PAID
TIME OFF, SICK LEAVE, LIFE
INSURANCE POLICIES, EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR FAMILIES
AND THEIR CHILDREN, AND MUCH
LIKE WE DO HERE IN THE SENATE,
WHEN ONE OF OUR MEMBERS FALLS,
OUR STAFF FALLS ON HARD TIMES.
WE COME TOGETHER AND DONATE SICK
LEAVE AND THINGS LIKE THAT. THE
TRIBE ALSO HAS A PROGRAM SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE DO HERE IN THE
SENATE, TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
MEMBERS OR THEIR TEAM MEMBERS,
THEIR EMPLOYEES, WHETHER FROM
THE COMMUNITY OR THE TRIBE THAT
FALL ON HARD TIMES, HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO BE
HELPED. ADDITIONALLY, FROM THEIR
FELLOW WORKERS AND THE TRIBAL
COUNCIL, THE TABLE MOUNTAIN
TRIBE, AND THE SKI AND MONO
PEOPLE IS ENDURED. AND THEY HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN THE WAKE OF
ALL OF THIS. THEY'RE COMMITTED
TO IMPROVING THE GENERAL WELFARE
OF ALL THEIR TRIBAL MEMBERS. AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO PARTNER WITH
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY.
THEY'RE THEY'RE A GOOD PARTNER
WITH OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
THEY'RE AN ASSET. IT'S A
WONDERFUL DESTINATION IN THE
FRESNO COMMUNITY AREA. I CAN
TELL YOU, COLLEAGUES, THAT, THE
CHAIRWOMAN HAS WALKED THE HALLS
WITH HER COUNCIL MEMBERS THE
LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS. AND I JUST
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS COMPACT AND ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR GROVE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? SENATOR
CIERTO. THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN IN FAVOR
AND SUPPORT OF THIS TRIBAL
COMPACT AND TOTALLY SUPPORT THE
EFFORT AND THE COMPACT AS
WRITTEN, WHAT I WAS DISAPPOINTED
WITH WAS THE PROCESS THAT THIS
PARTICULAR TRIBE HAD TO GO
THROUGH IN ORDER TO GET HERE,
AND I WILL LEAVE IT AT THAT. BUT
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR SECRETO, ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS? SEEING NONE,
SENATOR GROVE, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I WOULD
LIKE TO IF WITH THE CHAIR'S
PERMISSION, ASK THE HONORABLE
CHAIRWOMAN, MICHELLE DE CORDOVA,
TO STAND. SHE'S IN THE GALLERY
UP HERE. SO RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU,
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BY SIMPLY
READING. SHE'S NOT ALLOWED TO
READ THE STATEMENT ON THE FLOOR.
OBVIOUSLY, WE DON'T ALLOW THAT,
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO READ THE
HONORABLE CHAIRWOMAN'S.
STATEMENT. IF A PERMISSION IS
GRANTED WITHOUT OBJECTION. THANK
YOU. HALIMAH DELYLAH. GREETINGS.
I AM MICHELLE HEREDIA CORDOVA
AND I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
BEING THE TRIBAL CHAIRWOMAN FOR
TABLE MOUNTAIN RANCHERIA
RANCHERIA, A SOVEREIGN BAND OF
CHUKCHANSI AND MONO PEOPLE. THE
WORDS I HEAR, I SHARE TODAY, I
SHARE IN A GOOD WAY OVER THE
PAST TWO WEEKS, MY FELLOW
COUNCIL MEMBERS AND I HAVE
WALKED THE HALLS ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN HAVING OUR COMPACT
HEARD. DURING THAT TIME, SOMEONE
REMARKED THAT WE HAVE THIS. WE
CAN DO THIS BECAUSE WE STAND ON
THE SHOULDERS OF THOSE WHO HAVE
COME BEFORE US. I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THE SENTIMENT IS NOT LOST
ON US FOR WE DON'T JUST STAND ON
THE SHOULDERS, WE CARRY THEIR
BLOOD, THEIR SWEAT AND THEIR
TEARS FROM GENOCIDE, SLAVERY TO
DISPLACEMENT AND FORCED
ASSIMILATION, THERE IS NO
COMPENSATION GREAT ENOUGH TO
MAKE REPARATIONS FOR WHAT
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE
ENDURED. THIS COMPACT IS NOT
JUST AN AGREEMENT OR A CONTRACT,
FOR WE ARE NOT A BUSINESS OR A
CORPORATION FOCUSED ON IMPROVING
THE BOTTOM LINE FOR US, GAMING
IS A REVENUE. THIS GAMING
REVENUE HAS BEEN A LIFELINE,
HELPING US PIECE TOGETHER WHAT
WAS ONCE BROKEN. WITH THIS
REVENUE, WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE BEST MEDICAL CARE
FOR OUR TRIBAL CITIZENS, AS WELL
AS FOR 1300 PLUS EMPLOYEES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON BUILDING A NEW
MEDICAL FACILITY TO EXPAND OUR
SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC. ALONG
WITH OUR OWN MEDICAL OPERATION.
WE HAVE MADE MAJOR CONTRIBUTIONS
AND ARE LIFETIME PARTNERS WITH
THE COMMUNITY MEDICAL CENTER,
SAINT AGNES AND VALLEY
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS. IN TERMS
OF HOUSING, WE CAN NOW AFFORD
THE INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS
POWER, WATER AND ROADS NEEDED TO
BUILD HOMES FOR OUR TO BRING OUR
TRIBAL CITIZENS BACK TO THEIR
ANCESTRAL LANDS. FOR EDUCATION,
WE COVER THE FULL TUITION FOR
OUR TRIBAL CITIZENS SO THEY CAN
PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION AND
RETURN WITH THAT KNOWLEDGE TO
HELP STRENGTHEN OUR TRIBE. WE
ALSO HAVE A PRESCHOOL THAT
SERVES BOTH OUR TRIBAL COMMUNITY
AND THE FAMILIES OF OUR
EMPLOYEES. WE CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
LOCAL SCHOOLS THROUGH DONATIONS
AND SPONSORSHIPS, AND HAVE A
LONG STANDING PARTNERSHIP WITH
FRESNO STATE IN CULTURAL
PRESERVATION. OVER THE LAST 25
YEARS, WE'VE BROUGHT BACK
NUMEROUS BASKETS AND ARTIFACTS,
AND WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING ON
BUILDING A CULTURAL CENTER TO
SHOWCASE OUR COLLECTION. A PLACE
WHERE WE CAN SHARE OUR HISTORY
AND TELL OUR STORY. THIS CENTER
WILL ALSO HOUSE A DEDICATED
SPACE TO PRESERVE OUR LANGUAGE
CEREMONIES, SONGS, NATIVE FOOD,
AND TRADITIONS THROUGH GAMING
REVENUE. WE SUPPORT THE
OPERATION OF OUR TRIBAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT, WHICH SERVES TO
PROTECT OUR TRIBAL CITIZENS,
EMPLOYEES AND PATRONS. THE NEW
COMPACT WILL ALLOW OUR TRIBE TO
CONTINUE IN PARTNER PARTNERSHIP
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT, FIRE PROTECTION
AGENCIES AND OTHERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. THE REVENUE GENERATED
THROUGH GAMING HAS ALLOWED US TO
BUY BACK AND RECLAIM OUR
ORIGINAL LANDS AND INCREASE OUR
BASE, INCLUDING OUR TRIBAL
CEMETERY. MY AUNT, THE LATE
CHAIRWOMAN BEVERLY J. HUNTER,
WHO NOW RESTS THERE, WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN FIGHTING TO
BRING BACK THE TRIBES CEMETERY
AND THE RESTING PLACE OF OUR
ANCESTORS. AND IT'S NOW BACK
UNDER OUR POSSESSION, SHE BEGAN.
THESE COMPACT NEGOTIATIONS WITH
US, AND I KNOW SHE, ALONG WITH
OUR ANCESTORS, ARE HERE WITH US
TODAY. IN CLOSING, WE THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR TIME AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT, FOR SUPPORT, FOR TABLE
MOUNTAIN RANCHERIA GAMING
COMPACT. WE THANK THE GOVERNOR
AND THE COMPACT NEGOTIATIONS
TEAM FOR THEIR COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS IN REACHING THIS
AGREEMENT WITH OUR TRIBE. A NEW
CLASS THREE GAMING COMPACT. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO FUTURE CONTINUED
COLLABORATION AND MUTUAL
SUCCESS. THANK YOU. AND I SAY
THIS IN HONOR. THANK YOU,
COLLEAGUES, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BREAKSPEARE. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN DURAZO. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0. ON THE
URGENCY. 39 TO 0 ON THE MEASURE.
THE MEASURE PASSES. SENATE
EXTENDS ITS CONGRATULATIONS. AND
WELCOME TO THE LEADERS OF THE
TRIBE THAT ARE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS TODAY. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 270. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 157 PRESENTED BY
OUR BUDGET CHAIR, SENATOR WIENER
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. THE
ASSEMBLY BILL 157 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL. AN ACT RELATING
TO THE STATE BUDGET AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BUDGET
BILL. SENATOR WIENER, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. I THANK YOU, MISTER
CHAIR. COLLEAGUES, AB 157 IS A
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR AMENDING THE
BUDGET ACT. SPECIFICALLY, IT
MAKES A VARIETY OF AMENDMENTS
AND TECHNICAL CORRECTIONS TO THE
2024 BUDGET ACT. SPECIFIC
HIGHLIGHTS INCLUDE APPROPRIATION
OF $71 MILLION FOR THE ALISO
CANYON RECOVERY ACCOUNT FOR A
VARIETY OF LOCAL AIR QUALITY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPROVEMENTS, AND
RATEPAYER SUPPORT FOR THE ALISO
CANYON DELIVERY AREA, PROVIDING
FUNDING FOR A VARIETY OF
PRIORITY INVESTMENTS, INCLUDING
THE CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT, OUTREACH ACTIVITIES IN
PRISON PROGRAMING, AND THE
CALIFORNIA WINTER HABITAT
INCENTIVE PROGRAM, AMONG OTHERS.
IT AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO INCREASE EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY FOR INCREASED COSTS
RELATED TO THE REIMBURSEMENT OF
STOLEN FOOD AND CASH BENEFITS,
AND IT MAKES A VARIETY OF OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES AND
ADJUSTMENTS NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT THE BUDGET ACT OF
2024. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
WIENER. DISCUSSION AND DEBATE.
SENATOR NILO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'M GOING TO I'D LIKE
TO SPEAK TO THIS BILL AND REALLY
APPLIES TO THE REST OF THE
BUDGET BILLS. AND ALSO SO
PROPOSITION 25 WAS PROPOSED, WAS
PROPOSED BY THE MAJORITY PARTY
AS A PROMISE TO PASS A BUDGET ON
TIME IF THEY JUST DIDN'T HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE PRIORITIES OF THE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO WE
PESKY REPUBLICANS REPRESENT,
WHAT WE'VE SEEN REPEATEDLY AND
HAS BEEN WRITTEN BY DAN WALTERS
AND OTHERS, HAS BEEN A MERE
PLACEHOLDER BUDGET, DEVELOPED
LARGELY WITHOUT TRANSPARENCY, TO
BE AND ALWAYS IS, COMPLETED
LATER, LIKE TODAY. BUT FOR THE
PAGA RELATED ALLOCATIONS AND THE
MOUS, THESE BEALL BILLS DEAL
WITH ISSUES THAT LARGELY EXISTED
IN JUNE. SO THIS HEARING GIVES
PROOF TO THE FIB THAT WAS THAT
ON TIME BUDGET PASSED OVER TWO
MONTHS AGO. THIS IS NOTHING NEW
FOR ME. OF COURSE, I HAVE BEEN
REDUNDANTLY REDUNDANT IN MY
CRITICISM OF OUR BUDGET PROCESS
AND BY RIGHT COULD JUST OPPOSE
EVERYTHING BUT TO EXPLAIN AHEAD
OF TIME AND AVOID THE ADMONITION
OF RALPH WALDO EMERSON THAT A
FOOLISH CONSISTENCY IS THE
HOBGOBLIN OF LITTLE MINDS, I
WILL SUPPORT SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS THAT I FIND
NONETHELESS COMPELLING AND
IMPORTANT. BUT AS FOR AB 157, I
URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NILO. SENATOR STERN,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
IN IN FAVOR OF THIS MEASURE, AND
I JUST WANT TO, DELIVER MY
GRATITUDE BOTH TO THE BUDGET
CHAIR AND THE STAFF FOR HELPING
WORK THROUGH PENALTY FUNDING
THAT HAS BEEN BOTTLENECKED FOR
QUITE A WHILE NOW, THE DISASTER
IN ALISO CANYON WAS SEVERAL
YEARS AGO, BUT PEOPLE STILL HAVE
NOT BEEN MADE WHOLE, THE
MECHANICS, I THINK, ARE SOUND,
AND WE'RE GOING TO CUT PEOPLE'S
BILLS. $70 MILLION IN LOS
ANGELES, INSTEAD OF SENDING THAT
BACK TO THE GAS COMPANY. SO I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE GOOD FOR
ALL RATEPAYERS AND ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE AGGRIEVED MOST IN
THE LARGEST METHANE DISASTER IN
WESTERN HISTORY. SO I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR STERN. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE, SENATOR WIENER, YOU
MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO. GIL
NO. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALI. NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZO.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO HURTADO.
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN
WHEN? NO NILO. NO. OKUBO. NO
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO.
NO SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB. AYE WIENER. AYE.
WILK. NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 31 TO 9, THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 271. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 158, PRESENTED BY
SENATOR WIENER. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 158 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. AN ACT
RELATING TO THE STATE BUDGET AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
BUDGET BILL. SENATOR WIENER.
AYE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES. AB 158 IS A
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR AMENDING THE
BUDGET ACT. SPECIFICALLY, IT
MAKES A VARIETY OF AMENDMENTS
AND TECHNICAL CORRECTIONS TO THE
2022 AND 2023 BUDGET ACTS. SOME
HIGHLIGHTS INCLUDE AUTHORIZING
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
PROVIDE UP TO $3 MILLION IN
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS
TO THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION TO ADMINISTER
PROGRAMS RELATED TO ZERO
EMISSION SCHOOL BUS CHARGING OR
REFUELING INFRASTRUCTURE,
ADJUSTING THE FUNDING NEEDED TO
COVER DEBT SERVICE COSTS FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT HOUSING PROJECTS, AND
MAKING A VARIETY OF OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE,
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ON THE MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO, GIL. NØ.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. NÓ.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. NÓ. LAIRD.
AYE LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO NO. OCHOA
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO.
NO SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 31 TO 9, THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
ASK FOLKS TO PLEASE STAY HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS. WE HAVE A LONG,
LONG DAY AHEAD OF US. AND A LOT
OF MEASURES TO DISCUSS AND VOTE
ON AND WE NEED EVERYONE'S
COOPERATION FOR US TO KIND OF
GET GET THROUGH IT EFFICIENTLY.
SO PLEASE, EVERYONE, IF YOU CAN
PLEASE STAY IN THE CHAMBER. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM TWO 7271. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 176. EXCUSE ME.
272. ASSEMBLY BILL 176.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 176 BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET, AN ACT
RELATING TO EDUCATION, FINANCE
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION,
THEREFORE, TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. MEMBERS, PLEASE GIVE
SENATOR WIENER YOUR ATTENTION.
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES AB 176 IS
THE CHILD CARE PRESCHOOL K
THROUGH 12 EDUCATION AND HIGHER
EDUCATION OMNIBUS TRAILER BILL.
IT INCLUDES A REQUIREMENT FOR
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ON NEW BUILDING
REGULATIONS FOR DAYCARE CENTERS.
IT ALSO INCLUDES MOSTLY
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS TO PROPOSALS THAT
WERE ENACTED EARLIER THIS YEAR,
INCLUDING PRESCHOOL ENROLLMENT
FOR TWO YEAR OLDS TÊ K THROUGH
12. ATTENDANCE RECOVERY. THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHERS GRANT
PROGRAM, AND STREAMLINING
REPORTS FOR THE FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR SKINNER THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THIS
HAS BEEN A NUMBER OF THE
PROVISIONS HERE FOR OUR EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION HAVE BEEN
HARD FOUGHT AND ARE VERY
IMPORTANT, AND TO ALLOW US TO
REALIZE THE GAINS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN FUNDING TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR CHILDREN, 0 TO 4, HAVE
ADEQUATE EARLY CARE. AND WITH
THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE MEASURE? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SENATOR WIENER, YOU MAY
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALY DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE. OCHOA.
BORG. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. AYE WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. AYE. DALY GROVE. AYE
MENGIBAR. AYE ON A VOTE OF 39 TO
0, THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 273. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 177. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 177
BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET, AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR WIENER.
AYE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES. AB 177 IS THE
HEALTH OMNIBUS TRAILER BILL. IT
IMPLEMENTS A NEAR REAL TIME DATA
SYSTEM TO PROVIDE ELECTRONIC
INFORMATION TO HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS, FIRST RESPONDERS AND
OTHERS ON THE AVAILABILITY OF
BEDS AND HOSPITALS AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FACILITIES TO
AID IN PLACEMENT AND TIMELY
ACCESS TO TREATMENT. IT
IMPLEMENTS A MEDI-CAL MANAGED
CARE DIRECTED PAYMENT
REIMBURSEMENT METHODOLOGY TO
IMPROVE REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL. IT EXTENDS
THE EXISTING MORATORIUM OF
LICENSURE OF HOSPICE AGENCIES
FOR AN ADDITIONAL YEAR TO ALLOW
FOR THE PROMULGATION OF
REGULATIONS TO ADDRESS QUALITY
ISSUES RAISED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR, AND IT AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS TO
ADOPT EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
THROUGH JUNE 30TH, 2026
REGARDING TREATMENT OF
CONTRABAND IN STATE HOSPITALS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILLO. AYE.
OCHOA PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
AYE. WIENER. Ã. AYE WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THEN WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLL.
ALLEN. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. OCHOA. BORG. AYE
ALLEN. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBER. ALAN AYE. ON A VOTE OF
40 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES. I'D
LIKE TO ASK ALL THE MEMBERS TO
PLEASE STAY HERE IN THE CHAMBER
SO WE CAN COMPLETE OUR BUSINESS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 274. IS THAT WHAT WE JUST
DID? 274 TO FILE ITEM 275, THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 179. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ NÓ 274 IS NEXT UP.
74 274. THANK YOU. CORRECTION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 178 BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC RESOURCES AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
WIENER, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES AB 178 IS THE
RESOURCES TRAILER BILL. IT
INCLUDES A VARIETY OF ACTIONS TO
IMPLEMENT THE BUDGET. AMONG
OTHER THINGS, IT PROVIDES
CUSTOMERS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
UNDUE HARDSHIP, THE ABILITY TO
REQUEST GREATER PAYMENT PLAN
FLEXIBILITY BEYOND 12 MONTHS. IT
REDUCES THE REQUIRED MINIMUM
CONTRIBUTION AMOUNT FOR THE
WHALE TAIL FUND FROM 250,000 TO
200,000. IT RESTORES STATUTORY
LANGUAGE RECENTLY REPEALED,
AUTHORIZING CALRECYCLE TO
SOLICIT AND USE EXPERTISE
AVAILABLE IN OTHER STATE
AGENCIES FOR PURPOSES OF THE
TIRE RECYCLING ACT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR WIENER.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NO MICROPHONE'S
UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLASER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR. MIN AYE. MENGIBAR
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE SEYARTO. SKINNER. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. Ã. AYE WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL DALY.
GROVE AYE. JONES NGUYEN. NILO
SEYARTO. ON A VOTE OF 34 TO 0,
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 275. ASSEMBLY
BILL 179. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 179 BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACT RELATING TO STATE GOVERNMENT
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. SEN. WIENER. AYE. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES
AB 179 IS THE GENERAL GOVERNMENT
TRAILER BILL. IT INCLUDES A
VARIETY OF ACTIONS TO IMPLEMENT
THE BUDGET. AMONG OTHER THINGS,
IT MAKES VARIOUS TECHNICAL
CHANGES AND CONFORMING CHANGES
TO CONTINUE ENABLING VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS TO CONDUCT
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND
FINGERPRINTING. IT ESTABLISHES
THROUGH DECEMBER 31ST, 2030, THE
PROJECTED SURPLUS TEMPORARY
HOLDING ACCOUNT TO TEMPORARILY
HOLD FOR UP TO A YEAR. A PORTION
OF GENERAL FUND SURPLUS MONEY
FOR USE IN FUTURE FISCAL YEARS,
AND IT EXTENDS THE APPEALS
DEADLINE TO JANUARY FIRST, 2025
FOR APPLICATIONS TO THE FORCED
OR INVOLUNTARY STERILIZATION
COMPENSATION PROGRAM, AS WELL AS
EXTENDING THE PROGRAM THROUGH
JANUARY 1ST, 26. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR WIENER. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO
GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY DODD. AYE. HUESO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE JONES. AYE. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. NILO NØ. OCHOA
PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN ALVARADO. GILL
DALI. ALVARADO. GILL AYE. DALI.
GROVE WHEN? AYE OCHOA. SEYARTO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE LAST TIME. ALLEN. AYE DALI.
GROVE. OCHOA BORG. SEYARTO AYE.
A VOTE OF 35 TO 1. THE MEASURE
CARRIES. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 276. ASSEMBLY BILL 181.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 181 BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. SENATOR WIENER. AYE.
THANK YOU. MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. AB 181 IS THIS
YEAR'S MOU BILL. THE MEASURE
RATIFIES THREE EMPLOYEE
CONTRACTS BETWEEN THE STATE AND
THE HIGHWAY PATROL OFFICERS, THE
STATE FIREFIGHTERS AND THE
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS. THE NEW
CONTRACT WITH THE CHP OFFICERS
IS A THREE YEAR CONTRACT THAT
INCLUDES NEW LEVELS OF SENIORITY,
PAY AND INCREASES PAY FOR
OFFICERS WITH SPECIFIC
PROFESSIONAL SKILLS OR TRAINING.
THE MEASURE ALSO RATIFIES A TWO
YEAR CONTRACT WITH CALIFORNIA'S
FIREFIGHTERS, IMPLEMENTING
PROVISIONS THAT REDUCE THE
CURRENT 72 HOUR WORKWEEK TO A 66
HOUR WORKWEEK. ALSO IN THIS BILL
IS A THREE YEAR CONTRACT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS THAT
INCLUDES SALARY INCREASES
RANGING FROM 3 TO 12%, DEPENDING
ON THE CLASSIFICATION AND THE
EMPLOYEE'S SALARY RANGE. TO
RETAIN SENIOR EMPLOYEES, THE
CONTRACT CONTAINS LONGEVITY PAY
INCREASES FOR EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE
OVER 17 YEARS OF STATE SERVICE.
FINALLY, THE BILL INCLUDES A
2.6% GENERAL SALARY INCREASE FOR
STATE JUDGES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR WIENER. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. AYE HURTADO. AYE. JONES
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NEILA.
OKUBO AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE. AYE. NEILA AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 40 TO 0, THE MEASURE
CARRIES. THAT COMPLETES OUR
BUDGET BILLS THAT I UNDERSTAND.
SENATOR WIENER, YOUR MICROPHONE
IS STILL UP, BUT I THINK YOU'RE
SET. OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO SECOND READING FILE. THE
SECOND READING FILE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ THE SECOND READING
FILE. ASSEMBLY BILL 863 1113
2250, 22, 63, 24, 60, 26, 29,
28, 51, 22, 43. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, PURSUANT TO JOINT
RULE 33.1, JOINT RULE 61 WILL BE
SUSPENDED TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
BILLS 1205, 1831, 1843 AND 2095
TO BE AMENDED AFTER THE
DEADLINE. THIS REQUEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
SENATOR GONZALEZ, FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, THERE IS
A RESOLUTION AT THE DESK
REQUESTING PERMISSION TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE 61 FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ALLOWING ASSEMBLY BILLS 98, 1252
AND 2930 TO BE AMENDED AFTER THE
DEADLINE. THE REQUESTS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
SENATOR. CIERTO, FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? I RISE
BECAUSE WE OPPOSE THIS ACTION.
WE HAVE RULES FOR A REASON THAT
WE ESTABLISHED BEFORE WE STARTED
OUR LEGISLATIVE SESSION. AND
CONTINUING TO BREAK THOSE RULES
SO THAT WE CAN FIT THESE THINGS
IN, IS UNFAIR TO THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE IN THIS ROOM THAT HAVE OTHER
THINGS THAT THEY WERE PLANNING
ON GETTING TO LATER ON THIS
WEEK. THANK YOU, SENATOR. IT'S
AN UNDEBATABLE MOTION, BUT WE
HAVE A REQUEST FROM THE MAJORITY
LEADER TO SUSPEND THE RULES.
THAT'S A YES VOTE. SENATOR
CIERTOS SUGGESTING A NO VOTE
WITH THAT. SECRETARY, CAN YOU
READ THE RESOLUTION? PLEASE
RESOLVE THAT JOINT RULE 61 BE
DISPENSED WITH. ALL RIGHT,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GILL NØ.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY I ATKINS,
I BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER I
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. I
CORTEZ. AYE. DALI DODD. DALI.
NÓ. DODD. AYE DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 9, THE JOINT
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE BACK TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER. SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS,
THERE IS A RESOLUTION AT THE
DESK REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE 61 AND 62 A
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ALLOWING
ASSEMBLY BILLS 98 AND 1205 TO BE
HEARD IN POLICY AND FISCAL
COMMITTEE AFTER THE DEADLINE.
THESE REQUESTS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
SENATOR SECRETO, SAME OBJECTION.
WE CAN SUBSTITUTE THE RULE.
THANK YOU SIR. LET'S HAVE THE
RESOLUTION BE READ. RESOLVED
THAT JOINT RULE 60, JOINT RULE
61 AND 62 BE DISPENSED WITH. ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE PREVIOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS RESOLUTION?
SEEING NO OBJECTION. AYES 31.
NOES NINE. JOINT RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
SENATOR ANGELO, I'M TOLD THAT
YOU ARE ASKING FOR RECOGNITION.
IS THAT MISTAKEN? I'M SORRY, MR.
PRESIDENT. WHAT WAS THAT? I WAS
TOLD THAT YOU WANTED RECOGNITION
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
OH, YES, I DID. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR RESPONDING TO THAT.
WE'RE HERE TO HELP. WE'RE HERE
TO HELP. ON BEHALF OF THE
AUTHOR, I'D LIKE TO REMOVE AB
2471 BY ASSEMBLYMAN JIM
PATTERSON FROM SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE DESK WILL NOTE.
THANK YOU, SIR. ALL RIGHT.
ANYTHING FURTHER ON? MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NO MICROPHONES UP AT THE MOMENT,
WE'RE GOING TO SENATOR PADILLA.
FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE?
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I WANT
TO PULL FILE ITEM 300 AB 2381 BY
BONTA FROM SPECIAL CONSENT. THE
DESK WILL NOTE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS
MEMBERS. WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. I KNOW
THERE'LL BE MORE LATER IN THE
DAY, BUT THOSE ARE FILED ITEMS
21, 29, AND 37. IF YOU WANT TO
FOLLOW ALONG AT HOME. FIRST ONE
UP IS FILE ITEM 21. THIS IS SB
782. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 782 BY SENATOR
LEMON. AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT. SENATOR LEMON THANK
YOU, PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES.
SB 72 782 REQUIRES AN ANNUAL
REPORT WITH AGGREGATE
DEMOGRAPHIC DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION OF INDIVIDUALS
APPOINTED TO THE STATE'S BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR I'M. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
DALLI EGGMAN. GROVE SUGIARTO.
WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. DALLI
EGGMAN. AYE. GROVE SEYARTO. WILK
ON A VOTE OF 36 TO 0. THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 29. SB
1061. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1061 BY SENATOR
LYMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
CONSUMER DEBT. SENATOR LEMON,
THANK YOU. MEMBERS, I PRESENT SB
1061, WHICH SEEKS TO REMOVE
MEDICAL DEBT FROM CONSUMER
CREDIT REPORTS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS REDUCE THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL, EXEMPTING MEDICAL
CREDIT CARDS AND SPECIALTY
LOANS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
LEMON. MEASURE ANY DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
NØ. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO. NÓ. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL. I DON'T KNOW,
ALLEN. AYE. WHEN NILO. NO OKUBO.
NO ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 8, THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. AND FOR THOSE
KEEPING TRACK AT HOME. THAT'S
THAT'S TWO FOR THE MISS
POPULARITY. SENATOR LEMON, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
37. THIS IS SENATE BILL 1318.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1318 BY SENATOR WAHAB. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUPIL HEALTH.
SENATOR WAHAB. THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. S.B. 1318 CHILD SUICIDE
PREVENTION IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. THE BILL ENSURES
THAT STUDENTS EXPERIENCING A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES RECEIVE CARE FROM A
QUALIFIED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL. SB 1318 ENJOYS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO,
GILL. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
NØ. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MAGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. NØ. OCHOA
PADILLA. OCHOA. NO. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. AYE ALVARADO. GILL WHEN.
ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 6, THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
THE MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING.
ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING. FIRST
UP IS FINAL ITEM 48, FOLLOWED BY
FILE ITEM 62, 63 AND 68 WILL
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 48 AB 2865.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2865 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WENDY CARRILLO. AN ACT RELATING
TO PUPIL INSTRUCTION. WE WILL
TURN TO OUR EARLY LEADER FOR
MISS POPULARITY, SENATOR LIMON.
THANK YOU. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2865, WHICH AIMS TO CHANGE
ENSURING THAT THE STATE WHICH
AIMS TO CHANGE THAT BY ENSURING
THAT THE STUDENTS LEARN AND
UNDERSTAND THE EFFECTS OF
ALCOHOL, WE CAN HAVE THAT. THE
EXCUSE ME, WHICH AIMS TO CHANGE
THE UNDERSTANDING FOR STUDENTS
IN TERMS OF THE IMPACTS THAT
ALCOHOL CAN HAVE ON THEIR BODY
LONG TERM. THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 40. NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 62.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2293.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2293 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS. AN ACT RELATING TO JOINT
POWERS. SENATOR DURAZO IS
PRESENTING. PLEASE GIVE HER YOUR
ATTENTION. MEMBERS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS, THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW A 500 AND 1C3
ORGANIZATION TO JOIN A JOINT
POWERS AGREEMENT TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. REPLICATES
AN EXISTING IMPROVING MECHANISM
THAT CURRENTLY ALLOWS A 500 1C3
TO PARTNER WITH THE JPA WHEN
PROVIDING SERVICES TO ZERO
ADMISSION EMISSION TRANSMISSION
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
AND RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DURAZO. ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. SENATORS IN THE
GALLERY TODAY WE ARE JOINED BY
THE TRIBAL LEADERS OF THE FORT
YUMA INDIAN TRIBE. THE PIT RIVER
TRIBE, AND THE TORRES MARTINEZ
DESERT CAHUILLA INDIANS. LET'S
PLEASE GIVE A WARM SENATE
WELCOME TO THE GUESTS THAT WE
HAVE HERE IN THE GALLERY. THANK
YOU. COMMISSIONER, WELCOME TO
THE SENATE. THIS IS ONE OF OUR
QUIETER DAYS. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO ASSEMBLY.
THIRD READING, THIS IS FILE ITEM
63. ASSEMBLY BILL 2375.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2375 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWENTHAL. ENACT TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. SENATOR RUBIO
PRESENTING SENATOR RUBIO THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2375 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL. THIS
BILL IS INTENDED TO ADDRESS
DRINKING AND SPIKING OF DRINKS
COMMONLY KNOWN AS ROOFING. AB
2375 SIMPLY REQUIRES TYPE 48
LICENSED ESTABLISHMENTS TO
PROVIDE A LID TO A PATRON'S
DRINK UPON THEIR REQUEST TO POST
A SIGN ALERTING GUESTS THAT IT
IS AVAILABLE, AND THIS WILL HELP
PERPETRATORS INTENDING TO COMMIT
CRIMES AND FROM SPIKING DRINKS
AND COMMITTING THE ULTIMATE
CRIME OF ASSAULTING AND RAPING
VICTIMS. WHILE INCAPACITATED.
WITH UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
RUBIO. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? THIS IS A SENATOR
ALVARADO GIL. THANK YOU. I RISE
WITH NEUTRAL SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL. ALTHOUGH I DO SUPPORT THE
PREMISE OF THIS. I BELIEVE THAT
WE ARE ENTRUSTED WITH MAKING
LAWS THAT DO NOT USE SLANG
TERMS, BUT ACTUAL FACTUAL TERMS.
THIS BILL, UNFORTUNATELY, HAS A
CONNOTATION OF ROOFING THAT
APPLIES TO A ROHYPNOL DRUG. WE
KNOW NOW THAT THERE ARE VARIOUS
DRUGS THAT ARE CAUSE
INTOXICATION, AND I DO NOT
BELIEVE A PLASTIC LID WITH A
SIGN SAYING DON'T GET ROOFIED.
DRINK LIDS ARE AVAILABLE WILL
HELP TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC
AROUND WHAT INTOXICATION THROUGH
DRUGS IS. SO ALTHOUGH I DON'T
OPPOSE THIS BILL, I DO OPPOSE
USING LANGUAGE THAT ARE SLANG
TERMS IN OFFICIAL LEGISLATION.
THAT ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE. SENATOR
RUBIO, YOU MAY CLOSE. YEAH.
WELL, THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GIVE
OPTIONS TO THOSE THAT NEED IT.
SO WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THIS WAS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY. ALL RIGHT. NO
OBJECTION TO THAT OKAY. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL SEEING NONE. AYES 40. NÓ
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
68. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3227.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 3227 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ AND RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
ATKINS, PLEASE GIVE SENATOR
ATKINS YOUR ATTENTION. MEMBERS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 3227 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ ON THIS SUPPORT, SUPPORT
BILL. IT CREATES A NEW FIVE YEAR
EXEMPTION IN THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT, SEQUA
FOR ROUTINE MAINTENANCE OF
STORMWATER CHANNELS THAT ARE
FULLY CONCRETE OR HAVE
CONVEYANCE CAPACITY OF LESS THAN
100 YEAR STORM EVENT. IT CUTS
THE RED TAPE TO ENSURE TIMELY
UPKEEP OF ESSENTIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR ATKINS.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTIONS.
THAT'S 40 ZERO ON THE URGENCY,
40 ZERO ON THE MEASURE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, NEXT UP, OUR FILE ITEM
77, 82, 86. AND 96 WILL BEGIN
NEXT WITH FILE ITEM 77. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 1819. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1819
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON AND
ACCORDING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE OUR
FAVORITE SENATOR, SENATOR LEÓN.
WELL, THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON, TO
PRESENT AB 1890 1819, WHICH
ALLOWS FOR THE CREATION OF
SPECIAL INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS IN AREAS CATEGORIZED
AS HIGH OR VERY HIGH. FIRE FIRE.
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES. THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AS EXPECTED. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE, THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTION. AYES
40. NÓ ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 8280 AB
1801. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 1801 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON AND ACT RELATING
TO HOUSING. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1801, WHICH WILL PROVIDE CLARITY
TO EXISTING LAW BY ALLOWING
NONPROFITS THE ABILITY TO BUILD
THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE BUILDINGS
AND OFFICE SPACE ON THE SAME
SITES AS THEIR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING COMPLEX. CURRENT LAW IS
UNCLEAR ON WHETHER OR NOT
CALIFORNIA NONPROFITS CAN
CONSTRUCT THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICE SPACE ON THE SAME
PROPERTY TO COMBAT THE GROWING
HOUSING CRISIS, NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
BEEN ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
CONSTRUCTING AND OFFERING
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING, INCLUDING
PERMANENT AND TEMPORARY OPTIONS
TO FACILITATE STABILITY, SAFETY,
AND ACCESS TO SERVICES. THIS
BILL SEEKS TO SIMPLY CLARIFY AND
SUPPORT THESE VITAL EFFORTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. AYE. AYES 40. NØ
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 86. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2229. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2229
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUPIL
INSTRUCTION. SENATOR RUBIO,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. TODAY
I RISE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON TO PRESENT AB 20
229, ALSO KNOWN AS YOUR PERIOD
ACT, WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS RECEIVE MENSTRUAL
HEALTH EDUCATION, WHICH THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION HAS
FRAMED AS A HUMAN RIGHT ISSUE.
AB 2229 IS A BILL THAT WILL HELP
DISMANTLE HARMFUL STIGMAS ABOUT
MENSTRUATION AND IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES, AND SUPPORT THE
PERSONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
CONFIDENCE OF OUR YOUNG
INDIVIDUALS. THIS BILL WAS
BROUGHT TO US BY A 16 YEAR OLD
YOUNG LADY. SYRIA. I'M GOING TO
TRY TO SAY THE NAMES SRINIVASAN,
WHICH IS TO ME AN EXAMPLE OF
CALIFORNIA'S BRIGHT FUTURE. WE
HAVE OUR YOUNG INDIVIDUALS
GETTING ENGAGED IN LEGISLATION.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR RUBIO. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO. GIL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. I AM IN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO. AYE. OCHOA AYE. PADILLA.
AYE PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBER.
ALLEN. AYE. ON A VOTE OF 40 TO
0. THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM 96. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 3089. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3089
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES-SAWYER.
AN ACT TO STATE GOVERNMENT AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFOR. SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER, I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
3089 A CALIFORNIA APOLOGY ACT
FOR THE PERPETRATION OF GROSS
HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS AND
CRIMES AGAINST HUMANITY WITH
SPECIAL CONSIDERATION FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN SLAVES AND
THEIR DESCENDANTS. I, ALONG WITH
MR. JONES-SAWYER, HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING ON THE
REPARATIONS TASK FORCE FOR TWO
YEARS AND I'M VERY PROUD OF THE
REPORT THAT WAS PRODUCED BY THE
BODY AS REQUIRED BY STATUTE. THE
TASK FORCE WAS REQUIRED TO
INCLUDE IN ITS FINDINGS HOW THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL OFFER A
FORMAL APOLOGY ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
PERPETRATION OF GROSS HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS AND CRIMES
AGAINST HUMANITY ON AFRICAN
AMERICAN SLAVES AND THEIR
DESCENDENTS. THIS BILL IS A
COMPLETION OF THAT CHARGE BY
OFFERING A FORMAL APOLOGY FOR
THE PAST WRONGS. CALIFORNIA WILL
JOIN NINE OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
ENACTED SOME FORM OF APOLOGY FOR
THEIR ROLE IN THE SLAVE TRADE.
IT'S A LONG PAST TIME FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
ACKNOWLEDGE HIS ROLE IN
PROMOTING AND FACILITATING SLAVE
ERA POLICIES, AND TO AFFIRM ITS
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT AND
UPLIFT THE DESCENDANTS OF
ENSLAVED PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
HARMED BY THE ENDURING LEGACY OF
STATE SANCTIONED HORROR AND
TERROR. EVEN THOUGH CALIFORNIA
ENTERED THE UNION AS A FREE
STATE, EVERY BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT FROM TOP DOWN HAD HIS
HAND IN PERPETRATING THE
OPPRESSION OF BLACK
CALIFORNIANS. THIS BILL IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONFRONT THOSE
TRUTHS IN A MEANINGFUL WAY. I
THANK YOU, MY COLLEAGUES, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR BRADFORD, ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA. AYE
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. MCGUIRE.
AYE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA
PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL DALY. GROVE HURTADO. AYE
JONES. LIMÓN AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
OCHOA. BOG CIERTO. ON A VOTE OF
32 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE PLANNING TO GO
TILL 1230 FOR OUR LUNCH AND
COMMITTEE BREAK. SO THE NEXT
ITEMS THAT WE ARE PLANNING TO
ADVANCE FOR DISCUSSION ARE FILE
ITEM 99, 100, 102 AND 106. WE'LL
BEGIN NEXT WITH FILE ITEM 99.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2120.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2120 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN. AN ACT RELATING TO
TRESPASS. SENATOR. CIERTO. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS,
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT AB 2120
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN. WHEN A DEBTOR HAS FAILED
TO REPAY THEIR DEBT, THE LEGAL
OWNER WHO OWNS WHO HOLDS THE
NOTE COLLATERAL MAY ISSUE A
REPOSSESSION ORDER. AB 2110 2120
CLARIFIES THAT WHILE
REPOSSESSORS ARE EXEMPT FROM
TRESPASS LAWS, THEY ARE ONLY FOR
THE ABILITY TO BE ON THE
PROPERTY UPON COMPLETION, THE
REPOSSESSOR MUST LEAVE THE
PROPERTY IMMEDIATELY. THIS BILL
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT,
AND I RESPECT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR CIERTO. ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS. AYES 40.
NÓ ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 100. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2134.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2134 BY SENATE MEMBER
MURATSUCHI. AN ACT RELATING TO
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES. SENATOR
CORTEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2134, WHICH STRENGTHENS EXISTING
STATUTE TO PROTECT EDUCATOR SICK
LEAVE AFTER A JOB CHANGE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE HAVE BEEN
MANY INSTANCES WHERE NEW
EMPLOYEES, NEW EMPLOYERS HAVE
MISINTERPRETED THE LAW,
RESULTING IN NEW EMPLOYEES
LOSING THEIR ACCRUED SICK TIME.
WHEN THEY CHANGE JOBS. NO
TEACHER OR CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE SHOULD HAVE TO WORRY
THAT THEY WILL LOSE THEIR EARNED
SICK TIME JUST BECAUSE THEY
MOVED TO A DIFFERENT SCHOOL
DISTRICT. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR CORTEZ,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GO. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR MEN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEGATO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AYE. ALLEN.
AYE. JONES AYE. MENGIBAR AYE.
IT'S A VOTE OF 40 TO 0. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 102. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
99. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 99 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CONNOLLY. AN ACT TO
PESTICIDES. SENATOR STERN IS
PRESENTING. YEAH. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE CALTRANS TO USE
LESS INVASIVE AND HARMFUL
METHODS OF CONTROLLING PESTS BY
OUR ROADSIDES, IF NECESSARY. IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE THEM TO STOP
SPRAYING, BUT WHEN THERE ARE
MORE EFFECTIVE USES LIKE BRUSH
CLEARING AND OTHER OTHER TOOLS
THAT DON'T TAKE AWAY AS MUCH
HABITAT OR CREATE AS MUCH
WILDFIRE RISK, AS WELL AS HAVE
IMPACTS ON GOOD PESTS AND GOOD
WILDLIFE. THEY'LL BE USING THOSE
TOOLS GOING FORWARD.
RESPECTFULLY, I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? I SEE A MICROPHONE UP
FROM SENATOR CORTESE. NO OKAY.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DADDY. NO.
DODD. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO.
OKUBO. NO. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. NO SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN AYE. ATKINS BRADFORD. DODD
GLAZER. ON A VOTE OF 27 TO 9,
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 106.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1899.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1899 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
CERVANTES AND AQUILINA. COURTS
SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. AB 1899 HAS
TO DO WITH GENDER EXPRESSION
REPRESENTED ON JURIES. I ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN I. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
LAIRD. AYE LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLEY GROVE. JONES
NGUYEN. NILO NILO. Ã. OCHOA
BOGUE. SEYARTO. ON A VOTE OF 34
TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO DO ONE
MORE BILL BEFORE OUR COMMITTEE
AND LUNCH BREAK. THE NEXT ONE UP
IS ITEM 112 AB 2462. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2462
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON. AN
ACT RELATING TO ENERGY. SENATOR
EGGMAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AB
2462 ASKS THE CPUC IN THEIR
ANNUAL 696 REPORT TO INCLUDE
CURRENT TRENDS AND THEIR IMPACT
ON COST. I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MEMBERS. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS? SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO AYE. OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO. AYE.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER.
SKINNER. AYE. IT'S A VOTE OF 40
TO 0. THE MEASURE PASSES. OKAY,
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO BREAK
NOW FOR COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND
FOR LUNCH. IT'S A ONE HOUR
BREAK. I KNOW WE HAVE SOME
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH SENATOR WAHAB.
THANK YOU. SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
WILL IMMEDIATELY BEGIN AT THE
BREAK IN ROOM 113 TO HEAR ONE
BILL, SB 285 BY SENATOR ALLEN.
SO, MEMBERS, PLEASE MAKE YOUR
WAY THERE. NEXT, RECOGNIZE
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WILL MEET IN ROOM 112
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING BANKING
COMMITTEE. SO I RECOMMEND THAT
MEMBERS OF SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IMMEDIATELY EAT LUNCH
AND THEN PROCEED TO ROOM 112.
I'M TOLD THE BANKING COMMITTEE
SHOULDN'T LAST THAT LONG. WE'LL
SEE. WE'LL CHECK WITH SENATOR
LEHMAN FOR A REPORT. SENATOR
LEHMAN ON THAT NOTE, THE BANKING
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO BE MEETING
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE CALL OF
RECESS. AND WE ARE ASKING THAT
IF YOU ARE ON THE BANKING
COMMITTEE, YOU ACTUALLY COME
VOTE BEFORE YOU EAT IN ORDER TO
ALLOW THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
WE WILL MEET IN ROOM 112. ALL
RIGHT. AND FINALLY, WE HAVE
SENATOR ALLEN, THE SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING IMMEDIATELY
AFTER JUDICIARY. WE'RE GOING TO
BE HEARING ONE. SORRY. EXCUSE
ME. PUBLIC SAFETY. PUBLIC
SAFETY. THAT'S GOING TO BE IN
ROOM 113 RIGHT AFTER PUBLIC
SAFETY. WE'LL BE HEARING SENATOR
PORTANTINO'S SB. 551 SENATOR
ECK. ALL RIGHT. JUST A QUICK
REVIEW FOR THE FOLKS THAT ARE
PAYING ATTENTION. PUBLIC SAFETY
WILL BE MEETING IMMEDIATELY UPON
OUR RECESS IN 113, FOLLOWED BY
EC IN 113. BANKING WILL BEGIN
IMMEDIATELY AFTER OUR RECESS IN
ROOM 112, FOLLOWED BY JUDICIARY
IN ROOM 112. MEMBERS HAVE AN
ENJOYABLE COMMITTEE HEARING AND
LUNCH. WE'LL SEE YOU IN AN HOUR.
OKAY. MEMBERS CAN ASK ALL THE
SENATORS TO RETURN TO THE SENATE
CHAMBERS, PLEASE. SO WE CAN
BEGIN. RIGHT. OKAY. THE SENATE
WILL COME OUT OF RECESS IN 60S.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
I COUNT IT. THE SENATE WILL COME
BACK FROM RECESS. THANK YOU,
ALL, MEMBERS, FOR BEING PROMPT
AND BACK HERE IN THE CHAMBER. SO
LET ME WE WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND TAKE UP A BILL, AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. SO I
HAVE SENATOR ATKINS Þ SENATOR
SKINNER HERE. SENATOR SKINNER IS
HERE. OKAY. MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN AT FILE ITEM 113. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2483. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2483
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TÍNH. AN ACT
RELATING TO POST-CONVICTION
PROCEEDINGS. SENATOR SKINNER,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. PLEASE GIVE
SENATOR SKINNER. YOUR ATTENTION.
MEMBERS THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, AB 2483
MAKES THE PROVIDES FOR OUR
COURTS STANDARDIZED GUIDELINES
AND CONSISTENCY WITH OUR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF RESENTENCING
LAWS THAT ARE ALREADY ON THE
BOOKS. SO THIS DOES NOT CHANGE
ANY SENTENCING LAW. IT PURELY
SETS THE GUIDELINES ON
RESENTENCING PROCEDURES. THIS
IS, BACKED BY JUDICIAL COUNCIL
AND OTHERS AND WAS CAME OUT OF
THE COMMITTEE ON THE REVISION OF
THE PENAL CODES RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR.
AYE VOTE. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY ATKINS. AYE
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER BRADFORD.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DEL
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE.
HURTADO JONES. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MAGUIRE MENGIBAR.
I'M IN. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NILO
OCHOA. PADILLA PORTANTINO. ROTH
RUBIO. SEYARTO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. STERN UMBERG.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK.
SEN. SKINNER SEN. SKINNER. MOVES
A CALL. MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE 29.1 D, THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ARE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES. FILE ITEM FOR SB 1456.
SENATOR SKINNER, DO YOU MEAN TO
HAVE YOUR MICROPHONE UP? OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. NOTHING ELSE ON
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. ALL
RIGHT. SO HERE'S WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO GO NEXT. MEMBERS. WE
ARE GOING TO JUMP AROUND A
LITTLE BIT WITH WITH PURPOSE,
WHICH IS THAT WE DO HAVE MEMBERS
OFF THE FLOOR. SO WE ARE GOING
TO BE PUTTING BILLS ON CALL. SO
WE'RE GOING TO COLLECT UP WHAT
WE THINK ARE BILLS THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS CONSENT,
AND PUT THEM ASIDE UNTIL WE CAN
GET A FULL HOUSE, WHICH WILL
ALLOW FOR MUCH MORE EFFICIENCY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO TO BILLS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ROLL
CALL VOTES ON. AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO JUMP AROUND THE FILE A
LITTLE BIT. BUT I'LL GIVE YOU A
PREVIEW OF THE ORDER IN WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THEM UP. SO
THE ORDER IS FILE ITEM 117
FOLLOWED BY 137 146 150 AND 157.
SO THAT'S THE NEXT FIVE BILLS
UP. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
FILE ITEM 117. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 2783. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2783 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ. AN ACT
RELATING TO THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED PORT DISTRICT. SENATOR
ATKINS, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2783. THIS BILL IMPLEMENTS Kò
REFORMS THAT WILL IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY, ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT AT THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO. SINCE INTRODUCING THE
BILL, THE AUTHOR HAS TAKEN HAS
WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND OPPOSITION TO
AMEND THE MEASURE. THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HAVE
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS SUPPORT. SUPPORT
BILL. THANK YOU. SENATOR ATKINS,
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO. GIL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. BECKER. AYE
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LEMON
AYE. MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR I'M IN.
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO AYE. OCHOA. BORG. AYE.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE SENATOR ATKINS MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 137. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1799.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1799 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACKSON. AN ACT RELATING TO
CHILD ABUSE. SENATOR WIENER.
AYE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1799 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON. THIS BILL ALLOWS
MANDATED REPORTERS TO REPORT
CASES OF GENERAL NEGLECT TO ONE
OR MORE COMMUNITY BASED AGENCIES
OR SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT WILL
PROVIDE THE PARENT GUARDIAN OR
INDIAN CUSTODIAN OF THE CHILD
WITH SERVICES AND SUPPORT THE
REPORT, AND SUPPORTS THAT THE
REPORTER BELIEVES WILL IMPROVE
THE CONDITIONS IMPACTING THE
WELFARE OF THE CHILD. THE BILL
AUTHORIZES A MANDATED REPORTER
TO MAKE THIS REPORT. IN ADDITION
TO, OR IN LIEU OF REPORTING TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR THE WELFARE
DEPARTMENT, AND INSTANCES OF
GENERAL NEGLECT. TO BE CLEAR,
UNDER THIS BILL, MANDATED
REPORTERS CAN STILL REPORT CASES
OF NEGLECT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
THE CHILD WELFARE DEPARTMENT.
THE CURRENT DEFINITION OF
GENERAL GENERAL NEGLECT IS
OVERLY BROAD AND CAPTURES
SITUATIONS THAT CHILD PROTECTION
AGENCY HOTLINE WORKERS TYPICALLY
SCREEN OUT WITH THE CURRENT
STANDARD OF REPORTING MANDATED
REPORTERS OVER REPORT INSTANCES
OF SUSPECTED NEGLECT DUE TO
THEIR FEAR OF PROSECUTION. AS A
RESULT, THE MAJORITY OF THE
CALLS THAT THE CHILD PROTECTION
HOTLINE RECEIVES ARE FOR THE
CATCH ALL CATEGORY OF NEGLECT,
AND INCLUDING CASES OF POVERTY
OR LACK OF RESOURCES IN
CALIFORNIA, THE LRO FINDS THAT
OF CHILDREN BORN IN 1999,
APPROXIMATELY 50% OF BLACK AND
INDIGENOUS CHILDREN WILL HAVE
SOME LEVEL OF CHILD WELFARE
INVOLVEMENT BY THE AGE OF 18 DUE
TO BIAS, A LACK OF STANDARD
EDUCATION, AND THE PRESSURE OF
LIABILITY. MANY OF THESE
REFERRALS ARE DUE TO RACE,
ETHNICITY OR INCOME STATUS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WIENER. I SEE
MICROPHONES UP FROM SENATOR
RUBIO AND SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS, SENATOR RUBIO, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, AS AN
AVID ADVOCATE FOR VICTIMS AND
CHILDREN, I UNFORTUNATELY RISE
TODAY WITH CONCERNS ON AB 1799.
I'VE HEARD FROM PROPONENTS AND I
DO UNDERSTAND THE INTENT OF THE
BILL. AND I UNDERSTAND THAT 80%
OF CASES SOMETIMES ARE NOT
SUBSTANTIATED. BUT I WILL SUBMIT
THAT FOR THE 20% THAT ARE
SUBSTANTIATED, THAT MAY MEAN A
LIFE SAVED. HOWEVER, AS WE'RE
SPEAKING RIGHT NOW, I JUST CAN'T
HELP BUT THINK OF ALL THE
CHILDREN THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING HARMED, ABUSED, STARVED,
AND MANY INNOCENT LIVES ARE
LOST. AND I WANTED TO SHARE WITH
YOU THAT SOMETIMES WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT GENERAL NEGLECT, THAT
MEANS DIFFERENT THINGS TO
DIFFERENT PEOPLE. AND WHEN WE'RE
ASKED TO NOT REPORT AND SEND IT
OVER TO OTHER AGENCIES THAT ARE
NOT NECESSARILY TRAINED OR DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO TAKE CARE
OF THIS ISSUE, I BELIEVE WE'RE
PUTTING CHILDREN IN HARM'S WAY.
IF MANDATED REPORTERS ARE GOING
TO REPORT ABUSE OR NEGLECT.
SOMETIMES, LIKE I SAID, EVEN AS
PROFESSIONALS, THEY MISS THE
SIGNS THAT HAVE LED TO DEATH.
I'M GOING TO BRING UP THE CASE
OF GABRIEL FERNANDEZ, FOR
EXAMPLE, THAT AT LEAST FOUR
ADULTS THAT WERE MEANT TO BE
PROFESSIONALS SAW SOME OF THE
ABUSE THAT WAS HAPPENING, AND
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS JUST GENERAL
NEGLECT. AND AT THE END OF THE
DAY, THAT LITTLE BOY SUFFERED
THE CONSEQUENCE OF A STARVATION,
TORTURE AND SO MANY OTHER THINGS
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED.
BUT IT'S THAT DEFINITION OF
GENERAL NEGLECT THAT COULD BE
VERY HARMFUL TO CHILDREN WHEN
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT
MEANS. AGAIN, MY POINT HERE IS
THAT EVEN PROFESSIONALS MISS THE
SIGNS OF GENERAL NEGLECT WHEN IT
ACTUALLY WAS ABUSED. SO I SAY
THAT WHY CREATE A SYSTEM WHERE
WE DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES? WHY
NOT FIX THE SYSTEM WE HAVE? THIS
WEEK ON THE FLOOR, WE VOTED FOR
AB 1913 THAT INTENDS TO DO JUST
THAT. FIGURE OUT HOW TO INCREASE
THE PROFESSIONALISM AND THE YOU
KNOW, FOR OUR PROFESSIONALS THAT
ARE ALREADY MANDATED REPORTERS
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT MEANS,
HOW TO REPORT. I AM A TEACHER
AND I'M A MANDATED REPORTER, AND
I CANNOT REMEMBER A TIME THAT
THEY SET US DOWN TO EXPLAIN TO
US WHAT TO LOOK FOR AND WHAT TO
DO. AGAIN THIS BILL, AB 1913
THAT WE VOTED ON THIS WEEK WILL
ATTEMPT TO DO THAT. I HAVE A LOT
OF SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
COMING TO ME DURING THIS TIME,
BEGGING FOR FUNDING SERVICES
BECAUSE THEY'RE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY. AND NOW WE'RE GOING
TO PUNT UP ALL THESE CASES TO
OTHER PEOPLE THAT MAY NOT HAVE
THE RESOURCES. THE CAPACITY OR
THE EXPERTISE TO SAVE THIS,
THESE CHILDREN. AND AGAIN, TO BE
CLEAR, MY ISSUE IS WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT GENERAL NEGLECT, WE'RE
REALLY BEING SUBJECTIVE BECAUSE
THAT MEANS DIFFERENT THINGS TO
DIFFERENT PEOPLE. WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CHILDREN, WE
CANNOT TAKE THAT CHANCE OF
SOMEONE MISSING THE SIGNS.
CHILD, AFTER CHILD HAS BEEN
HARMED AND EVEN KILLED BECAUSE
PEOPLE THOUGHT IT WAS GENERAL
NEGLECT. SO I AM REALLY
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO PUTTING IT
OFF TO SOMEONE RIGHT NOW THAT
MAY NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES. THE
EXPERTISE, AND I JUST, YOU KNOW,
CRY INSIDE FOR THOSE CHILDREN
RIGHT NOW THAT NEED OUR HELP.
AND WHEN WE DO REFER IT TO THE
PROPER AGENCIES, AT LEAST THERE
MIGHT BE A VISIT. SOME OF THE
KIDS THAT ARE BEING HARMED TODAY
REQUIRE THAT ONE HOME VISIT THAT
MAY SAVE THEM. WE ALL REMEMBER
THAT FAMILY THAT HAD ABOUT 13
CHILDREN FROM THE OUTSIDE. THEY
LOOKED LIKE A PERFECT FAMILY IN
PICTURES IN THEIR OUTINGS, AND
YET THEY WERE BEING TORTURED
INSIDE THE HOME. THEY WERE
STARVED. THEY WERE NOT FED, THEY
WERE ABUSED, THEY WERE HARMED.
AND NO ONE SAW THAT BECAUSE IT
LOOKED REALLY NICE FROM THE
OUTSIDE. WE HAVE TO LEAVE IT IN
THE HANDS OF THE PROFESSIONALS.
MY SUGGESTION IS THAT WE FIX THE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE, AND WE
DON'T CREATE ANOTHER ONE WHERE
OUR CHILDREN END UP DEAD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
RUBIO. SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND I
WANT TO THANK MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
FOR HER HER WORDS AND HER
ADVOCACY IN THIS SPACE. AND, AND
WE KNOW EVEN WITH THE SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE, FAR TOO MANY OF
OUR CHILDREN FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS. AND ALL WE ARE SAYING IN
THIS BILL AND I APPRECIATE THE
MEMBER FROM MORENO VALLEY
PUSHING THIS ISSUE TO THE TOP
OF, OF THE SURFACE SO WE CAN ALL
LOOK AT IT. BUT ALL WE'RE SAYING
IS THAT WE WANT TO PROVIDE
OPTIONS. WE WANT TO PROVIDE
OPTIONS. MANY OF US WORK WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WHO ARE VIGILANT, WHO DO WHAT
THE SYSTEM CANNOT, WHO ARE THERE
FOR FAMILIES WHEN THE SYSTEM HAS
BROKEN DOWN. AND ALL WE ARE
SAYING IS TO GIVE AN OPTION FOR
MANDATORY REPORTERS TO BE ABLE
TO GO TO OUR TRUSTED NONPROFIT
ACTIVIST ADVOCATES TO THOSE
COMMUNITY BASED AGENCIES SO THEY
TOO CAN STEP IN OVER 50%, 50% OF
CHILDREN WHO ARE INVOLVED WITH
OUR WELFARE SYSTEM ARE BLACK AND
INDIGENOUS. OVER 50%. AND WE
KNOW FAR TOO LONG. AND AS A
BLACK WOMAN WHOSE FAMILY HAS
EXPERIENCED THIS, THE SYSTEM IS
INVOLVED, PARTICULARLY WHEN
THERE'S POVERTY. SOMETIMES THE
ONLY THING THE PARENTS HAVE IS
THAT THEY'RE POOR. AND YES, THAT
OFTENTIMES GETS TRANSLATED AS
NEGLECT, BUT THEY JUST NEED HELP
AND SO WE ARE NOT SAYING TO STOP
THE WAYS IN WHICH OUR MANDATORY
REPORTERS ENGAGE. WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS LET'S PUT SOME MORE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND. LET'S BRING
THESE COMMUNITY, THESE TRUSTED
COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO THE TABLE TO
ALSO SUPPORT THIS SYSTEM. THAT
IS ALL WE'RE SAYING. SO I THINK
WE CAN HOLD UP AND WE NEED TO DO
MORE TO SUPPORT OUR PUBLIC
WELFARE AGENCIES. THEY'RE
OVERBURDENED BECAUSE WE HAVE A
SAFETY NET THAT HAS BEEN
DESTROYED OVER THE LAST 40
YEARS, AND THEY ARE HAVING TO DO
TOO MUCH. AND ALL OF THIS BILL
IS SAYING IS, LET'S GIVE OPTIONS.
LET'S ENGAGE THESE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE THE
TRUST OF OUR COMMUNITIES, AND
LET'S LET THEM STAND NEXT TO
THESE WELFARE AGENCIES TO DO
WHAT OUR FAMILIES NEED. AND THAT
IS SERVICE TO HELP. AND
SOMETIMES WE KNOW WHEN WE CALL
IN POLICE THAT ISN'T OFTEN A
HELP IN FAR TOO MANY CASES. SO
LET'S BE ABLE TO CALL IN FOLKS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
TRUSTED, AND LET'S GIVE FOLKS
OPTIONS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE CARE AND THE SERVICE THAT
OUR COMMUNITIES NEED, AND THAT
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR THE AYE VOTE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY THANK AGAIN THE
MEMBERS WHO HAVE SPOKEN ON THIS
ISSUE. BUT I THINK THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, WE CAN ALWAYS DO
BETTER. AND WHEN WE HAVE MORE ON
BOOTS ON THE GROUND, WE ARE ABLE
TO HELP MORE OF OUR COMMUNITY.
AGAIN, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SENATOR MIN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I WASN'T PLANNING TO
SPEAK ON THIS, BUT AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW, MY WIFE IS A LEADING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EXPERT. AND I
KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SHE
HAS DISCUSSED WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BALDWIN PARK. THEY DISAGREE
ON THE VALUE OF SOME SLIGHT
WAIVERS OR EXEMPTIONS FROM
MANDATORY REPORTING. BUT WHAT MY
WIFE AND OTHER DV EXPERTS HAVE
ALWAYS TOLD ME IS THAT SOMETIMES
YOU WANT TO HAVE ESCAPE VALVES
BECAUSE MANDATORY REPORTING CAN,
IN CERTAIN INSTANCES, LEAD TO
ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES. AND I WILL
JUST NOTE THAT THIS BILL IS
DISCRETIONARY. IT'S SOMETHING
THAT SPECIFICALLY DOES NOT APPLY
TO SITUATIONS WHERE A MANDATED
REPORTER KNOWS OR REASONABLY
SUSPECTS A CHILD HAS BEEN A
VICTIM OF ABUSE, OR INVOLVING
NEAR FATALITIES. SO I THINK THAT
SOME OF THE DESCRIPTIONS OF
SITUATIONS DESCRIBED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BALDWIN PARK HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ADDRESSED BY SOME
OF THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL,
SO I'M GOING TO BE VOTING AYE ON
THIS BILL. I WOULD URGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO VOTE AYE AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? SEEING NO
MICROPHONE'S UP, SENATOR WIENER,
YOU MAY CLOSE. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
FOR THE DEBATE TODAY. I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO BE CLEAR.
THIS BILL APPLIES TO CASES OF
QUOTE UNQUOTE GENERAL NEGLECT,
NOT SEVERE, SEVERE NEGLECT.
PHYSICAL ABUSE IS STILL MANDATED
REPORTING. THIS IS GENERAL
NEGLECT FOR RIGHT NOW THERE ARE
CASES THAT ARE GETTING FUNNELED
INTO LAW ENFORCEMENT WHERE THEY
DO NOT NEED TO BE FUNNELED INTO
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND THIS IS
ABOUT RESPECTING THE
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT OF THESE
WHO ARE NOW MANDATED REPORTERS
THERE ABOUT WHETHER TO CALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR CHILD WELFARE, OR
WHETHER TO WORK WITH SOCIAL
SERVICES. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO,
GILL. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. NÓ. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN GLAESER.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE LEHMAN.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR I'M IN.
AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NILO
WHEN? NO. NILO. NO OKUBO.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. NO SATO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. NO SEN. WIENER
MOVES A CALL NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 46 146.
THAT'S. FILE ITEM 146. WE'RE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
150. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2105.
SENATOR RUBIO WAS THE FLOOR
MANAGER. WELL I'M LOOKING OUT
FOR SECRETARY. PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2105 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWENTHAL. AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
SENATOR RUBIO, SENATOR RUBIO,
THIS IS YOUR BILL. IT'S 150,
RIGHT. OKAY. YEAH. THANK YOU
MADAM. I'M SORRY, MR. PRESIDENT.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT AB 2105
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWENTHAL, WHICH REQUIRES A
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLAN,
CONTRACT OR HEALTH INSURANCE
POLICY ISSUED, AMENDED OR
RENEWED TO PROVE TO PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR TREATMENT OF
PEDIATRIC AUTOIMMUNE
NEUROPSYCHIATRIC DISORDER
ASSOCIATED WITH INFECTIONS AND
PEDIATRIC ACUTE ONSET
NEUROPSYCHIATRIC SYNDROME.
PRESCRIBED OR ORDERED BY A
PHYSICIAN OR SURGEON. ALSO KNOWN
AS PANDAS AND PANDAS, THEY ARE
INFLAMMATORY DISEASES OF THE
BRAIN THAT RESULT IN SUDDEN
ONSET, DEVASTATING BEHAVIORAL
AND NEUROLOGICAL DYSFUNCTIONAL,
THAT DYSFUNCTION THAT USUALLY
OCCURS AFTER TRIGGERING AN
INFECTION. EARLY AND EXPEDITIOUS
ACCESS TO TREATMENT IS CRITICAL
FOR THESE PATIENTS. AN EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT OF PANDAS AND PANS IN
ORDER TO AVOID POTENTIALLY
PERMANENT NEUROLOGICAL DAMAGE
AND SOMETIMES FATAL OUTCOMES
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE DISORDERS,
IS IMPORTANT. UNFORTUNATELY, TOO
OFTEN TREATMENT IS ROUTINELY
DENIED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR RUBIO. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE, SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO, GIL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALI AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA BOG AYE. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER WILK. AYE. SENATOR
RUBIO MOVES TO CALL. NEXT UP.
FLOOR MANAGERS. NEXT UP, SENATOR
LIMON. SENATOR DODD, WE'RE GOING
TO GO NEXT TO FILE ITEM 157.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2316.
SENATOR LIMON, ARE YOU PREPARED?
ALL RIGHT, SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2316 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. AN ACT
RELATING TO PUPIL NUTRITION.
SENATOR LIMON. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS, FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DODD.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS. THANK YOU,
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2316 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. THIS
BIPARTISAN BILL WOULD PROHIBIT
SCHOOLS FROM SERVING FOODS
CONTAINING DANGEROUS ADDITIVES
THAT CAN HARM OUR CHILDREN AND
INTERFERE WITH THEIR ABILITY TO
LEARN. GIVEN THE LONG STANDING
CONCERNS IN 2019, THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED THE
CALIFORNIA EPA TO CONDUCT AN
INDEPENDENT AND THOROUGH
SCIENTIFIC EXAMINATION INTO THE
IMPACT OF SYNTHETIC FOOD DYES ON
CHILDREN. IN 2021, AFTER AN
EXTENSIVE AN EXHAUSTIVE REVIEW,
CALIFORNIA EPA ISSUED A REPORT
WHICH CONCLUDED THAT I QUOTE
CONSUMPTION OF SYNTHETIC FOOD
DYES CAN RESULT IN HYPERACTIVITY
AND OTHER NEUROBEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS IN SOME CHILDREN. TO BE
CLEAR, THIS BILL WILL NOT RESULT
IN A BAN ON FOODS IN CALIFORNIA,
NOR WILL IT RESULT IN ANY
PRODUCTS COMING OFF THE SHELF.
MORE THAN 95% OF THE PRODUCTS
SERVED IN SCHOOLS ARE ALREADY
FREE FROM THESE CHEMICALS, AND
THAT AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS AROUND
THE STATE, INCLUDING LA, USD AND
RURAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS, HAVE
ALREADY STOPPED SERVING FOODS.
THAT INCLUDES THESE HARMFUL
ADDITIVES. THE AUTHOR HAS TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION AND LIMIT THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL, WHICH HAS
REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM THE AG
COUNCIL, AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL AND THE DAIRY
ASSOCIATION. AMONG OTHERS. IT IS
SPONSORED BY THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION, TONY THURMOND, AND
SUPPORTED BY THE LA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. CTA, CFT,
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS,
SEIU, AND MORE THAN 70
ADDITIONAL ORGANIZATIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR LIMON,
IS THERE A DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALI AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. SENATOR.
LEMON MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS I
WANT TO JUST REPEAT THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT EARLIER THAT SOME
MAY HAVE MISSED. WE'RE TRYING TO
DEAL WITH MEMBERS OFF THE FLOOR.
WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL WITH
MEASURES THAT ARE GOING TO
REQUIRE A ROLL CALL VOTE. OKAY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO JUMP AROUND A
LITTLE BIT. I'LL LET YOU KNOW
OVER THE NEXT 6 OR 7 BILLS IN
ORDER. SO YOU CAN BE PREPARED.
AND THE FLOOR MANAGERS CAN BE
PREPARED. SO THE ORDER IS AS
FOLLOWS. ITEM 168 FLOOR MANAGER
DODD FILE ITEM 172 FLOOR MANAGER
ALLEN. FILE ITEM 185 FLOOR
MANAGER WAHAB. FILE ITEM 193
FLOOR MANAGER SENATOR WIENER.
FILE ITEM 204 FLOOR MANAGER.
SENATOR ROTH. FILE ITEM 207
FLOOR MANAGER. SENATOR GROVE.
ALL RIGHT, SO WE'LL BEGIN AT THE
TOP OF THE LIST. THIS IS FILE
ITEM 168 AB 3259. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 3259
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON AND
ACT RELATING TO TAXATION AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
DODD. MR. PRESIDENT, MEMBERS, I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB 3259 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON, THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL
THAT WOULD PROVIDE NEEDED
FLEXIBILITY FOR RESIDENTS IN
SOLANO COUNTY, THE CITY OF
PINOLE, AND THE CITY OF CAMPBELL
TO VOTE ON PENDING LOCAL REVENUE
MEASURES TO PROTECT ESSENTIAL
SERVICES AND IMPROVE CRITICAL
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS BILL DOES NOT RAISE ANY NEW
TAXES. IT SIMPLY EMPOWERS VOTERS
WITHIN SOLANO COUNTY. THE CITY
OF PINOLE, THE CITY OF CAMPBELL,
BY ALLOWING THEM TO DECIDE
WHETHER TO APPROVE LOCAL REVENUE
MEASURES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE BY ME AT THE END.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DODD, IS
THERE FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
THIS. SEEING NONE. THIS IS A TWO
THIRDS VOTE BILL. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. DODD DALY.
NØ. DODD. AYE DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA. NO.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH.
AYE RUBIO. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER.
AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK. NO
SENATOR DODD MOVES A CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
172. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2454.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2454 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEE. AN ACT RELATING TO DRINKING
WATER. SENATOR ALLEN. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
2454. THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
WELL OWNERS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
FREE WELL WATER TESTING
PROGRAMS, ENSURING THAT THOSE
LIVING IN AREAS SERVICED BY
DOMESTIC WELLS HAVE ACCESS TO
SAFE AND CLEAN TAP WATER.
BECAUSE STATE AND FEDERAL LAW DO
NOT CURRENTLY REQUIRE DOMESTIC
WELLS TO BE TESTED FOR DRINKING
WATER CONTAMINANTS, THOSE WHO
ARE DRINKING FROM THOSE WELLS
MAY NOT KNOW WHETHER
CONTAMINANTS ARE PRESENT IN
THEIR DRINKING WATER. THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE TESTING OF THESE
WELLS FOR CONTAMINANTS. IT WILL
HELP TO ACHIEVE THE RIGHT OF
EVERY CALIFORNIAN TO HAVE ACCESS
TO SAFE DRINKING WATER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR ALLEN, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO, GILL. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO.
LAIRD. AYE LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. NILO.
NÓ. OCHOA PADILLA. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO. SEYARTO.
NO SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. NO SENATOR ALLEN MOVES A
CALL. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 185.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 884.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. THE.
ASSEMBLY BILL 884 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWE. AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS. SENATOR WAHAB. THANK
YOU. COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. I RISE AS A PROUD
COAUTHOR TO PRESENT AB 884,
WHICH REQUIRES THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO IDENTIFY LANGUAGE NEEDS
BY DECEMBER 15TH, 2025, AND BY
2028 REQUIRES COUNTIES TO
TRANSLATE MATERIALS INTO
LANGUAGES TO MEET THOSE
IDENTIFIED. IDENTIFIED NEEDS,
INCLUDING PROVIDING TRANSLATED
VOTABLE BALLOTS RATHER THAN
REFERENCE BALLOTS. CALIFORNIA
LEADS THE NATION IN LANGUAGE
DIVERSITY, WITH 43.9% OF
HOUSEHOLDS SPEAKING A LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH AT HOME, AND
NEARLY 3 MILLION ELIGIBLE VOTERS
WHO IDENTIFY AS BEING LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT ON THE CENSUS.
AB 884 WILL ENSURE LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT VOTERS HAVE
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO THE BALLOT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SENATOR WAHAB, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NO
MICROPHONES, UPS SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ
AYE. DADDY. AYE. DODD. AYE.
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN! AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO.
AYE. OCHOA. BOGH PADILLA.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
NO. SENATOR. WAHAB MOVES A CALL.
WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
193. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 3190.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3190 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HANEY. AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
WORKS. SENATOR WIENER, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. AYE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
3190 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY. THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ON
CERTAIN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS ARE BEING PAID A FAIR
WAGE, WHILE ALSO ADVANCING OUR
STATE'S HOUSING GOALS BY
RECRUITING THE WORKFORCE, WE
NEED TO BUILD HOUSING.
PREVAILING WAGE EXEMPTIONS, AS
WELL AS LACK OF BENEFITS AND
WAGE THEFT, CAN PREVENT THE
STATE FROM RECRUITING THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. WE NEED TO
BUILD HOUSING AND REACH OUR
HOUSING GOALS. CALIFORNIA NEEDS
100,000 MORE RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS TO MEET OUR
GOALS. IT ALSO NEEDS AN
ADDITIONAL 200,000 CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS TO MEET OUR OVERALL
HOUSING GOALS. AB 3190 PROVIDES
A CLEAR SOLUTION TO THESE
CHALLENGES AND WILL HELP RECRUIT
THE WORKFORCE. WE NEED BY
EXTENDING PREVAILING WAGE
REQUIREMENTS TO CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS FUNDED WITH THE STATE
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDITS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR WIENER,
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NO MICROPHONES.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. NÓ. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN
AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NILO.
NO. OCHOA. NO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. STERN.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. NO SENATOR WIENER
MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM
204. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1577.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1577 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
LOW. AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
FACILITIES. SENATOR ROTH. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS BILL
REQUIRES HEALTH FACILITIES AND
CLINICS TO MEET WITH A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OR CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY NURSING PROGRAM UPON
THE COLLEGE'S REQUEST, AND TO
WORK IN GOOD FAITH TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE COLLEGE'S NURSING
PROGRAM. CLINICAL PLACEMENT
NEEDS. ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL
REQUIRES THE HEALTH FACILITY IF
IT IS UNABLE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS TO INFORM HCCI. OUR
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND INFORMATION OF ITS LACK OF
CAPACITY OR CAPABILITY USING A
FORM DEVELOPED BY THAT
DEPARTMENT. THE HEALTH
FACILITIES WOULD BE SUBJECTED TO
A $1,000 FINE FOR FAILURE TO
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION
REQUESTED. WHILE THIS BILL DOES
NOT ESTABLISH THE NURSING
CLINICAL PLACEMENT INVENTORY
THAT THE SENATOR FROM STOCKTON
AND I HAVE BEEN PURSUING FOR
SEVERAL YEARS, THAT BILL, SENATE
BILL 1042, WAS HELD IN THE
ASSEMBLY. THIS IS A GOOD START,
AND THE REST OF YOU CAN FINISH
THE JOB NEXT YEAR. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THAT'S THAT
SPECIAL ROTH CHARM RIGHT THERE.
MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLAN. AYE. ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. NÓ.
DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO.
NO. OCHOA NO. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN.
AYE. UMBER AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. NO. SENATOR
ROTH MOVES THE CALL. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, LET ME GIVE YOU THE
ORDER OF THINGS TO COME. WE'RE
GOING TO DO FILE ITEM 207 NEXT.
THAT'S A FLOOR MANAGER. SENATOR
GROVE. IT'S GOING TO BE FOLLOWED
BY FILE ITEM 258 TWO 6261, 268
AND 281 WITH FLOOR MANAGERS
SENATORS GONZALEZ, CORTEZ,
SKINNER, PORTANTINO, AND CORTEZ.
WE'LL MOVE NOW TO FILE ITEM 207.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2119.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 29 2119 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER. AN ACT RELATING TO MENTAL
HEALTH. SENATOR GROVE. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB 2119 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, DOCTOR WEBER.
AB 2119 WOULD REMOVE A
STIGMATIZING LANGUAGE RELATED TO
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS FROM
CURRENT LAW AND SUBSTITUTING IT
WITH PERSONAL FIRST LANGUAGE
WHERE SUITABLE. NEARLY 50% OF
AMERICANS ARE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE A MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGE AT SOME POINT IN THEIR
LIVES, AND MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS ARE THE WORLD'S
LEADING CAUSE FOR DISABILITY.
YET THE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
STIGMA PERSIST AROUND MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS AND TREATMENT.
UTILIZING FIRST PERSON LANGUAGE
SHOULD BE FOUND AS A POSITIVE
IMPACT FOR DESTIGMATIZING MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY SENATOR WANT TO BE
HEARD ON THIS MEASURE. ANY
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
LIMÓN. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MEN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO. AYE. OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE.
SENATOR GROVE MOVES A CALL. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 258. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2286. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. THE ASSEMBLY BILL
2286 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGAR
CURRY. AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB 2286 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MAJORITY LEADER AGUILAR CURRY.
IT WILL ENSURE AN INTENTIONAL
AND SAFE TRANSITION TO
AUTONOMOUS TECHNOLOGY AS IT IS
INTEGRATED INTO LARGE VEHICLES
LIKE HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS. IT DOES
NOT BAN AUTONOMOUS TRUCKS. IT
DOES, HOWEVER, ASK THAT A HUMAN
SAFETY OPERATOR BE PRESENT TO
MONITOR THE TECHNOLOGY AND
RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES AS TESTED
AND DEPLOYED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS.
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO.
GILL. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD NO. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. NO. NO.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD LIMÓN.
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MIN NO.
NEUMANN AYE. NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA.
AYE. PADILLA. PORTANTINO ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN.
UMBERG WAHAB. AYE WIENER. AYE.
WILK. AYE. CARILLO SENATOR
GONZALEZ MOVES A CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
260. THIS IS FILE ITEM AB 2245.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2245 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUAN CARRILLO. AN ACT RELATING
TO SCHOOL EMPLOYEES. SENATOR
CORTESE, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO REPRESENT ASSEMBLY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2245 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO. THIS IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD PARITY BILL, AND
IT WOULD ALLOW CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS EMPLOYED BY
REGIONAL OCCUPATION CENTERS OR
THEIR PROGRAMS, WHICH ARE
OPERATED BY A SINGLE SCHOOL
DISTRICT, MEANING NO JPA'S
SINGLE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
OBTAIN PERMANENT STATUS AFTER A
PROBATIONARY PERIOD OF TWO
YEARS. LIKE OTHER CTE TEACHERS
IN CALIFORNIA. AS WE ALL KNOW,
WHEN EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE TO BE
CLASSIFIED AS PERMANENT, THEY
ARE NO LONGER EMPLOYED AT WILL
AND CAN RECEIVE DUE PROCESS AND
BASIC LABOR RIGHTS SUCH AS
NOTICE OF DISCIPLINE OR LAYOFF,
AND PROCEDURES FOR APPEAL. IN
ORDER TO FULLY INVEST IN CTE
PROGRAMS, HE MUST START BY
RETAINING AND PROTECTING OUR
WORKFORCE, WHICH ARE THE SOLE
FOUNDATION AND DRIVING FORCE OF
KEEPING THESE PROGRAMS AVAILABLE
FOR STUDENTS. THANK YOU, AND I
URGE AND I VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE?
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. AYE. RAGGIO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. NO. DODD AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. NO.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD. LEHMAN.
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NO.
NILO. NO. OCHOA NO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH RUBIO.
AYE. CIERTO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB WIENER.
AYE. WILK NO. SENATOR CORTEZ
MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 261. ASSEMBLY BILL 2022.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2022 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ARDIS. AN ACT RELATING TO MOBILE
HOME PARKS. SENATOR SKINNER
PRESENTING. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS AB 2022
ALLOWS FOR. MAKING IT SAFER FOR
OUR MOBILE HOME PARK RESIDENTS
BY REQUIRING MORE COMPREHENSIVE
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PLANS TO
AND MAKING SURE THAT THOSE PLANS
ARE EASILY ACCESSIBLE FOR THE
RESIDENTS. ENSURING FOR EXAMPLE,
THAT RESIDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
ENTRY AND EXIT POINTS. UTILITY
SHUT OFF CAPABILITIES AND
WORKING FIRE HYDRANTS, THIS HAS
SUPPORT FROM MANY OF OUR MOBILE
HOME PARK RESIDENTS. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR SKINNER. ANY SENATOR
WANT TO BE HEARD ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE DAWLEY. NØ. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. GROVE. AYE. GROVE.
NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO.
LAIRD. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. NO. OKOBO.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SATO. NO.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. NO.
SENATOR SKINNER MOVES THE CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 268. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1038.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1038 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MIKE FONG. AN ACT RELATING TO
SURPLUS RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
PORTENTINO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, AND MAY I
NEVER SEE ANOTHER BILL RELATED
TO THE 710 CORRIDOR AGAIN IN MY
LIFE? THIS IS AN IMPORTANT,
EXCITING MEASURE BECAUSE IT
BRINGS CLOSURE TO A SECTION OF
SOUTH PASADENA WHERE THERE IS A
DESIRE TO CREATE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THIS BILL BRINGS SOUTH
PASADENA IN PARITY WITH THE
LANGUAGE USED FOR PASADENA,
WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE CITY TO
SELL SURPLUS PROPERTY AND USE
THE PROCEEDS TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. UNDER THE CURRENT
SYSTEM, THERE IS A $7 MILLION
LIABILITY ON THE TABLE THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED IN ORDER TO
BRING THESE PROPERTIES UP TO
SPEED IN ORDER TO SELL THEM.
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON CALTRANS AND THE CITY
OF SOUTH PASADENA. IF THE CITY
AND CALTRANS COULD NOT MEET THAT
BURDEN, THESE HOMES WOULD BE
SOLD AT AUCTION AND NOT BE USED
AS AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS ALLOW THE CITY TO
PURCHASE THE HOMES AT THE
ORIGINAL PURCHASE PRICE, AND
THEN SELL THEM AND USE THE
PROCEEDS TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THERE'S CURRENTLY A 51
UNIT PROJECT ON THE TABLE THAT,
IF THIS BILL DOESN'T PASS, WOULD
BE JEOPARDIZED BECAUSE IN THE
FINANCING WE'RE USING, THE
PROCEEDS FROM THE SALE OF THESE
OTHER HOUSES IN A 3 TO 1
MULTIPLIER. SO FOR EVERY HOUSE
WE SELL, WE WILL GET THREE MORE
ADDITIONAL UNITS. SO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG AND MYSELF, IN
WORKING WITH CALTRANS, HCD AND
THE ADMINISTRATION OVER THE PAST
YEAR HAVE CRAFTED SB 268 AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
FROM YOU ALL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR PORTANTINO. ANY
MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY MEMBER. SENATOR
JONES. IS THERE SOME ISSUE WITH
YOU, SENATOR JONES? IS THERE A
CONCERN? I HEARD A DISTURBANCE
OVER THERE. I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE YOU'RE OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT. WE WON'T CALL FOR
MEDICAL. ALL RIGHT. IF THERE'S
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALI DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO.
LAIRD. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NHIÀU AYE. OCHOA
PADILLA. OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE SEN.
PORTANTINO MOVES A CALL. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 281.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 892.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 882 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BANKS AND ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES. SENATOR CORTEZ.
OKAY THANK YOU AGAIN. MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAYNES TO PRESENT
AB 892, WHICH ENSURES THAT THE
KERN COUNTY HOSPITAL AUTHORITY
AND THE CURRENT MEDICAL CENTER
FOUNDATION FOLLOW BEST PRACTICES
ESTABLISHED BY THE ACCOUNTING
STANDARDS BOARD, PUBLISH AN
ANNUAL AUDIT AND COMPLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
ENSURING THE LONG TERM HEALTH OF
CURRENT MEDICAL IS OF PARTICULAR
IMPORTANCE TO DOCTOR BAYNES, AS
IT IS THE HOSPITAL WHERE SHE
COMPLETED HER RESIDENCY. THE
HOSPITAL HAS A MEDI-CAL CASELOAD
NORTH OF 70%, AND IT'S THE
REGION'S ONLY LEVEL TWO TRAUMA
CENTER. LOSING CURRENT MEDICAL
WOULD MEAN LOSING LIVES, AND AS
THE CLOSURE OF MADERA COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL HAS SHOWN US, THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY CANNOT AFFORD TO
LOSE A SINGLE HOSPITAL, CLINIC
OR DOCTOR. THE BILL HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST, AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
CORTESE, FOR CARRYING A BILL FOR
KERN. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. NÓ. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
I'M IN. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NO.
NILO NO. OCHOA. NO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. NO SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO SENATOR
CORTEZ MOVES A CALL. OKAY.
MEMBERS. GOOD NEWS. GOOD NEWS IS
THAT WE HAVE SENATE BILLS THAT
HAVE COME BACK OVER UNDER
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO AND DO SIX SENATE
BILLS. AUTHORS ARE UMBERG WIENER
BRADFORD AND BLAKE SPEAR.
THAT GOT EVERYBODY PRETTY
EXCITED. WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE
FOR A MOMENT.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE OKAY.
SO HERE ARE THE FILE NUMBERS FOR
THOSE UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
SENATE CONCURRENCE AND ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. IT'S GOING TO BE
FILED. ITEM 1924 2832 33 AND 39.
SO AUTHORS, BE PREPARED FOR YOUR
SPEECHES. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
FIRST WITH FILE ITEM 19. WE HAVE
IT. ALL RIGHT. GREAT. ALL RIGHT.
SO WE WE'RE GOING TO GET THE
COMPUTER UP TO SPEED. WE'RE
MOVING FASTER THAN TECHNOLOGY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. SO WE'RE
GOING TO LET IT CATCH UP FOR
JUST A MOMENT.
ALL RIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE, WE'RE BACK IN
SESSION. HERE WE ARE. THE
TECHNOLOGY HAS CAUGHT UP WITH
US. AND SO WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
ON UNFINISHED BUSINESS. AND I'LL
TELL YOU THE ORDER AGAIN, THE
FILE ITEMS ARE 19 AND 24 BY
SENATOR UMBERG, 28 BY SENATOR
WIENER, 32 AND 33 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. AND 39 BY SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR. ALL RIGHT. NEXT UP.
ITEM 19 SB 758. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 758 BY
SENATOR UMBERG. AN ACT RELATING
TO FIREARMS. SENATOR UMBERG,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, THE AMENDMENTS TO SB
758 REMOVE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL CREATING CRIMES FOR
SPECIFIED FIREARMS TRANSFERS. SO
I WOULD EXPECT THOSE WHO WERE
OPPOSED. ORIGINALLY, THE BILL
WOULD EMBRACE THESE AMENDMENTS
AND SUPPORT THEM ALONG WITH ME.
I URGE, AND I VOTE MEMBERS
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK ON
THE ON THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ADRIN I ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DAL NØ DODD
I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE NØ HURTADO I
JONES NÓ. LAIRD I LEHMAN I
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. I'M IN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN NILO NÓ OCHOA
B¢O NÓ PADILLA PORTANTINO I ROTH
I RUBIO I CIERTO NÓ. SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN UMBERG
I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK. NO.
SENATOR UMBERG MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 24, SB 919.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 919 BY SENATOR UMBERG. AN
ACT RELATING TO FRANCHISES.
SENATOR UMBERG, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, THE
AMENDMENTS TAKING THE ASSEMBLY
CLARIFIED DEFINITIONS. CHANGE
REQUIRED APPLICATION FEE AND
AUTHORIZED DFP TO DEFINE BY RULE
MATERIAL CHANGES THAT REQUIRE
THE AMENDED DISCLOSURE TO BE
FILED. I UNDERSTOOD, AND I
ASSUME EVERYBODY ELSE
UNDERSTOOD, THAT URGE. AND I
VOTE YES. I, AS A MEMBER, HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT THIS MEASURE
DISCUSSION, DEBATE. ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE, SENATOR UMBERG,
LOOKS LIKE YOU EXPLAINED IT VERY
WELL. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO, GO.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY. AYE DODD. AYE.
DURAZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER.
AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN AYE. NHIÀU AYE. OCHOA
BORG. AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. ACIERTO
AYE. SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
SENATOR UMBERG MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 28. THIS IS
SENATE BILL 988. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 988 BY SENATOR
WIENER. AN ACT RELATING TO
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. SENATOR
WIENER, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SB 988 IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THIS IS THE
FREELANCE WORKER PROTECTION ACT
AND THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY SIMPLY REMOVE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE FROM THE
BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
WIENER. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE, SENATOR GROVE?
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I KNOW
WE'RE CHIPPING AWAY AT AB5 IN
THE DISASTER THAT THAT CAUSED IN
THE STATE. WE STILL HAVE TO
ADDRESS MANICURISTS. YOU GUYS,
THE MANICURISTS ARE FREAKING OUT
BECAUSE ON JANUARY 1ST, THEY'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO WORK AT A SALON.
AND WE JUST APPRECIATE US
ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE, WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH THIS BILL THAT'S
EXCLUDING FREELANCE NEWSPAPER
WRITERS. THANK YOU. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THEY SHOULD GO UNDERGROUND
LIKE ALL THE OTHER LABOR. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE. SENATOR WIENER, YOU
MAY CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. DODD AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. AYE.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO. AYE SECRETO. NO.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE SEN.
WIENER MOVES THE CALL. NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM 32. THIS IS SENATE
BILL 1130 BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
AN ACT RELATING TO ELECTRICITY.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. 1130 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE AMENDMENTS
REDUCED THE THRESHOLD ON
ELECTRICAL IOUS TO ENROLL
CUSTOMERS BY CHANGING THE SYSTEM
SUFFICIENTLY ENROLLED TO MADE
REASONABLE EFFORTS TO ENROLL AND
MAKE CLARIFYING LANGUAGE AND I.
WHAT? AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE. WHAT? THANK YOU,
SENATOR BRADFORD AND COMPANY
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON THESE
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DALI. AYE DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. AYE. NILO.
NØ. OCHOA B¢O. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. CIERTO NO. SKINNER. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
HAMBURG AYE. WAHAB. AYE WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE. SENATOR BRADFORD
MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM
33. THIS IS SENATE BILL 1177,
ALSO BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1177 BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
UTILITIES. SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. 1177
UPDATES CALIFORNIA UTILITIES
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY LAW TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND SPIN CONCENTRATION
AND FOSTER MORE DIVERSE
WORKFORCE. THE AMENDMENTS AT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS CLARIFY
THAT THE INFORMATION IS REPORTED
AS AGGREGATE AND ALLOWS ENTITIES
REQUIRED TO FILE A REPORT TO USE
DATA COLLECTED BY THE PUC
SUPPLIERS CLEARINGHOUSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR BRADFORD, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE?
SEEING NO MICROPHONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO, GO! ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DAWLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. OCHOA PADILLA. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER WILK. AYE
SENATOR BRADFORD MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 39. THIS IS
SENATE BILL SEVEN. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
BY SENATOR BLAKE SPEER. AN ACT
RELATING TO LAND USE. SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB SEVEN, WHICH
IS BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY ON
CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL WILL MAKE
MINOR CHANGES TO THE ARENA
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS BASED ON
HCD'S EVALUATION. I
RESPECTFULLY, RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLY. NØ. DODD AYE.
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LYMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO.
NO. OCHOA. NO. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. NO. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. STERN
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
WILK. NO SEN. BLAKE SPEAR MOVES
A CALL. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT. MEMBERS TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE 29.1, SEE. THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1205. ASSEMBLY BILL 98.
ANYTHING ELSE ON MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS? MEMBERS ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT. THE GAME PLAN. THE
GAME PLAN NOW, FOLKS, IS TO GO
BACK TO ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU A HEADS UP ON
MEASURES AND BILLS SO YOU CAN
ALL BE PREPARED OVER THERE IN
THE NORTH SIDE OF THE CHAMBER.
AND WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
PUT BILLS ON CALL. WE DO HAVE
MISSING MEMBERS, SO WE'RE ONLY
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLE
ONCE THE ORDER FOR THE NEXT SIX
BILLS ARE FILED. ITEM 61. EXCUSE
ME, WE'RE GOING TO SKIP.
ALL RIGHT. HERE ARE THE NEXT
FOUR BILLS WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH. ITEM 89 FOLLOWED BY
FILE ITEM 108 111 AND 115. THOSE
ARE FLOOR MANAGERS CABALLERO,
SMALLWOOD, CUEVAS AND ALLEN. ALL
RIGHT. SO NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
89. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 26
770. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2670 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH. SENATOR CABALLERO. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS.
WE'RE ALL AWARE OF THE BATTLE
OVER ABORTION RIGHTS IN OUR
COUNTRY, AS WELL AS THE ROLE
CALIFORNIA PLAYS TO ENSURE
ACCESS. HOWEVER, MANY
CALIFORNIANS STILL DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY CAN SEEK
COMPREHENSIVE AND ACCURATE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AB 2670 WILL PROMPT
THE LAUNCH OF A PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
COMMUNICATE THE FACTS ABOUT
PREGNANCY CARE, ABORTION
SERVICES THROUGH A WEBSITE.
ABORTION CA.GOV TIMELY
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS
ESSENTIAL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR CABALLERO, ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. NÓ DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MCGUIRE. AYE.
BOERNER HORVATH. AYE. MEN. AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO NO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. WILK NO. SEN. CABALLERO
MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 108. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
1975. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL, 1975 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA. AN ACT RELATING TO
MEDI-CAL. SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA, I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 1975 UPON
APPROPRIATIONS OF FUNDS, AB 1975
WOULD MAKE MEDICALLY SUPPORTIVE
FOOD AND NUTRITION INTERVENTIONS
A COVERED BENEFIT TO ALL
MEDI-CAL RECIPIENTS WHEN DEEMED
MEDICALLY NECESSARY BY THEIR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER. AB 1975
WOULD DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO FORM A
COMMITTEE TO ISSUE GUIDANCE FOR
IMPLEMENTING THESE INTERVENTION
SERVICES. FOOD IS MEDICINE IS A
LEGISLATIVE REPARATIONS PRIORITY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DADDY. AYE.
DODD DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ GROVE.
AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH. AYE. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. SKINNER
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
WILK. AYE. SEN. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM 111. ASSEMBLY BILL
2319. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2319 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON. AN ACT RELATING
TO MATERNAL HEALTH. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I WANT
TO SAY ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON, I'M PLEASED TO
COAUTHOR AND PRESENT AB 2319.
THIS BILL AIMS TO REDUCE THE
ALARMING AND DISPROPORTIONATE
MATERNAL MORTALITY RATE OF BLACK
WOMEN AND OTHER PREGNANT PERSONS
OF COLOR. THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE CONDUCTED AN
INVESTIGATION THAT REVEALED A
NEED FOR THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM. PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY
OF COMPLIANCE. DATA FIRM
COMPLIANCE DEADLINES, AND
ADDITIONAL SPECIFICITY. ADOPTING
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD
ALLOW FACILITIES TO KNOW WHICH
PROVIDERS NEED TO BE TRAINED. WE
NEED TO PROTECT ALL PREGNANT
PEOPLE OF COLOR ACROSS THE
STATE, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DAWLEY. NO. DODD. AYE.
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. GROVE.
NO. HURTADO. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEUMANN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO
OCHOA. B¢O. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. ACIERTO
NO. SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. WILK. AYE SEN.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS MOVES A CALL.
ALL RIGHT. THE NEXT THREE FLOOR
MANAGERS FOR MEASURES. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP ARE SENATORS
ALAN NEUMANN AND CORTEZ. WE'LL
BEGIN FIRST WITH ITEM 115.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2552. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2552
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. AN
ACT RELATING TO PESTICIDES.
SENATOR ALLEN, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. MEMBERS. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL BILL.
BUILDING UPON PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION THAT RESTRICTED SOME
OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
RODENTICIDES, ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDES, WHICH HAVE BEEN
LINKED TO THE POISONINGS OF
NON-TARGETED NON-TARGETED
WILDLIFE, PETS AND CHILDREN.
IT'S BEEN CONSIDERABLY SCALED
BACK. A NUMBER OF AG OPPONENTS
HAVE DROPPED THEIR OPPOSITION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE?
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECK. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. NØ DODD.
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. GLAZER. NO.
NO. GONZALEZ. GROVE NO. HURTADO.
JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR I'M
IN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NO.
NILO. NO. OCHOA. BOGH. NO.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. NO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. WILK. AYE SENATOR ALLEN
MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 165 AB 2642. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2642
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. AN
ACT RELATING TO ELECTIONS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SEN.
NEWMAN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2642. AB
2642 WILL STRENGTHEN AND
SUPPLEMENT CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
ANTI INTIMIDATION LAWS BY
PROVIDING EXPLICIT CIVIL
PROTECTIONS FOR BOTH ELECTION
WORKERS AND VOTERS. THIS BILL
ALSO ESTABLISHES A PRESUMPTION
THAT A PERSON WHO OPENLY CARRIES
A FIREARM OR AN IMITATION
FIREARM WHILE INTERACTING WITH
OR OBSERVING ELECTION ACTIVITY,
SUCH AS VOTING OR COUNTING
VOTES, IS DOING SO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF INTIMIDATION. THIS
BILL HAS HAD NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. IT IS AN URGENCY
MEASURE SO AS TO BE IN EFFECT TO
APPLY TO THE UPCOMING ELECTION
CYCLE. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN, I AM RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU. SENATOR NEWMAN, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY NÓ. DODD
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. JONES NO. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO. ACIERTO NO. SKINNER
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. WILK. NØ. SEN. NEWMAN.
MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP, FILE 184.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1963.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL, 1963 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
PESTICIDES. SENATOR CORTEZ.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 1963 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN'S BILL. IT
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATIONS, OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS DPR, TO COMPLETE A
REEVALUATION OF THE PESTICIDE
PARAQUAT BY JANUARY 1ST, 2029,
AND TO MAKE THE DETERMINATION AT
THAT TIME, JANUARY 1ST, 2029, TO
EITHER RETAIN COUNSEL OR SUSPEND
ITS REGISTRATION OR TO PLACE NEW
RESTRICTIONS ON THE USE OF
PESTICIDES. PRODUCTS CONTAINING
PARAQUAT. PARAQUAT IS A HIGHLY
TOXIC HERBICIDE OR WEED KILLER.
IT'S BANNED IN MORE THAN 60
COUNTRIES, INCLUDING THOSE WITH
LARGE AGRICULTURAL ECONOMIES.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FOLLOW THEIR
LEAD. ALTHOUGH THIS BILL DOES
NOT AMOUNT TO A BAN, IT AMOUNTS
TO THIS FIVE YEAR EVALUATION
THAT I JUST DESCRIBED AND I
THANK. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SENATOR CORTEZ, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. BECKER.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. NO. DODD DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GROVE NO. HURTADO.
JONES. NO. HURTADO. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA.
BOGH. NO. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO ACIERTO. NO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. WILK. NO SENATOR
CORTEZ MOVES A CALL. ALL RIGHT,
HERE'S THE ORDER FOR THE NEXT
THREE. WE'RE GOING TO GO NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 214. FLOOR MANAGER
STERN. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO DO
FILE ITEM 231 FLOOR MANAGER.
SENATOR DURAZO, FOLLOWED BY
FLOOR ITEM 230. FLOOR FLOOR
MANAGER. SENATOR LEMON. SO NEXT
UP, FILE ITEM 214. THIS IS AB
347. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 347 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TÍNH. AN ACT RELATING TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION. SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR KING
CARRYING AB 347. THIS BILL WOULD
NOT ADD NEW REGULATIONS, BUT
INSTEAD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL TO
COME UP WITH A TESTING
ENFORCEMENT FRAMEWORK FOR
EXISTING REGULATIONS AROUND
PFAS. THESE CHEMICALS ARE
CURRENTLY REGULATED IN FOOD
PACKAGING, JUVENILE PRODUCTS AND
TEXTILES. RECENT AMENDMENTS HAVE
CLARIFIED THE FUNDING MECHANISM
BY WHICH DTSC WILL IMPLEMENT THE
BILL. THEY STRIKE OUT THE
APPLICATION OF BOTH COSMETICS AS
WELL AS COOKWARE, AND THEY DELAY
THE TIMELINE FOR IMPLEMENTATION
FOR DTSC TO GET THIS TESTING
FRAMEWORK UP AND RUNNING.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR STERN.
SENATOR, DARLING. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN OPPOSITION,
AND I'VE STATED MANY TIMES ON
THE FLOOR ABOUT PFAS, AND WE
HAVE MANY BILLS ON PFAS. AND
THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF WHY
WE NEED TO HAVE A HEARING. AND
WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT PFAS. PFAS
IS EVERYWHERE. IT'S IN OUR
WATER. IT'S IN A BAG OF
MICROWAVE POPCORN. AND WE NEED
TO GET A HANDLE ON HOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD WITH PFAS.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I OPPOSE
THESE BILLS WITH PFAS. UNTIL WE
HAVE A HEARING AND WE TALK ABOUT
WHAT THE FUTURE LOOKS LIKE, NOT
ONLY FOR THE MANUFACTURERS BUT
FOR OUR FOLKS THAT DO WATER
PURIFICATION OR COMMUNITY
SERVICE DISTRICTS. FOR THOSE
REASONS, I OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. SENATOR DAWLEY, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SENATOR STERN, YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BIEBER'S, ASK ABOUT A HEARING. I
THINK, THAT'S A REASONABLE
SUGGESTION, AND I APPRECIATE
ALSO HIS CONCERNS ABOUT THE LACK
OF ENFORCEMENT AROUND PFAS. IT
IS EVERYWHERE, IT IS GETTING
INTO US AND OUR CHILDREN, WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
SO WE HOPE THAT THIS BILL MOVES
THE BALL FORWARD AND THAT WE
HAVE THAT KIND OF OVERSIGHT AND
HEARING GOING FORWARD. SO WITH
THAT, RESPECTFULLY, I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
STERN. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ADRIN AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DAWLEY. NØ. DODD. AYE.
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ. GROVE NO. HURTADO
JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. I'M IN.
NEWMAN. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA
PADILLA. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO NO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. WILK WILK. NO
SENATOR STERN MOVES A CALL. ALL
RIGHT. MEMBERS. AYE. THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR ATTENTION TODAY.
AND WE'RE REALLY MAKING
PROGRESS. THAT'S A LITTLE SLOW,
SO I'M HOPING WE CAN PICK UP THE
PACE. ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE
HAVE THE NEXT TWO ITEMS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP. FILE
ITEM 231 WITH THE FLOOR MANAGER
AND FILE ITEM 234 WITH THE FLOOR
MANAGER. THIS POPULARITY,
SENATOR LEMON SO NEXT UP, 231,
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2447.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2447 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VALENCIA. AN ACT RELATING TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
SENATOR DURAZO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AB ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, VALENCIA, AB
2447 WILL REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM TO
PUBLISH SUPPLEMENTAL DATA ON
THEIR EXPENDITURES ABOVE
$25,000. REPORTING THIS DATA
WILL PROVIDE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THE CSU'S
SPENDING COMPARES TO THE RESERVE
SURPLUSES AND OPERATING BUDGET.
THE AUTHOR HAS ACTIVELY
COLLABORATED WITH THE CSU TO
ADDRESS AND ALLEVIATE ANY
CONCERNS REGARDING THE BILL. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR DURAZO,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
DOES ANY SENATOR WANT TO BE
HEARD ON THIS MEASURE? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ADRIN I'LL
GO. ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. NO.
NO. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NHIÀU AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH. AYE. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER WILK. WILK. HÌNH. WILK
AYE. SENATOR DURAZO MOVES A
CALL. WANT TO REMIND MEMBERS
THAT WE'RE ONLY GOING THROUGH
THE RULE ONCE. PAY ATTENTION.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 234. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2537. AND WE'LL GO TO SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2537
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADIS. AN ACT
RELATING TO OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY
DEVELOPMENT AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR. SENATOR
LEHMAN, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2537. THE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
IN OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY ACT ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARDIS.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A GRANT
PROGRAM TO BUILD CAPACITY FOR
LOCAL AND TRIBAL COMMUNITIES TO
ENGAGE IN THE PROCESS OF
OFFSHORE WIND DEVELOPMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEN. DOLLY THANK YOU, MADAM
SPEAKER, AND MEMBERS. IT'S
PROBABLY NO SURPRISE THAT I RISE
IN OPPOSITION. HERE WE ARE AGAIN
TALKING ABOUT WE'RE JUST GOING
TO GO TO OFFSHORE WIND WITHOUT
DOING GOOD SCIENCE. I'M NOT THE
SPEAKER. OKAY. THIS IS THE
PRESIDENT. HE ADDRESSED ME.
EXCUSE ME, MISTER PRESIDENT.
SORRY, SIR. LET'S START AGAIN.
ALL RIGHT. IT'S THE BOW TIE.
IT'S THE BOW TIE. WE'LL START
AGAIN, SENATOR, DARLING. THANK
YOU, MISTER PRESIDENT. MEMBERS.
IT'S PROBABLY NO SURPRISE THAT
I'M RISING ON THIS BILL, BECAUSE
HERE WE ARE GOING OUT AND GOING
TO JUST GO FOR OFFSHORE WIND
WHEN WE HAVE REALLY NOT
ADDRESSED THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
OUR STATE. WE JUST HAD A BILL UP
IN COMMITTEE THIS MORNING
TALKING ABOUT FISHING OFFSHORE
AND DOING A RESOLUTION. LOOK, WE
NEED TO DO THIS RIGHT. WE NEED
TO PLAN. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE MITIGATE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE THAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IF WE JUST MOVE
TO OFFSHORE WIND. FOR THOSE
REASONS, I WILL BE OPPOSING. AB
2537. MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS MEASURE? MEMBERS I DON'T
SEE ANY MICROPHONES UP,
CERTAINLY FROM ANY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. OH, EXCUSE ME, I WANT
TO GIVE THE OPPONENT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR LEHMAN, THIS IS BILL
FIVE FOR YOU. IS THAT RIGHT,
SENATOR LEHMAN? BILL FIVE. YEAH
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ADRIN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY NØ. DODD. DURAZZO DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. I'M
IN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NO.
NEILA NO. OKUBO PADILLA.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
ACIERTO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. WILK NO. SENATOR. LEMON
MOVES A CALL.
OKAY, MEMBERS, IF YOU CAN. IF I
CAN GET YOUR ATTENTION, PLEASE.
SO HERE'S KIND OF THE DIRECTION
WE'RE GOING. FIRST, WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE IN A FEW IN A MOMENT, A
TEN MINUTE BREAK, I CAN TELL YOU
THAT. AND I'M SURE, YOU KNOW, IN
TRACKING OUR PROGRESS TODAY THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A VERY LONG
NIGHT AHEAD OF US. WE HAVE A LOT
OF MEMBERS OFF THE FLOOR. WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO BRING THEM BACK
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE MORE
PROGRESS ON OUR ON OUR CALENDAR
TODAY, WHEN WE DO COME BACK,
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT CALLS, OKAY?
SO USE THESE TEN MINUTES TO GET
READY FOR THOSE BILLS THAT YOU,
YOU MISSED. SO YOU CAN BE
PREPARED TO VOTE ON THOSE. WHEN
WE GO THROUGH THAT AND WE DO IT
FAIRLY QUICKLY, WE'RE ASKING YOU
TO NOT LEAVE THE BUILDING. NO
RUN RUNS AROUND THE PARK. IT'S
GOING TO BE A TEN MINUTE BREAK
AND THEN WE'LL BE BACK AT OUR
WORK. WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE
BEFORE WE BREAK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS, WITHOUT OBJECTION,
PURSUANT TO JOINT RULE 33.1,
JOINT RULE 61 WILL BE SUSPENDED
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY BILLS 24, 71
AND 2795 TO BE AMENDED AFTER THE
DEADLINE. THE REQUEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
SENATOR GONZALEZ, WHAT PURPOSE
DO YOU RISE? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I MOVE THE
SENATE RULES BE SUSPENDED TO
ALLOW THE ENERGY, UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATION COMMITTEE TO AMEND
ASSEMBLY BILL 3264. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR GONZALEZ HAS MADE A
REQUEST. SENATOR SECRETO, WE
WOULD RATHER NOT. SO WE OPPOSE
THAT. SENATOR GONZALEZ IS ASKING
FOR A YES VOTE, AND I VOTE.
SENATOR SECRETO IS ASKING FOR A
WE WOULD WE WOULD APPRECIATE
NOT. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ALVARADO GILL
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY.
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ I GROVE. NØ HURTADO I
JONES. NO LAIRD I LIMON I
MCGUIRE. I MENGIBAR I AM IN I
NEWMAN. I NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO
OCHOA. NO. PADILLA PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO I CIERTO. NO.
SKINNER I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER
WILK. NO. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO.
GILL. DALLEY NÓ. PADILLA WIENER
I ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 8, THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, THERE IS A
RESOLUTION AT THE DESK
REQUESTING PERMISSION TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE 61 FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ALLOWING ASSEMBLY BILL 3024 TO
BE AMENDED AFTER THE DEADLINE.
THESE REQUESTS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
I SEE A MICROPHONE UP FROM
SENATOR CIERTO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AGAIN OUR PREFERENCE
WOULD BE THAT WE DID NOT DO THAT
AND ASK FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
SIR. WOULD THE SECRETARY READ
THE RESOLUTION RESOLVE THAT
JOINT RULE 61 BE DISPENSED WITH?
AND THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN I ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS, I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY NØ
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE NÓ HURTADO I
JONES NO. LAIRD LEHMAN I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN NEWMAN I NGUYEN
NO NILO. NO. OCHOA. NO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SECRETO. NO. SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN I
UMBERG I WAHAB I WEINER, I WILK.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL. LAIRD I
MCGUIRE. MEN I PADILLA. I VOTE
OF 29 TO 8. THIS JOINT RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. SENATOR GONZALEZ
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, THERE IS A RESOLUTION
AT THE DESK REQUESTING
PERMISSION TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
61 AND 62. A FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ALLOWING ASSEMBLY BILL 3264 TO
BE HEARD IN POLICY AND FISCAL
COMMITTEE AFTER THE DEADLINE.
THESE REQUESTS HAVE ALSO BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
I THINK I JUST READ THAT ONE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR GONZALEZ,
SENATOR CIERTO. ONCE AGAIN, WE
WOULD PREFER THAT WE DID NOT
SUSPEND THE RULES ANYMORE EVER
AGAIN AND WOULD REQUEST A NO
VOTE, NO AND BUT WE ARE AMENABLE
TO A SUBSTITUTE RULE. ALL RIGHT.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
THE LAST ROLL CALL ON THIS
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
RESOLUTION, SEEING NO OBJECTION.
HOW. OH. ALL RIGHT, LET'S READ
THE RESOLUTION. THEN WE'LL DEAL
WITH THE VOTE. PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION. SECRETARY RESOLVE
THAT. JOINT RULE 61 AND 62 BE
DISPENSED WITH. ALL RIGHT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE'LL USE THE
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL. AYES 29,
NO'S EIGHT. JOINT RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. OKAY, MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A TEN MINUTE
BREAK. COME BACK TO DO ALL THE
VOTES ON CALL. EXCUSE ME,
SENATOR NILO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I MOVE TO ADJOURN.
SECOND. WELL, WE'RE GOING TO
VOTE. FOR THE RECORD, SENATOR
NILO, THE. YOUR MOTION IS OUT OF
ORDER BECAUSE WE HAVE BILLS ON
CALL. ACCORDING TO SENATE RULES.
SO WE HAVE BILLS ON CALL
ACCORDING TO SENATE RULES,
MEANING THAT YOUR MOTION AT THIS
MOMENT IN TIME IS OUT OF ORDER.
THANK YOU. SIR PLEASE ACCEPT MY
DEEPEST APOLOGIES. THANK YOU
SIR. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A TEN MINUTE BREAK, AND
WE'RE GOING TO BILLS ON CALL
WHEN WE COME BACK. MEMBERS,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU
TO RETURN TO THE FLOOR. WE'LL
BEGIN IN ABOUT 60S. WE WILL GET
TO SHOW BACK ON THE ROAD.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU
AGAIN TO RETURN TO THE FLOOR. WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SO IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IF WE
HAVE EVERYBODY ON THE FLOOR.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WE NEED ALL MEMBERS BACK
ON THE FLOOR AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. WE'RE READY TO GO.
SO OUR NUMBER WILL BE 39. 30.
WIENER. ARE.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE READY
TO GET GOING. WE'RE GOING TO
START OFF WITH A SERIES OF BILLS
BY SENATOR GLAZIER. I'M GOING TO
FIRST START OUT WITH PHIL. ITEM
125 AB 2057. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2057 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. SENATOR GLAZIER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL WOULD BUILD
UPON ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN'S
TRANSFER LEGISLATION, WHICH
ESTABLISHED THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE
FOR TRANSFER INTERSEGMENTAL
IMPLEMENTATION COMMITTEE TO
FACILITATE GREATER COORDINATION
BETWEEN OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS. THIS PAST DECEMBER,
THE COMMITTEE, WHICH INCLUDES
STUDENTS AND FACULTY, RELEASED A
REPORT WITH NUMEROUS
RECOMMENDATIONS. THIS BILL WOULD
ENACT FOR LOW COST AND HIGH
IMPACT RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THAT
COMMITTEE TO IMPROVE TRANSFER
FOR HIGH UNIT STEM MAJORS. WITH
THAT, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING
AND SEEING NONE. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE, BUT WE DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE FLOOR RIGHT NOW.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 125.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
MEMBERS. ALLEN Ã ALVARADO, GIL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DAWLEY AYE.
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. I AM IN,
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
NILO AYE. OCHOA. BOGH. AYE
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO SUGIARTO AYE.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. UMBERG STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE WILK. AYE ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THIS ITEM ON CALL
NOW. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 131 AB
298. SENATOR MCGUIRE. SENATOR
GLAZER'S PREPARED SECRETARY. YOU
MAY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2198 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA. AND
ACCORDING TO HEALTH CARE SENATOR
GLAZER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORES IS A
CLEANUP BILL THAT ALIGNS
CALIFORNIA LAW WITH FEDERAL LAW
BY EXEMPTING COMMERCIAL, DENTAL
AND VISION PLANS WITH
APPLICATION PROGRAMING INTERFACE
REQUIREMENTS. THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO NØ VOTES AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. MEMBERS. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 39.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 146 AB 2727 11.
SENATOR GLAZIER HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2711 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUPIL DISCIPLINE. SENATOR
GLAZIER THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS, THIS BILL IS
TARGETED AT SUPPORTING OUR YOUTH
WHO MAY BE STRUGGLING WITH
SUBSTANCE USE. IT TAKES A
PROACTIVE APPROACH OF ENSURING A
STUDENT WHO WANTS HELP AND
VOLUNTARILY DISCLOSES THEIR USE
OF A SUBSTANCE IS NOT SUSPENDED
FOR DOING SO. IN ORDER TO BETTER
PROTECT OUR YOUTH, WE MUST LOOK
AT ADDRESSING THE HEALTH NEEDS
OF THESE STUDENTS IN THESE
SITUATIONS. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE CABALLERO. COURT. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALI. NÓ. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. NO HURTADO. AYE. JONES
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. I AM IN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO AYE. OCHOA NO. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH RUBIO.
AYE. SEGATO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER WILK. AYE. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL. ROTH. AYE
WIENER. AYE. AYES 33. NOES SIX.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 250 AB
2664. SENATOR GLAZER'S PREPARED
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2664 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRYANT. AN ACT TO FOSTER
YOUTH. SENATOR GLAZER. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYANT, THIS
BILL SEEKS TO CLARIFY FAMILY
REUNIFICATION TIMELINES IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. THE BILL
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS. AND WITH
THAT, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE TODAY. MEMBERS. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
HERE ON FILE ITEM 250? HEARING
AND SEEING. NO OBJECTION. AYES
39. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
ASK THAT YOU STAY ON THE FLOOR.
WE WANT TO LIFT THE CALL SHORTLY
ON ALL THOSE ITEMS. SO WE'RE
GOING TO NEED MEMBERS ON THE
FLOOR FOR THAT.
MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT. SO THE NEXT
ITEM ON THE DOCKET, FOLKS, IS
FILE ITEM 218 218. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 1866. THE
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1866 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HART. AN ACT RELATING TO OIL AND
GAS AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION.
THEREFORE GOES TO OUR FRIENDLY
ASSEMBLY. SENATOR LIMÓN, THANK
YOU. I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 1866 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART, WHICH
ADDRESSES ISSUES WITH OUR IDLE
WELLS AB 1866 REQUIRES OIL
OPERATORS TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO PLUG AN
ESTIMATED 40,000 IDLE OIL WELLS
IN CALIFORNIA. THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES OPERATORS TO PRIORITIZE
PLUGGING WELLS WITHIN 3200FT OF
WHERE COMMUNITIES LIVE, WORK,
AND PLAY. OVER HALF OF THE IDLE
WELLS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE NOT
PRODUCED OIL IN DECADES, AND IT
MAY TAKE OVER A CENTURY TO PLUG
ALL IDLE WELLS UNDER CURRENT
LAW. WITHOUT AB 1866, MANY OF
THESE WELLS COULD BECOME
ORPHANED AND CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR BILLIONS IN CLEANUPS. RECENT
AMENDMENTS PHASE IN THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENTS AND RESTORE FEES TO
FUND A PROGRAM THAT USES SKILLED
AND TRAINED LABOR TO PLUG
ORPHANED WELLS. AB 1860 1866 IS
A NECESSARY TOOL TO SOLVE OUR
ISSUES WITH IDLE WELLS IN
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. I SEE MIKE'S UP FROM
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB 1866. I REPRESENT THE
LARGEST OIL PRODUCING COUNTY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, WHERE
70% OF THE OIL IS PRODUCED. THE
BILL WOULD REQUIRE AN OPERATOR
OF AN IDLE WELL OR GAS WELL TO
PLAN WITH CAL JAM TO PROVIDE A
MANAGEMENT OF ELIMINATION OF ALL
IDLE WELLS. IN 2016, THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AND THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED AB 2729, WHICH
CREATED AN IDLE WELL MANAGEMENT
PLAN OF CAL JIM, AND SINCE 2019,
MORE THAN 15,000 IDLE WELLS HAVE
BEEN PLUGGED AND ABANDONED, AND
11,000 OF THOSE IN JUST THE LAST
FEW YEARS, THE DIFFERENT THERE'S
DIFFERENT REASONS WHY. AND
SOMETIMES THESE WELLS ARE NOT
PLUGGED AND ABANDONED. SOMETIMES
IT'S A GLOBAL PRICE ON OIL AND
IT DOESN'T MAKE IT PROFITABLE TO
OPERATE. AND SOMETIMES IT'S A
DECISION TO HALT PRODUCTION FOR
A PERIOD OF TIME. AND SOMETIMES
IT MAY REALLY DO NEED TO BE, YOU
KNOW, OR ABANDONED. AND SO THEY
ABANDONED THAT. WELL, BUT THE
MAJORITY OF THE TIME IT'S JUST
NOT GETTING PERMITS. 30 PERMITS
HAVE BEEN ISSUED THIS ENTIRE
YEAR. WE'RE ABOUT 270 PERMITS
FROM BEING ISSUED EVEN ON
MAINTENANCE WELLS. SO IF YOU
HAVE SOMETHING THAT IS HAS
LITTLE, YOU KNOW, BOLT LOOSE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, YOU CAN'T
GO AND DO MAINTENANCE ON THOSE
WELLS WITHOUT GETTING A PERMIT.
PERMITS ARE NOT BEING ISSUED. SO
IT JUST SITS IDLE. SO IF WE
COULD ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ROOT
CAUSES THAT CAUSE US NOT TO BE
ABLE TO OPERATE SOME OF THESE
WELLS, MAYBE WE WOULDN'T HAVE
IDLE WELLS. AGAIN, POLICIES
AFFECT COMING OUT OF THIS
BUILDING AFFECT THE WAY THAT WE
DO BUSINESS. WE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO WE SHOULD ALWAYS AND CONTINUE
TO ENCOURAGE OPERATORS TO
REMEDIATE THEIR OWN ASSETS, WE
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT, FOR AN
OPERATOR TO BE ABLE TO SHUT DOWN
AN IDLE WELL, THERE NEEDS TO BE
AN INCOME GENERATED FROM OTHER
WELLS. AGAIN, NOT GETTING
PERMITS. SO THERE'S NO INCOME
COMING IN TO SHUT DOWN THESE
WELLS, AND THE BILL IS
ARBITRARY. IN AN ATTEMPT TO FIX
A PROBLEM THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
ADDRESSED, MEMBERS CALIFORNIA
IMPORTS ABOUT 70% OF ITS OIL. I
KNOW, I SOUND LIKE A BROKEN
RECORD. IT COST ABOUT $7 A
BARREL TO DO THAT. WE ARE
TRANSITIONING OFF OF OIL, BUT
ONLY DOMESTICALLY PRODUCED OIL.
AND WE'RE GETTING IT FROM
FOREIGN COUNTRIES WHERE OUR
POLICIES HAVE A DETRIMENTAL
IMPACT ON GLOBAL, GLOBAL ISSUES
THAT TAKE PLACE, MEANING WARS,
INFRASTRUCTURE, ALL OF THOSE
THINGS. AND WE SHOULD DEFINITELY
PRODUCE OIL HERE, REDUCE CARBON
EMISSIONS. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NO VOTE ON THIS
RIDICULOUS BILL. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GROVE. SENATOR DALI,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I ALSO RISE IN
OPPOSITION. I JUST WANT TO I
THINK IT'S VERY DISINGENUOUS TO
SAY THE TAXPAYERS ARE GOING TO
BE ON THE HOOK FOR ABANDONED
WELLS. WE HAVE AN ABANDONED
WELL, PROCESS WHERE WE DID HAVE
ABANDONED WELLS THAT WERE DONE
50 YEARS AGO. THE COMPANIES CAME
IN AND THERE'S BEEN A FEE PUT ON
TO TAKE CARE OF THOSE IDLE
WELLS. THROUGH THE YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE, ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AND ENERGY,
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THESE. IDA
WELLS, THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT WE
HAVE CAL CHEN THAT IS NOT
PERFORMING AT THE LEVELS THAT
THE OIL COMPANIES ACTUALLY PAID
TO HAVE THEM SUPPORT. THEY PAY A
FEE FOR THOSE POSITIONS TO BE
FUNDED, AND THEY HAVEN'T BEEN,
WE HAVEN'T FILLED THOSE
POSITIONS AND WE JUST LAST WEEK
HAD OR THIS WEEK HAD A HEARING
TALKING ABOUT CHEN. WE NEED TO
DO AN AUDIT OF CAL CHEN, AND WE
NEED TO STOP RUNNING BILLS AND
PUTTING FEAR IN THE PUBLIC THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
ABANDONED. WELL THERE ISN'T
THERE'S A PROCESS FOR THOSE
WELLS. THERE'S MONEY FOR THOSE
WELLS. AND QUITE FRANKLY, THE
RATEPAYERS OF CALIFORNIA WHO BUY
GAS AND OIL AND DIESEL HAVE PAID
THAT. THE BIGGEST TAX HIKE IN
CALIFORNIA IS THE MONEY THAT WE
PAY TO CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD FOR EVERY GALLON OF FUEL
THAT WE BUY. AND THAT'S
DISPERSED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
TO THINGS LIKE THE HIGH SPEED
TRAIN TO WATER INFRASTRUCTURE,
WHICH HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH OIL
WELLS. AND SO I THINK WE NEED TO
BE HONEST WITH THE RATEPAYERS OF
CALIFORNIA, PEOPLE WHO BUY
GASOLINE, DIESEL AND NATURAL
GAS, THAT THESE WELLS ARE NOT
REALLY THE PROBLEM. THE REALLY
PROBLEM IS HOW WE'RE DISPERSING
THE MONEY AND HOW CALLAGAN IS
NOT DOING THEIR JOB TO MAKE SURE
CALIFORNIANS ARE SAFE AND GET
THE JOB DONE. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, I OPPOSE AB 1866 AND
ASK FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER ANY OTHER SENATOR WANT
TO BE HEARD ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SENATOR LIMÓN, YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU. MEMBERS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO, GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. NÓ. DODD DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. NO. HURTADO NO. JONES
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE MAGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO
OCHOA. NO. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK AYE. CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME,
FOLKS. WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE, SO
WE'LL CLOSE THE ROLL AFTER THIS
LAST GO THROUGH IT. ALVARADO,
GILL. ARCHULETA. BRADFORD DODD.
GLAZER. AYE AYE. JONES NEWMAN.
RUBIO AYE. DODD. DODD. AYE
BRADFORD. AYE A VOTE OF 29 TO 7.
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO ITEMS
THAT ARE ON CALL. ONE MOMENT.
LET'S GET TO THE LIST. WE'LL
LIFT OKAY. SO THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO GO NEXT. WE'RE GOING TO
GO ITEMS THAT ARE ON CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK ALL MEMBERS TO BE
AT THEIR DESKS AND HAVE A QUIET
IN THE, IN THE, IN THE, IN THE
SENATE SO THAT WE CAN HEAR
EVERYBODY'S VOTE. AND WE'RE
GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLL ON ALL
THESE VOTES IN JUST JUST A
MINUTE OR TWO. WHAT DOES IT SAY?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT SAYS.
FIRST.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE HAVE 32
BILLS ON CALL. YOU SHOULD ALL
HAVE THAT RECORDED ON YOUR
DEVICES, ON YOUR DESKS. SENATOR
JONES, WE NEED EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION. EVERYONE AT THEIR
SEATS. IF WE COULD, PLEASE. YES,
SIR. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN AT FILE ITEM 113. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2483. SECRETARY, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL.
ALVARADO, GIL. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
BRADFORD. DALLY GLAZER. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES NØ. MCGUIRE AYE.
MIN WEN. NILO OCHOA. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH RUBIO.
SEYARTO SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN UMBERG. WILK NO.
WHEN. NO. ZERO. NO. ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL ONE
LAST TIME, BUT IS NOT A PRACTICE
OF THIS. PRESIDING OFFICER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA. I
DON'T KNOW. ALVARADO. GIL ASHBY,
BLAKE. SPEER BRADFORD. BLAKE.
SPEER. I BRADFORD I DAWLEY. NO
GLAZER. GROVE NO. HURTADO NO.
MIN NILO. NO. OCHOA ROTH. RUBIO.
STERN RUBIO. I STERN. I UMBERG I.
ASHBY I HERE WE GO. I VOTE OF 26
TO 9. THE MEMBER. THE MEASURE
PASSES. ALL RIGHT. HOPEFULLY
THAT'S NOT THE PRACTICE FOR THE
NEXT 34 ITEMS. ALL RIGHT. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 117. THIS IS AB
2783. SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. ALVARADO, GIL. GROVE JONES
MCGUIRE. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
THAT'S GROVE. AYE ALL RIGHT,
FOLKS, 38 TO 0. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GONNA MOVE NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 137 AB 1799.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO, GIL ASHBY,
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO NO.
EGGMAN NO. GLAZER GROVE. NO
HURTADO. NO LIMON. OCHOA PADILLA.
PORTANTINO AYE. ON A VOTE OF 22
TO 11. THAT MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM. ONE. I'M
JUST GOING TO REMIND MEMBERS
THEY NEED TO BE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS AT THEIR DESKS IF THEY
WANT THEIR VOTE TO BE RECORDED.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE MOVING NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 150. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 2105. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO, GIL BRADFORD, A LEMON.
PADILLA LIMON A PADILLA I WIENER
I. ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 157. ASSEMBLY BILL
2316. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ALVARADO, GIL. BRADFORD JONES.
MCGUIRE. AYE NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA
BOG AYE. PADILLA AYE. SEYARTO
WHEN I. BRADFORD. AYE. ON A VOTE
OF 36 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT ITEM UP IS 168 AB 3259.
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ALVARADO. GIL MCGUIRE. AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. PADILLA AYE. RUBIO
AYE. ON A VOTE ON A VOTE OF 31
TO 8, THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 172. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2454. SECRETARY,
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. ALVARADO
GIL DAWLEY, NÓ GROVE, NØ
MCGUIRE. AYE NGUYEN. OCHOA
PADILLA. AYE. RUBIO AYE. AND A
VOTE OF 31 TO 6. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 185.
THIS IS AB 884. SECRETARY,
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. ALVARADO,
GIL. BRADFORD AYE. JONES MCGUIRE.
AYE OCHOA. BOGH AYE. PADILLA
AYE. JONES AYE. ON A VOTE OF 38
TO 1, THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP. FILE ITEM 193. ASSEMBLY BILL
3190. SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO, GIL ASHBY,
BRADFORD. GLAESER. BRADFORD. AYE
GLAZER. GROVE JONES. NÓ MCGUIRE.
AYE WEN. NØ PADILLA. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE ON A VOTE OF 28 TO 7, THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP, FILE
ITEM 204. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
1577. SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. ALVARADO, GIL. BRADFORD
AYE. GROVE NØ MCGUIRE. PADILLA
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS PADILLA. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE ON A VOTE
OF 30 TO 8, THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM 207,
ASSEMBLY BILL 2119. SECRETARY,
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. ALVARADO,
GIL. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE, MENGIBAR. AYE. PADILLA
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 38 TO 0, THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'LL MOVE NOW TO FILE
ITEM 258. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2286. SECRETARY, OPEN THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO, GIL BECKER,
GROVE. LAIRD. AYE MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. HOLD ON, GUYS, HOLD
ON. IF YOU'RE MISSED, LET THE
ROLL FINISH AND THEN WE'LL I'LL
GIVE YOU A PAUSE SO YOU CAN ADD
YOUR VOTE. OKAY. BUT PLEASE PAY
ATTENTION SO WE DON'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH IT A SECOND TIME.
SECRETARY. I'M SORRY. PLEASE
CONTINUE CALLING THE ROLL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WHEN NILO AYE
PADILLA AYE. SEYARTO SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. MANY WOMEN? NO AYE. MEN.
NO. AYE DALLEY I DON'T KNOW.
SENATOR ALLEN, DID YOU HAVE.
AYE. ALLEN. AYE ALL RIGHT. ON A
VOTE OF ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 3,
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING NOW
TO FILE ITEM 260. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2245. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GIL. BECKER. AYE GROVE.
LAIRD AYE. MCGUIRE PADILLA. AYE
RATH. WAHAB GIVING EVERYBODY THE
PREGNANT PAUSE ON A VOTE OF 27
TO 8. GROVE. NÓ ROTH. AYE. WAHAB
ON A VOTE OF 28 IN FAVOR AND
NINE AGAINST, THE MEASURE PASSES
AFTER WE FINISH THE ROLL, I'LL
GIVE A PAUSE. IN CASE YOU WANT
TO SWITCH YOUR VOTE. OKAY MOVING
TO FILE ITEM 261 AB 2022.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO, GIL
LAIRD. AYE. MCGUIRE NGUYEN OCHOA.
PADILLA AYE. STERN AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 30 TO 6, THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 268. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
1038. SECRETARY CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GIL
BECKER. DALI. BECKER. AYE DALI.
GROVE LAIRD. AYE MCGUIRE. NGUYEN
PADILLA. AYE SEYARTO. STERN AYE.
ON A VOTE OF 33 TO 1, THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 281. ASSEMBLY BILL
892. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL.
LAIRD. AYE. MCGUIRE MIN. AYE
PADILLA. STERN AYE. BY THE AYE.
AYE.
ON A VOTE OF 30 IN FAVOR. EIGHT
AGAINST. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 19. THIS
IS SB 758. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GIL. BECKER. AYE
MCGUIRE. NGUYEN NØ. PADILLA AYE.
STERN AYE. AYE ON A VOTE OF 30
TO 8, THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL
MOVE NOW TO FILE ITEM 24. THIS
IS SB 919. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GIL ARCHULETA, MCGUIRE.
PADILLA. AYE STERN. AYE SEN.
ARCHULETA. AYE WAS THERE WAS
THERE A VOTE CHANGED THERE?
SENATOR. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILMORE THERE WE ARE.
THANK YOU. ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0,
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NOW TO FILE ITEM 28.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 988.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL DALY,
MCGUIRE. NGUYEN NILO PADILLA.
AYE. STERN AYE. DALI. NO. ON A
VOTE OF 33 TO 3, THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'LL MOVE NOW TO FILE
ITEM 32. THIS IS SB 1130.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GIL
MCGUIRE. OCHOA B¢O. PADILLA A
STERN AYE ON A VOTE OF 34 TO 3,
THE MEASURE PASSES. ITEM 33, SB
1177, PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GIL. DALY GROVE. JONES
MCGUIRE. AYE NGUYEN, NILO.
OCHOA. PADILLA AYE. SEYARTO
STERN. AYE WIENER. AYE. AYE
NGUYEN. NØ ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 1,
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT STEP.
FILE ITEM 39, THIS IS SB SEVEN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GIL
MCGUIRE. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN. AYE.
WIENER AYE. ON A VOTE OF 31 TO
8, THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
89. ASSEMBLY BILL 2670.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL
GONZALEZ. AYE. JONES OCHOA. NÓ.
PADILLA AYE. SKINNER AYE. STERN.
AYE WIENER. AYE JONES. NO. ON A
VOTE OF 31 TO 8, THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVE TO FILE ITEM 108.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1975.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GIL BRADFORD DODD
BRADFORD. AYE. DODD GONZALEZ.
AYE. JONES PADILLA. AYE DODD.
AYE SEYARTO. SKINNER AYE. STERN
AYE. WIENER AYE. ON A VOTE OF 37
TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES. ITEM
111. ASSEMBLY BILL 2319.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO, GIL.
BRADFORD GONZALEZ. AYE. HURTADO
AYE. MILO OCHOA. BOGH PADILLA.
AYE. SKINNER AYE. STERN AYE.
WIENER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. NILO.
NØ ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 6, THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL MOVE NOW
TO FILE ITEM 115. ASSEMBLY BILL
2552. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL.
DODD. EGGMAN AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
HURTADO PADILLA. HURTADO AYE.
PADILLA AYE. SKINNER. AYE STERN.
AYE. WIENER AYE. HURTADO I DON'T
KNOW. ATKINS I DON'T KNOW. DODD.
DODD. DODD NO. ON A VOTE OF 28
TO 11, THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 165. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2642.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GIL
GONZALEZ. AYE. HURTADO Ã. OCHOA
NÓ. PADILLA AYE. SKINNER AYE.
WIENER AYE. ON A VOTE OF 31 TO
8, THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
STEP. FILE ITEM 184. ASSEMBLY
BILL, 1963. SECRETARY, CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO, GIL.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER I BRADFORD,
DODD GONZALEZ. PADILLA AYE.
SKINNER AYE. WIENER AYE. DODD,
AYE. ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 8, THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP, FILE
ITEM 214. ASSEMBLY BILL 347.
SECRETARY, CALL ABSENT MEMBERS,
PLEASE. ALVARADO, GIL. GONZALEZ.
AYE HURTADO, MC. HURTADO. AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. NEWMAN OCHOA.
PADILLA AYE. SKINNER AYE. WIENER
AYE. ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 7, THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP. FILE
ITEM 231. ASSEMBLY BILL 2447.
SECRETARY, CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS, PLEASE. ALLEN ALVARADO,
GIL ARCHULETA. BECKER GROVE.
PADILLA SKINNER. WIENER PADILLA.
AYE WIENER. AYE SKINNER. AYE.
GROVE AYE. ON A VOTE OF 35 TO 1,
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP,
FILE ITEM 234, THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 2537. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL.
OCHOA. PADILLA OCHOA. BONO
ALVARADO. GIL. I MEAN PADILLA.
AYE. WIENER AYE. ON A VOTE OF 31
TO 8, THE MEASURE PASSES. LAST
ITEM ON CALL FILE ITEM 125.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2057. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO,
GIL ASHBY. AYE. RUBIO SKINNER.
AYE ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE 2910 D 2110 D, THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON RULES SB 299,
SB 537, SB 707, AND SB 1266. 30.
SENATOR GONZALEZ, FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO ADD
AB 2901 FILE ITEM 221 TO THE
INACTIVE FILE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MAJORITY LEADER AGUILAR
CURRY. THE DESK WILL NOTE.
SENATOR ROTH, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. REQUEST THAT WE MOVE
AB 2914, FILE ITEM NUMBER 66 TO
THE ENACTED FILE. THE DESK WILL
NOTE. ALL RIGHT.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING
FILE ITEM 181. ASSEMBLY BILL
869. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 869 BY SENATOR.
MEMBER WOULD AN ACT RELATING TO
HOSPITALS. SENATOR ROTH, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL PROVIDES
SMALL RURAL DISTRICT AND
FINANCIALLY DISTRESSED HOSPITALS
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO REQUEST
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
ACCESS AND INFORMATION KNOWN AS
HCCI, TO GRANT AN UP TO THREE
YEAR DELAY IN THEIR SEISMIC
SAFETY COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS.
THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS HCCI TO
APPROVE AN ADDITIONAL UP TO TWO
YEAR DELAY FOR HOSPITALS THAT
CONTINUE TO BE IN FINANCIAL
DISTRESS OR NEED TO ADDRESS
CONTRACTOR LABOR AND MATERIAL
DELAYS, GOVERNMENT ENTITLEMENTS
OR OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES BEYOND
THE HOSPITAL'S CONTROL. IN
EITHER CASE, THE HOSPITAL WILL
BE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE HCCI WITH
A PROPOSED COMPLIANCE PLAN AND
MEET AGREED UPON PROGRESS
MILESTONES IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
THE DELAY. THE BILL ALSO EXPANDS
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE SMALL AND
RURAL HOSPITAL RELIEF PROGRAM,
AND PROVIDES GRANTS TO THOSE
HOSPITALS TO SECURE STRUCTURAL
CATEGORY PERFORMANCE. CATEGORY
FOUR D ASSESSMENTS AND PLAN FOR
THEIR 2030 SEISMIC SAFETY
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS. WE'RE
ALL AWARE THAT MANY HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE EXPERIENCING
DIFFICULT FINANCIAL SITUATIONS,
BUT HOSPITALS COVERED BY THIS
BILL HAVE Ã CONTINUALLY HAVE
CONTINUALLY FACED FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES DUE TO THE LOCATION
AND POPULATIONS THAT THEY SERVE.
THIS BILL IS A TARGETED APPROACH
TO HELP PRESERVE A SMALL NUMBER
OF HOSPITALS THAT ARE MOST OFTEN
A COMMUNITY'S ONLY ACCESS TO
EMERGENCY CARE, AND ARE LIKELY
TO CLOSE IF SOME ASSISTANCE IN
MEETING SEISMIC REQUIREMENTS IS
NOT PROVIDED. THE AUTHOR HAS
WORKED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION, THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND HCCI TO
INCORPORATE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OFFERED THERE HAS
BEEN NO OPPOSITION, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR ROTH.
SENATOR CABALLERO, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. FOLKS, YOU'LL
REMEMBER THAT THIS BODY PASSED
OFF MY LEGISLATION THAT DOES THE
EXACT SAME THING, WHAT WE ARE
TRYING TO DO IS TO CREATE A
FRAMEWORK SO THAT HOSPITALS WILL
MEET THEIR COMPLIANCE
REQUIREMENTS BY 2030. IF THEY
CAN. AND IF THEY CAN'T, THEY
HAVE TO GO TO HK AND THEY'VE GOT
TO ASK FOR PERMISSION TO EXTEND
THE TIME. THE REASON THIS
BECOMES IMPORTANT IS THE ONLY
OPTION THAT REMAINS. IF WE DON'T
DO THIS EXTENSION, IS THAT THE
HOSPITAL LOSES ITS LICENSE,
HAVING BEEN IN A SITUATION WHERE
ONE OF THE HOSPITALS IN MY
DISTRICT HAD TO CLOSE AND THEY
ARE STRUGGLING TO REOPEN, I CAN
TELL YOU THAT IT HAS DEVASTATING
IMPACTS ON THE LOCAL COMMUNITY,
ON THEIR HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AND THEIR ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
GET EMERGENCY CARE SERVICES. SO
THIS IS REALLY, REALLY
IMPORTANT. AND MANY OF THE
ELEMENTS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN MY
BILL ARE ALSO INCLUDED IN THIS
BILL TO PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF
THE PROCESS THAT GIVES HK THE
AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO GRANT
THESE EXTENSIONS OF TIME. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON THIS AS WELL. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SENATOR ROTH, YOU MAY
CLOSE. HE ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE,
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ALVARADO. GILL.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DAWLEY I
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLASER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LEHMAN I MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN
I NILA I OCHOA I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
CIERTO I SKINNER I SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB I
WIENER I WILK I PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALVARADO GILL
MCGUIRE, SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. ON A
VOTE OF 37 TO 0. THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM. I SEE A
MICROPHONE UP FROM SENATOR
ALLEN. SO WE'LL GO BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR
ALLEN, WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE,
MR. PRESIDENT, THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR. WE'D LIKE TO MOVE AB
1917 TO THE INACTIVE FILE. THE
DESK WILL NOTE. SENATOR BECKER
FOR MY TWIN. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
MOVE AB. NO, I'M KIDDING. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE
MOVE. 2959 ORTEGA FILE ITEM 119
TO THE INACTIVE FILE DESK WILL
NOTE REDUNDANCY FOR SENATOR
ALLEN IS SOMETIMES APPRECIATED.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT, WE'RE DONE. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING I'M GOING
TO TRY TO GIVE YOU A HEADS UP IN
TERMS OF THE ORDER IN WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH IT.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM 126 FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM
144, 149 AND 151. FOR AUTHORS.
FOR MANAGERS THERE, PLEASE BE
AWARE SENATOR MIN, SENATOR RUBIO,
SENATOR MENGIBAR. SENATOR MIN.
LET'S GO WITH FILE ITEM 126.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2295. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2295
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OTIS. AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMES. SENATOR MIN.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARDIS,
I PRESENT AB 2295. IT'S A
SUPPORT SUPPORT BILL THAT WOULD
HELP SURVIVORS OF CHILD SEXUAL
ABUSE. SO I THINK YOU SHOULD
VOTE FOR IT IF THEY'RE DONE
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EXCUSE ME.
IS THIS ELIGIBLE? THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES 38. NO,
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. AND
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
144. THIS ASSEMBLY BILL 1511.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATOR
RUBIO.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1511 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO. AN ACT TO STATE
GOVERNMENT. SENATOR RUBIO, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 11 1511 ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO,
WHICH SEEKS TO INTEGRATE ETHNIC
AND COMMUNITY MEDIA OUTLETS IN
THE STATE'S OUTREACH EFFORTS TO
BETTER INFORM AND EDUCATE
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA'S ETHNIC AND
COMMUNITY MEDIA SECTORS HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF SERVING AS
TRUSTED MESSENGERS OF CULTURALLY
COMPETENT AND COMMUNITY SPECIFIC
NEWS TO UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES,
BUT HAVE BEEN UNDERUTILIZED IN
THE DEPLOYMENT OF STATE OUTREACH
AND ADVERTISING CAMPAIGNS. THIS
BILL AIMS TO REMEDY THIS BY
REQUIRING STATE AGENCIES TO
DEVELOP PLANS FOR INCREASING
OUTREACH AND INVESTMENTS IN THE
ETHNIC COMMUNITY. MEDIA OUTLETS
WITH UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR RUBIO. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER? ANY
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO, GIL ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. ATKINS AYE. BECKER
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. AYE. NHIÀU. AYE.
OCHOA BORG. AYE. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE STERNE AYE. UMBERG. AYE
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
AYES 38. NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
149. ASSEMBLY BILL 3291.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. THE
ASSEMBLY BILL 3291 BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES. AN ACT RELATING TO
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. SENATOR
MENGIBAR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AB 3281 IS THE
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE BILL THAT PROPOSES A
SUCCESSION PLAN FOR AGING
CAREGIVERS AND ALLOWS REGIONAL
CENTERS TO OFFER SERVICES TO
CONSUMERS WHO ARE AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS RATHER THAN WAITING
UNTIL THEY ARE HOMELESS,
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR NIVEAU.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER.
ANY SENATOR WANT TO BE HEARD.
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I, ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS, I
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ DALLEY I
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMON I MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN
I NILO I OCHOA BOGH I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
CIERTO I SKINNER I SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK I PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBER ALVARADO GILL
BECKER I CORTEZ I ON A VOTE OF
38 TO 0. THE MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS, THE MAJORITY
LEADER ASKED THAT I SHARE THIS
INFORMATION WITH YOU ALL. WE'VE
GOTTEN OVER 65 BILLS SO FAR
TODAY. GREAT JOB. WE WILL BREAK
FOR DINNER AT 5 P.M. FOR 30
MINUTES. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 151.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1738. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1738
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY
CARRILLO IN RELATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
SENATOR MIN, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 1738 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO.
THIS SUPPORT SUPPORT BILL
REQUIRES THE DMV TO ESTABLISH A
MOBILE HOMELESS CONNECT PILOT
PROGRAM TO ASSIST PERSONS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITH
OBTAINING AN ID CARD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTIONS.
AYES 38. NOS ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
163. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2531.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2531 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRYANT. AN ACT RELATING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SENATOR MENGIBAR.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AB
2531 WILL INCLUDE YOUTH IN THE
DATA COLLECTION OF INDIVIDUALS
DYING WHILE IN CUSTODY AND
ALIGNS THE DEFINITION OF
IN-CUSTODY DEATHS WITH FEDERAL
STANDARDS, RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR AN I VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I ALVARADO.
GILL ARCHULETA. ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER I
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. I
CORTEZ. AYE. DALI AYE. DODD I
DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I AYE.
GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES. AYE LAIRD I LIMON I
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MEAN I
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN I NILO I
OCHOA BOGH I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I SATO
I SKINNER I SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I
STERN, I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER,
I WILK, I REALLY MISSING THERE
ARCHULETA I ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS THESE
NEXT SIX ITEMS ALL HAVE SUPPORT
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES AND ARE
ELIGIBLE. I'M GOING TO GO
THROUGH THEM STARTING OFF WITH
FILE ITEM ONE 7171, 174, 175,
176 AND 179. THE FLOOR MANAGERS
ARE DOLLY CORTEZ, ALLEN LIMÓN
PADILLA, LIMÓN CABALLERO. WE'LL
BEGIN FIRST WITH AGAIN, THESE
ARE ALL SUPPORT SUPPORT FILE
ITEM 170 AB 1868. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1868
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. AN
ACT RELATING TO TAXATION.
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 1868. IT ADDRESSES A
WIDE VARIANCE BETWEEN
JURISDICTIONS ABOUT ASSESSING
THE VALUE OF AFFORDABLE HOMES
SOLD TO AND OCCUPIED LOW INCOME
FAMILIES THAT PARTICIPATE IN LOW
INTEREST MORTGAGES. THIS IS AN
ORGANIZATION LIKE HUMANITY
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY, THAT SELLS
HOMES TO INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES WHO
QUALIFY FOR LOW INCOME HOMES.
THIS BILL BASICALLY TAKES CARE
OF LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND ON
THEIR MORTGAGES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS? THIS IS
THIS IS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES. AYES 38. NO,
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 171. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2137. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. THE.
YEAH. HE'S NEXT. HE'S FINE.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON 171. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 174. ASSEMBLY BILL.
SENATE-TV LIMON HERE ON THE
FLOOR. SENATOR SENATE-TV LIMON
IS HERE ON THE FLOOR. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE THAT IN
174. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1842.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1842 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES AN EQUITY TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. THIS HAS SUPPORT
SUPPORT. SENATOR LEÓN. THANK YOU
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. AB
1842 IS A BILL THAT PROHIBITS
COMMERCIAL HEALTH INSURANCE FROM
IMPOSING PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
RULES TO CREATE BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT FOR PATIENTS SUFFERING
FROM SUBSTANCE ABUSE OR
OVERDOSES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AYES 38. NO.
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 175.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2757. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2757
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. AN
ACT RELATING TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. SENATOR PADILLA,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, I'M PRESENTING AB
2757 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA. THIS BILL WOULD
STREAMLINE AND ACCELERATE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN SALTON
SEA AREA AND COMMUNITIES. MOST
IMPACTED BY LITHIUM EXTRACTION
AND FACILITATE COLLABORATION
WITH STATE, FEDERAL, REGIONAL
AND LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS,
ENTITIES AND GOVERNMENTS ON
ISSUES OF MUTUAL INTEREST TO
ADVANCE THE ECONOMY AND QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR RESIDENTS. IN THIS
AREA. IT'S RECEIVED BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, HAS NO NO
VOTES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. AYES 38. NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL MOVE
BACK TO FILE ITEM 171. THIS IS
AB 2137. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2137 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA. AN ACT
RELATING TO HOMELESS AND FOSTER
YOUTH. SENATOR CORTEZ. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2037 2137 ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN QUIRK-SILVA.
THE BILL SUPPORTS HOMELESS AND
FOSTER YOUTH IN EDUCATION BY
STREAMLINING THE ABILITY OF
FOSTER YOUTH, COORDINATING
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE DIRECT
SUPPORT. SENATE AMENDMENTS
NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE BILL,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTION. AYES 38. NO, ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL MOVE
NEXT TO PHIL. ITEM 176. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2574. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2574
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALENCIA.
ENACT RELATED TO ALCOHOL AND
DRUG PROGRAMS. SENATOR LIMON.
THANK YOU. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2574 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VALENCIA. THIS BILL AIMS
TO ENHANCE THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR CERTIFIED
PROGRAMS AND LICENSED FACILITIES
THAT PROVIDE ALCOHOLISM OR DRUG
ABUSE RECOVERY TREATMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION, ANY DEBATE. THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES 30
800. THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVE TO
FILE ITEM 179 AB 3275.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3275 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SONYA. AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. SENATOR
CABALLERO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT SB 3275 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORIA. THIS BILL
SHORTENS THE TIME FRAME FOR
HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS TO PAY
PROVIDERS FOR COMPLETED CLAIMS
TO 30 CALENDAR DAYS,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE. IT IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 38. NO. ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. ALL RIGHT,
WE'RE GOING TO GO. THIS IS THE
ORDER FOR THE NEXT COLLECTION OF
BILLS. IT'S GOING TO BEGIN WITH
ONE FILE ITEM 189. 191, 201 AND
203. THESE ARE FLOOR MANAGERS
NILO BLAKE, SPEAR, CORTEZ AND
BECKER. WE'LL BEGIN FIRST WITH
PHIL. ITEM 189 AB 801. THIS HAS
SUPPORT. SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 801 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOE
PATERSON. AN ACT RELATING TO
PRIVACY. SENATOR MILO. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT, GOOD AFTERNOON OR
GOOD MORNING? I THINK IT'S GOOD
EVENING. AND IT'S GOING TO BE
GOOD NIGHT. MEMBERS AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 801 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMAN JOE PATTERSON. AB
801 WOULD ALLOW A PARENT OR
STUDENT TO REQUIRE SCHOOL
TECHNOLOGY VENDORS. MR.
PRESIDENT. YOU CAN CONTINUE TO
REQUIRE SCHOOL TECHNOLOGY
VENDORS SUCH AS INTERNET
WEBSITES AND MOBILE APPLICATIONS,
TO DELETE THE STUDENT'S PRIVATE
INFORMATION AFTER NO LONGER
BEING ENROLLED AT A K THROUGH 12
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION,
PREVENTING THE VENDORS FROM
SELLING THE STUDENTS INFORMATION
INSTEAD OF ONLY ALLOWING THE
DELETION OF PRIVATE AND
SENSITIVE INFORMATION THROUGH A
SCHOOL. THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
GIVE STUDENTS AND PARENTS THE
DIRECT AUTHORITY TO DELETE THEIR
INFORMATION AS WELL. THE BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS ZERO
NO VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR I'M
SORRY YOU WERE BOTHERED BY THE
NOISE IN THE ROOM. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS Ó
SENATOR JONES. FOR WHAT PURPOSE
DO YOU RISE? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I JUST WANTED TO
OFFER MY SUPPORT ON AB 801,
WHICH IS A SUPPORT SUPPORT BILL,
AND I THINK WE SHOULD ALL
SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE OR ANYTHING ELSE? SORRY.
WITH THAT I GET TO CLOSE. DO I
NOT? SENATOR O'NEILL, YOU NEED
TO WAIT TO BE RECOGNIZED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK, AND I'D LIKE
TO NOW RECOGNIZE YOU TO CLOSE,
SENATOR MILO. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? ALL RIGHT. UNAUTHORIZED
CLOSE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 38. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL MOVE NEXT
TO ITEM 191. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 2446. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2446 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA. AN ACT
RELATING TO MEDI-CAL AND SENATOR
BLAKE SPEARS PRESENTING IT IS
YOUR. THANK YOU, PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2446 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ORTEGA. THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE MEDICALLY NECESSARY
DIAPERS THROUGH MEDI-CAL. RECENT
AMENDMENTS MAKE THE BILL
CONDITIONAL UPON THE STATE
OBTAINING ANY NECESSARY FEDERAL
APPROVALS AND AVAILABLE FEDERAL
FUNDING. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE. IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES
38. NO ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 201.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2866. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2866
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN AND
ACCORDING TO STATE SENATOR
CORTESE, THIS IS A SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS ON MONDAY, OCTOBER 2ND,
2023, ONE YEAR OLD PEYTON COBB
AND 18 MONTH OLD LILLIAN HANNON
LOST THEIR LIVES IN A HORRIFIC
EVENT. THESE CHILDREN WERE AT A
LICENSED HOME DAYCARE LOCATED IN
SAN JOSE, MY HOME TOWN, WHEN
THREE TODDLERS ACCESSED THE
SWIMMING POOL LOCATED ON THE
PREMISES UNSUPERVISED. THIS BILL
AB 2866, WILL HELP PREVENT THIS
TRAGEDY FROM EVER HAPPENING
AGAIN. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR CORTESE, ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 39. NO. ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE THREE MORE MEASURES UP.
ALL ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. THEIR FILE ITEM 203.
BECKER IS THE FLOOR MANAGER. 210
EGGMAN AND 216 HURTADO.
MEMBERS, WE'RE MAKING GOOD
PROGRESS. AND THANK YOU FOR
GIVING EVERYONE, EVERY SENATOR,
YOUR ATTENTION. WE'RE MOVING
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 203. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2925. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
ASSEMBLY BILL 2925 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND ACT RELATING
TO POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL REQUIRES
COLLEGE CAMPUSES TO INCLUDE
TRAINING TO COMBAT AND ADDRESS
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST THE FIVE
MOST TARGETED GROUPS IN THE
STATE AS PART OF ANY ANTI
DISCRIMINATION TRAINING OR DEI
INITIATIVES OFFERED THE OFFICE.
THE AUTHORS HAD A CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS CONCERNS THE
BILL WOULD UNINTENTIONALLY LEAVE
OUT GROUPS NOT IN THE TOP FIVE.
IT'S A PRIORITY BILL FOR THE
JEWISH CAUCUS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 30 900. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 210. ASSEMBLY BILL 2058.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2058 BY SENATE MEMBER
WEBER. AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. AB
2058 REQUIRES THE MANUFACTURER
OF A DEVICE THAT COLLECTS DATA
FROM YOUR PHYSIOLOGICAL MATTER
TO DO SOME KIND OF DISCLOSURE.
THERE'S A COUPLE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS ABOUT WHERE THEY CAN DO
THAT, THAT SOME OF THE DEVICES
THAT USE THIS KIND OF DATA CAN
BE WRONG FOR YOUR SIZE, PER YOUR
SKIN COLOR AND OR TONE. SO
PEOPLE SHOULD BE AWARE OF THAT.
I'D ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR EGGMAN FOR THAT
INFORMATIVE PRESENTATION. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MATTER? THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES 30 900.
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL MOVE
NEXT TO FINAL ITEM 216. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3145. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3145 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYANT. AN ACT
RELATING TO CHILD WELFARE.
SENATOR HURTADO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
3145 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRYANT. THIS BILL IS
SUPPORT. SUPPORT, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR HURTADO. ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES 39. NØ
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. ALL
RIGHT, WE'RE GOING TO THE NEXT
FOUR BILLS. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
UP. MEMBERS ARE 217, 229, 230
AND 238. FLOOR MANAGERS ARE
ALLEN, PADILLA, RUBIO AND LAIRD.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH ITEM 217. AB
2331. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2331 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL. AN ACT RELATING
TO CARBON OFFSETS. SENATOR
ALLEN. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
PLEASED TO PRESENT. 2331, WHICH
IS A CLEAN UP BILL TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATION FOR
BUYERS AND SELLERS OF VOLUNTARY
CARBON OFFSET CREDITS. LAST
YEAR, AS YOU ALL KNOW, WE OF
COURSE PASSED AB 1305, WHICH
ESTABLISHED DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS FOR BUYERS AND
SELLERS OF THESE OFFSET CREDITS
AND ENTITIES MAKING CLAIMS ABOUT
MAJOR EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS. THIS
CLEAN UP. THIS MEASURE WILL
CLARIFY THAT THE FIRST ANNUAL
DISCLOSURES HAVE TO BE PUBLISHED
ON AN ENTITY'S INTERNET
WEBSITES. THEY HAVE TO MAKE
MAKES A COUPLE OF OTHER
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO HELP
FACILITATE IMPLEMENTATION. NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION. BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ASKED FOR A VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
DISCUSSION MEMBERS. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALI. AYE. DODD PASO. I. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
NILO AYE. OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE. ON A
VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS THE NEXT TWO
ITEMS ARE ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL FILE ITEM
229 AND 230 FOR STEP 229. AB
2922. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2922 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA, AN ACT RELATING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SEN.
PADILLA. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2922 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. THE BILL
EXTENDS THE AUTHORIZATION FOR
CAPITAL INVESTMENT INCENTIVE
PROGRAM UNTIL JANUARY 1ST, 2035,
AND AUTHORIZES CIP FOR
PROPONENTS OF QUALIFIED
MANUFACTURING FACILITIES WITH AN
ASSESSED VALUE EXCEEDING $25
MILLION. ADDITIONALLY, IT
INTRODUCES LABOR REQUIREMENTS
AND JOB CREATION PLAN FOR THESE
PROPONENTS. THIS BILL HAS HAD NO
OPPOSITION AND NO VOTES, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SEN. PADILLA.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AYES 39. NÓ ZERO. AND THE
URGENCY. AYES 30 900. ON THE
MEASURE. MOVING ON TO ITEM 230.
AB 2843. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2843 BY SENATE
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS. AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. SENATOR RUBIO IS
PRESENTING. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2843 WHICH WILL
PROHIBIT INSURERS FROM CHARGING
RAPE SURVIVORS FOR MEDICAL
SERVICES AND CARE RELATED TO
THEIR ASSAULT, RAPE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT. STATISTICS ARE
STAGGERING AND VERY FEW COME
FORWARD. IT IS HARD ENOUGH TO
DEAL WITH THE CHALLENGE OF THE
PAIN, THE STRESS AND THE TRAUMA.
WE SHOULD NOT ADD THE COST TO
IT. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTIONS. AYES
39. NÓ ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO DO TWO MORE
MEASURES BEFORE WE BREAK SO
EVERYONE CAN KEEP THEIR
ATTENTION FOCUSED. WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN WITH ITEM. 238 AND THEN
FILE ITEM 253. 238. FLOOR
MANAGER LAIRD, IT'S AB 2207.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2207 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES. AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. SENATOR LAIRD. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS BILL
WOULD INCREASE THE
REPRESENTATION OF OLDER ADULTS
ON THREE STATE BOARDS,
COMMISSIONS AND ADVISORY
COMMITTEES TO ALIGN WITH THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING. THERE'S
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THIS IS POSSIBLE. UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL MEMBERS. ANYONE OBJECT TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL?
SEEING NO OBJECTION. AYES 39. NÓ
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL
END OUR AFTERNOON SESSION WITH A
FINAL ITEM. 253. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2237. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ.
THE. ASSEMBLY BILL 2237 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY. AN
ACT RELATING TO MEDICAL SENATOR
MENGIBAR. THANK YOU SIR. WHEN
YOUTH MOVED FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY, THEIR MENTAL HEALTH CARE
IS HALTED WHILE THEY REESTABLISH
ELIGIBILITY FOR SERVICES. AB
2237 REQUIRES THAT DCS ISSUE
GUIDANCE TO SUPPORT THOSE KIDS
WHO GO FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY,
AND WILL ISSUE COUNTIES TO
COORDINATE AND EXPEDITE THE
TRANSFER OF SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FROM ONE COUNTRY
TO ANOTHER. RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT.
JUST A POINT FOR FUTURE
REFERENCE FOR ALL THE SENATORS
HERE. IF THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
GOOD BILL IDEAS, IT WOULD BE
GREAT IF WE JUST HAD ONE
MEDI-CAL. YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO
CHANGE IT WHEN YOU WENT FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY TO GET A
STATEWIDE MEDI-CAL WOULD MAKE
THINGS SO MUCH EASIER. THANK YOU.
I KNOW THAT RELATED TO THE BILL
IN QUESTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SENATOR EGGMAN. SENATOR
MENGIBAR, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE. SENATOR
MENGIBAR, YOU GET TO CLOSE. ONCE
AGAIN, RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THIS IS
YOUR ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AYES 30 900. THE MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT, WELL, THAT WAS A GOOD
RUN. YOU GET APPLAUSE FOR THAT.
AS PER THE DIRECTION OF OUR
MAJORITY LEADER, WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A DINNER BREAK OF 30
MINUTES. 30 MINUTES ASKING THAT
YOU REMAIN HERE IN THE CAPITOL,
SO THAT WE CAN COME BACK AND
CONTINUE OUR WORK. WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO. STILL APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR HELP. WE'LL BE IN
RECESS.
THE EVENING SESSION AND GET OUR
WORK DONE.
GOOD EVENING AGAIN, SENATORS.
WE'RE ABOUT TO BEGIN OUR SENATE
SESSION. WE WANT TO INVITE ALL
THE SENATORS TO COME BACK INTO
THE CHAMBERS. SENATORS, WE'D
LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO COME BACK
INTO THE CHAMBERS AND GET TO OUR
DESKS SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD. SERGEANTS, CAN YOU CALL
THE MEMBERS INTO THE CHAMBER,
PLEASE?
MEMBERS. GOOD EVENING AGAIN.
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE ALL THE
MEMBERS TO COME BACK TO THE
CHAMBERS AND TAKE THEIR SEATS.
SENATORS, PLEASE. IF WE COULD
CURB THE CONVERSATIONS NOW AND
INVITE MEMBERS TO COME BACK TO
THE SENATE AND TAKE THEIR SEATS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO THIS
EVENING, AND WE NEED EVERYONE'S
HELP.
SENATORS, IF I COULD GET YOUR
ATTENTION, PLEASE. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE BACK TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS. THIS IS GOING TO BE
FILE ITEM 15, SB 310. I'D LIKE
TO ASK THE SECRETARY TO READ.
SENATOR DODD IS PRESENTING.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 310 BY SENATOR DODD. AN ACT
RELATING TO FIRE PREVENTION. ALL
RIGHT, SENATOR DODD, THIS IS
YOUR BILL COMING BACK ON
AMENDMENTS. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. YOU'RE REALLY DOING A
FINE JOB THIS EVENING. THANK
YOU, SIR. DODD. I OKAY. MR.
PRESIDENT, MEMBERS SB 310
PERTAINING TO CULTURAL BURNING
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE IN THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS DO THE FOLLOWING. ADD
MORE ROBUST FINDINGS. LIMIT THE
TYPES OF AGREEMENTS BETWEEN A
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBE AND THE
SECRETARY OF NATURAL RESOURCES.
AUTHORIZED BUT NOT MANDATE, AIR
QUALITY DISTRICTS TO ENTER INTO
AGREEMENTS, ELIMINATED ADVISORY,
WORKGROUP AND MOVE THE SUNSET
BACK ONE YEAR. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALI. AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. ECKMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE. NILO. AYE. OKUBO. AYE.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO. AYE CIERTO. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME AND
THEN CLOSE THE ROLL. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. Ó. WE'RE
GOING TO GO ON CALL. OKAY, SO
THAT WOULD BE SEN DODD MUSICAL.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DODD. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 22.
SENATOR UMBERG BILL, SB 900.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 900 BY SENATOR UMBERG. AN
ACT RELATING TO COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS. SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, THE
AMENDMENTS TO SB 900 SIMPLY
CLARIFY THAT IF THE BOARD OF
ASSOCIATION FAILS TO FIX
WIDESPREAD OUTAGES IN 14 DAYS,
THEN THE QUORUM FOR THE NEXT
MEETING IS REDUCED. URGENT. I
VOTE ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GIL.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DADDY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
OKUBO. AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE. SEN.
UMBERG MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM 25 BY SENATOR CIERTO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 936 BY SENATOR CIERTO. AN
ACT RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION.
SENATOR. CIERTO, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
SB 936 IS BACK HERE ON
CONCURRENCE FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN WERE
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING. THE
BILL HAS EARNED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALI AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON.
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
NILO WENT. AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO. AYE.
SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE. GÂY. FROM
I MEAN, I MEANT AYE. JONES. AYE
SENATOR. CIERTO MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
30. THIS IS SENATE BILL 1064.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1064 BY SENATOR LAIRD. AN
ACT RELATING TO CANNABIS.
SENATOR LAIRD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS SIMPLIFY THE
LICENSING SCHEME BY COMBINING A
COUPLE OF CATEGORIES. THERE'S
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE. THIS IS
A 27 VOTE BILL. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
AYE. OKUBO. AYE. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. ACIERTO. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE
SENATOR LAIRD MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 34. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1184 BY SENATOR EGGMAN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1184 BY SENATOR EGGMAN. AN
ACT TO MENTAL HEALTH. SENATOR
EGGMAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
1184 IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE FROM
THE ASSEMBLY, HAVING TO DO WITH
REESE HEARINGS AND EXIGENT
REASONS. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY SENATOR WANT
TO BE HEARD ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NO FURTHER DEBATE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BREAKSPEARE. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO. AYE. EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
THAT WAS COOL. AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE SENATOR EGGMAN
MOVES A CALL. THAT WAS A
TERRIFIC ROLL CALL. THERE BY THE
WAY, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. PURSUANT TO
JOINT RULE 33.1, JOINT RULE 61
WILL BE SUSPENDED TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY BILL 3261 TO BE AMENDED
AFTER THE DEADLINE. THIS REQUEST
HAS BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU, MISTER PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, THERE IS A RESOLUTION
AT THE DESK REQUESTING
PERMISSION TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
61 FOR THE PURPOSE OF ALLOWING
ASSEMBLY BILL 3129 AND 2348 TO
BE AMENDED AFTER THE DEADLINE.
THESE REQUESTS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE. OKAY. SENATOR CIERTO,
FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? I
RISE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DECLARING THAT WE ARE RULE
FOLLOWERS, AND THEREFORE WE DO
NOT WISH TO SUPPORT THIS
ABERRATION OF THE RULES. WE ASK
FOR A NO VOTE, AND WE ASK FOR 13
OF OUR GREAT COLLEAGUES FROM THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE TO JOIN
US. THANK YOU SENATOR CIERTO.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE CLERK TO
READ THE RESOLUTION. RESOLVE
THAT JOINT RULE 61 BE DISPENSED
WITH. SENATOR GONZALEZ IS ASKING
FOR A AYE VOTE AND SENATOR
CIERTO IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE VOTE.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY. NØ. DODD AYE. AYE.
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO.
NO. OCHOA. NO PADILLA.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
ACIERTO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GILL. MEN AYE. PADILLA.
AYE ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 8, THE
JOINT RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, THERE IS
A RESOLUTION AT THE DESK
REQUESTING PERMISSION TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE 61 AND 62 A FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ALLOWING ASSEMBLY
BILLS ONE, 80 TO 18 AND 2348 TO
BE HEARD IN POLICY AND FISCAL
COMMITTEES AFTER THE DEADLINE.
THESE REQUESTS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR GONZALEZ. I
SEE A MICROPHONE UP FROM SENATOR
SECRETO. SENATOR THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AS WE RECOVER FROM
OUR DISAPPOINTMENT OVER THE LAST
VOTE, WE ONCE AGAIN STAND TO
OPPOSE THESE DEVIATION OF THE
RULES AND ASK FOR A NO VOTE,
WHICH WE CAN DO WITH THE
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL. THANK YOU.
SENATOR SECRETO. IF WE COULD
HAVE THE RESOLUTION READ.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION. RESOLVE THAT JOINT
RULE 61 AND 62. BE DISPENSED
WITH. WHAT WAS THE VOTE? ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE PREVIOUS
ROLL CALL? SEEING NONE. IT'S A
VOTE OF 31 AYES. EIGHT NOES. THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. THANK YOU
ALL.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. THIS
IS FILED ITEM 53 FOR ALL OF YOU
FOLLOWING ALONG AT HOME. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 1964 MANAGED BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. A SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL, 1960
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
AND ACT RELATING TO SENTENCING.
SENATOR NEWMAN. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE ON
BEHALF OF SPEAKER RIVAS TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 1960,
WHICH RESTORES AN IMPORTANT TOOL
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT IN COMBATING
RETAIL THEFT. SPECIFICALLY, IT
REINSTATES A TIERED SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENT IF THE VALUE OF
PROPERTY STOLEN OR DAMAGED
DURING A FELONY EXCEEDS CERTAIN
VALUE THRESHOLDS. THE BILL
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL TOOLS FOR
TOOLS FOR POLICE AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S TO PROSECUTE AND
DETER THOSE WHO WOULD COMMIT AND
PROFIT FROM SMASH AND GRAB
ROBBERIES AND ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT RINGS. AB 1960 IS PART OF
THE LEGISLATURE'S COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE OF BILLS TO ADDRESS
RETAIL CRIME IN A MEANINGFUL AND
BALANCED WAY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE SPEAKER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR NEWMAN. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION, MEMBERS SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY ATKINS. AYE BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE. OCHOA.
BOGH. AYE PADILLA. PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I DON'T KNOW.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. WILK AYE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GIL. ASHBY AYE. DURAZO
MENGIBAR MIN. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
WIENER SKINNER. I DON'T KNOW. ON
A VOTE OF 34 TO 2, THE MEASURE
PASSES. ALL RIGHT. NEXT ON THE
DOCKET, FOLKS, IS FILE ITEM 61.
FILE FOLLOWED BY FILE. ITEM 104.
61 IS AB 2292. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2292 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
AN ACT RELATING TO ELECTRICITY.
SENATOR PADILLA, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AB 2292 REPEALS THE REQUIREMENT
THAT THE CPUC CONSIDER
ALTERNATIVES TO PROSPECTIVE
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS BEFORE
ISSUING A MAJOR PERMIT APPROVAL
IN ORDER TO MEET OUR CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS. THIS CAPACITY WILL
NEED TO GROW SIGNIFICANTLY IN
THE NEXT TWO DECADES. TODAY,
MAJOR PROJECTS MUST BE REVIEWED
TWICE TO DETERMINE IF THEY ARE
NEEDED, ONCE BY ISO AND ONCE BY
THE PUC. AB 22 2292 PROPOSES
MODEST BUT IMPORTANT CHANGES TO
SUPPORT FASTER TRANSMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT IN
OUR STATE. THIS BILL HAS HAD NO
NO VOTES. RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
PADILLA, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. DODD AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN NO. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES
NO. LAIRD. AYE LIMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. NO. OCHOA BOG. PADILLA.
AYE PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO!
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE MEMBERS, SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLL ONE LAST TIME AND CLOSE THE
ROLL. ALVARADO GILL. DAWLEY. NO
GROVE. NO. NO WHEN OCHOA. ON A
VOTE OF 30 TO 7, THE MEASURE
PASSES. ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS, THE
NEXT FEW ITEMS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE UP ARE AS FOLLOWS. FILE
ITEM 104, FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM
122, 124, 139 AND 152. THAT'S
FLOOR MANAGERS, SENATORS WIENER,
CABALLERO, SMALLWOOD, CUEVAS,
WIENER AND SKINNER. SO NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM 104, AB 1826.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1826 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN. AN ACT RELATING TO
COMMUNICATIONS. SENATOR WIENER,
I THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1826 THE DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE
AND VIDEO COMPETITION ACT OF
2024 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN HAS BEEN COMMITTED TO
REVISING DIFFICULT OVER THE PAST
THREE YEARS BECAUSE HE
UNDERSTANDS IT TO BE A CRITICAL
TOOL NEEDED TO ADDRESS THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. THIS BILL WILL
UPDATE DIVKA OF 2006 BY
REFORMING THE STATE VIDEO
FRANCHISING PROCESS AT THE CPUC
AND CREATING A TRANSPARENT
PUBLIC PROCESS BY REQUIRING
ADDITIONAL REPORTING ON
FRANCHISE HOLDERS AND INCREASING
CUSTOMER SERVICE VIOLATION FINES
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR'S AB 41,
THIS BILL DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
EQUAL ACCESS PROVISIONS. AB 1826
INCREASES FINES FOR VIOLATIONS
OF CERTAIN CUSTOMER SERVICE
RULES AND EXPANDS OPPORTUNITIES
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND GROUPS TO
PARTICIPATE IN CABLE FRANCHISE
APPLICATIONS AND RENEWALS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR WIENER,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION? MEMBERS SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALLY. NÓ. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR MAN.
AYE. NEWMAN NO. NGUYEN. NO.
NILO. NO. OCHOA NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. NO DODD. I DON'T
KNOW. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME. BROUGH.
GILL BECKER. GLAZER JONES. NO
MENGIBAR. AYE PORTANTINO. UMBERG
ON A VOTE OF 25 TO 10, THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP, FILE
ITEM 122. THIS IS AB 52.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 52 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON. AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. TAX LEVY. SENATOR
CABALLERO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
52 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
INCENTIVIZE LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS AND FUEL EXPANSION
IN CALIFORNIA'S MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY BY PROVIDING A STATE
TAX CREDIT UPON LEGISLATIVE
APPROPRIATION FOR THE LOCAL
SALES TAX PAID BY MANUFACTURERS
FOR QUALIFIED EQUIPMENT
PURCHASES. THIS WILL FACILITATE
THE GROWTH, HIRING, AND TRAINING
OF A SKILLED WORKFORCE AND
PROVIDE HIGH WAGE JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR CABALLERO. MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE? IT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES 30 900.
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
ITEM 124. AB 1905. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL, 1905
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ARDIS. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT, I GET IT. SUPPORT
SUPPORT MEMBERS, I HEAR YOU. ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARDIS,
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT. 1905 AB
1905 AS PART OF A CALL TO ACTION
BILL PACKAGE TO ADDRESS SEX
DISCRIMINATION AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
AB 1905 HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION ON
THE MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 39. NØ ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
ITEM 139. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2747. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
YOUR FREELANCING AND NOT PAYING
YOU. OKAY YOU'RE DOING THE JOB.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2747 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY. AN ACT RELATING TO
TENANCY. MEMBERS, PLEASE GIVE
SENATOR WIENER YOUR ATTENTION.
SENATOR WIENER. AYE. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. EXCUSE ME,
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2747 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY. THIS BILL BRINGS
RENT REPORTING UP TO STANDARD
PRACTICE BY REQUIRING LANDLORDS
TO GIVE TENANTS THE ABILITY TO
HAVE THEIR POSITIVE RENT
PAYMENTS COUNT TOWARDS THEIR
CREDIT SCORE. CREDIT SCORES ARE
DESIGNED TO REFLECT THE GOOD AND
THE BAD OF A PERSON'S FINANCIAL
HISTORY. USUALLY, IF A PERSON
MISSES A CREDIT CARD PAYMENT,
THEIR SCORE WILL GO DOWN, AND IF
THEY STAY ON TOP OF THEIR
PAYMENTS, THEIR SCORE WILL
INCREASE. HOWEVER, THIS BALANCE
REPORTING DOES NOT APPLY TO
RENTAL PAYMENTS. MILLIONS OF
RENTERS AROUND THE STATE ARE
PAYING THEIR RENT ON TIME, BUT
UNLIKE OTHER MONTHLY PAYMENTS,
POSITIVE RENT PAYMENTS ARE NEVER
REPORTED TO CREDIT AGENCIES. ON
THE OTHER HAND, ANY RENT
PAYMENTS A TENANT MISSES ARE
REPORTED AND HAVE A NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON THE RENTERS CREDIT
SCORE. AB 2747 WILL MAKE SURE
THAT, LIKE THE MAJORITY OF OTHER
MONTHLY EXPENSES, TENANTS HAVE
THE ABILITY FOR POSITIVE RENT
PAYMENTS TO ALSO COUNT TOWARDS
THEIR CREDIT SCORES. THE
REPORTING IS ENTIRELY OPTIONAL
AND RECENT AMENDMENTS HAVE
REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR WIENER, ANY DISCUSSION
ON THE MEASURE? MEMBERS ANY
MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD. SEEING
NO MICROPHONE'S UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY. NØ DODD.
AYE. DURAZO EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER.
AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE.
NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. NO. MIN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA. NO
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB WIENER. AYE WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL. DURAZO JONES.
MIN PORTANTINO. WAHAB ON A VOTE
OF 26 TO 8, THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 152. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2694. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2694 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD AND ACT RELATING TO
LAND USE. THIS IS SENATOR
SKINNER. THIS HAS SUPPORT
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES. SENATOR
SKINNER, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS AB 2694 CLARIFIES THAT
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY QUALIFY AS SENIOR
CITIZEN HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
UNDER THE DENSITY BONUS LAW. AND
WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR. I
VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE MEASURE? IT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. THAT OBJECTION. AYES 39.
NOS ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS 178.
THAT'S THE ASSEMBLY BILL 1575.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. YES.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1575 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN. AN ACT TO PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION. THIS
ALSO HAS SUPPORT SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES. SENATOR ASHBY, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. MR. PRESIDENT, I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 1575, WHICH IS
CALLED K¾T MEYER'S LAW. ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN,
THE BILL WAS MOTIVATED MOTIVATED
BY A DEVASTATING EXPERIENCE IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN'S DISTRICT.
KATIE MEYER, AN OUTSTANDING
STUDENT ATHLETE AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY, TRAGICALLY TOOK HER
OWN LIFE AFTER RECEIVING A
DISCIPLINARY NOTIFICATION. HER
DEATH IS ONE OF MANY TROUBLING
STORIES OF STUDENT SUICIDES.
KATIE WAS JUST THREE MONTHS SHY
OF GRADUATING FROM LAW SCHOOL. I
URGE AN I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR ASHBY. MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE? ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? IT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES
39. NÓ ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 197, FOLLOWED BY 208. 197
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1984. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1984
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. AN ACT
RELATING TO PUPIL DISCIPLINE.
SENATOR NEWMAN, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOCTOR AKILAH WEBER TO
PRESENT AB 1984, WHICH WILL
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
PUBLISH STUDENT TRANSFER DATA ON
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD
WEBSITE. RECENT REPORTS SUGGEST
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ARE
INCREASINGLY UTILIZING FORCED
TRANSFERS TO ALTERNATIVE SCHOOLS
AS A WAY TO DISCIPLINE STUDENTS
WITHOUT EMPLOYING THE STANDARD
EXPULSION PROCESS, THEREBY
CIRCUMVENTING THE EXTENSIVE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT
PROCESS ENTAILS. AB 1984 WILL
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND ASSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH
NO NO VOTES, THUS FAR AND HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THANK YOU. SENATOR
NEWMAN, ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE? IT IS POSSIBLE WE COULD
GET A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. AYES 30 900. THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 208. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1581.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1581 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA. AN ACT RELATING TO FISH
AND WILDLIFE. SENATOR MARTIN.
THIS HAS SUPPORT SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I'M HAPPY HERE TO PRESENT AB
1581 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN
KALRA. IT EXPANDS AND CODIFIES
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE RESTORATION MANAGEMENT.
PERMIT IT. SUPPORT. SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR MARTIN, FOR A
VERY CONCISE AND COMPELLING
TESTIMONY. MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
MEASURE IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. AYES 3038. NÓ ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
OKAY. MEMBERS. THE NEXT SIX
ITEMS THAT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR.
IF YOU'RE KEEPING TRACK, ARE AS
FOLLOWS AS FOLLOWS. FILE ITEM
215 TWO 2233, 234, TWO 4248 AND
265. FLOOR MANAGERS NEWMAN,
SKINNER, DODD, LIMÓN, SKINNER,
ASHBY AND ASHBY. SO WE'LL MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 215 AB 637.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 637 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACKSON. AN ACT RELATING TO AIR
POLLUTION. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOCTOR COREY
JACKSON TO PRESENT AB 637 WHICH
WILL PROMOTE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
AIR RESOURCE BOARD'S ADVANCED
CLEAN FLEET RULE BY ALLOWING
FLEETS TO COUNT RENTED ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES TOWARD THEIR
ZEV MANDATES. IN DOING SO, AB
637 WILL ALSO HELP COMPANIES
WHICH RENT TRUCKS AND WHICH HAVE
BEEN REQUIRED TO PROCURE ZEV
TRUCKS UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF
THE ACF, TO PUT THOSE ZEV TRUCKS
INTO SERVICE AT HIGHER RATES,
THEREBY ALLOWING THEM TO RECOUP
THEIR INVESTMENTS. AB 637 HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
NO NO VOTES. ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
SEN NEWMAN. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THE MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, THERE IS AN
OBJECTION. ALL RIGHT. ALL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ADRIN. Ã.
ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA I. ASHBY
I. ATKINS, I. BECKER NÓ. BLAKE.
SPEER I. BRADFORD I. CABALLERO.
I. CORTEZ I. DALLEY. I. DODD I.
DURAZO I. EGGMAN I. GLAESER I.
GONZALEZ GROVE I. HURTADO I.
JONES I. LAIRD I. LEHMAN, I.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN NEWMAN. I.
NGUYEN I. NIETO I. OCHOA I.
PADILLA I. PORTANTINO I. ROTH I.
RUBIO. I. SATO I. SKINNER I.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. NO.
UMBERG, I. WAHAB I. WIENER I.
WILK I. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GIL. GONZALEZ
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I. MIN. I.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I. ALLEN. I
DON'T KNOW. ON A VOTE OF 34 TO
3, THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 220. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 653. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 653
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES. AN ACT
TO HUSING. SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS. AB 653 REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO CONVENE
A WORKGROUP TO IMPROVE THE
SUCCESS RATES OF OUR HOUSING
VOUCHER PROGRAM. VOUCHERS ARE A
PROVEN TOOL TO REDUCE HOUSING
INSTABILITY FOR FAMILIES.
HOWEVER, A LARGE NUMBER OF
FAMILIES WHO RECEIVE A VOUCHER
ARE UNABLE TO EVER LEASE. THIS
BILL IS A PRODUCT OF TWO YEARS
OF DISCUSSIONS AND THE MOST
RECENT AMENDMENTS ARE A RESULT
OF NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO IMPROVE THIS
PROCESS. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY NO.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DADDY. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE NILO. OCHOA PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
SUGIARTO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL. DALLEY GROVE.
MCGUIRE MENJIVAR. AYE NILO.
OCHOA BOGUE. PORTANTINO RUBIO.
AYE SUGIARTO. ON A VOTE OF 31 TO
1, THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
233. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 457.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 457 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND ACT RELATING TO
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
DODD. THIS IS SUPPORT. SUPPORT
ON BOTH SIDES. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES. THIS
IS A SIMPLE BILL UNDER SB 1013.
ALL WINE BOXES, REGARDLESS OF
SIZE, WERE ASSIGNED A CRV OF
$0.25 ON THE BOTTLE DEPOSIT. A
SMALL BOXES THAT WAS RETAIL FOR
A FEW DOLLARS THAT ARE SOMETIMES
SOLD IN MULTI-PACKS. THE 25 CENT
DEPOSIT ADDS UP QUICKLY. SO UPON
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT, WE TOOK A
LOOK AT THAT AND SENATOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGAR CURRY HAD
THIS BILL THAT WILL HELP SMALL
WINERIES AND STREAMLINE THE
NUMBER OF REPORTS THEY HAVE TO
SUBMIT TO CALRECYCLE AND WILL BE
LOWERING. THIS WOULD LOWER IT
FROM 25 CENT DEPOSIT TO $0.10.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE. ANY DISCUSSION THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES
38. NØ ZERO. AND THE URGENCY.
AYES 38. NÓ ZERO. ON THE
MEASURE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 240. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2759. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2759 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS. AN ACT
RELATED TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS HB 2759
STRENGTHENS THE EFFICACY OF OUR
LAW THAT PUTS FIREARM
RESTRICTIONS ON PERPETRATORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. UNDER CURRENT
LAW, A PERPETRATOR OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE MAY RETAIN A FIREARM IF
IT'S NECESSARY FOR WORK.
HOWEVER, ADVOCATES FOR VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AGREE THAT
THE CURRENT EXEMPTION IS TOO
LIMITED AND VAGUE, INCREASING
THE POSSIBILITY THAT SOMEONE
RECEIVES AN EXEMPTION WHO SHOULD
NOT. AB 2759 ENACTS SEVERAL
IMPORTANT REVISIONS TO CLARIFY
AND STRENGTHEN THE LAW AND
BETTER PROTECT SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND WITH
THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR SKINNER, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE? THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES
38. NO ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES
THE NEXT TWO MEASURES. WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR. MEMBERS ARE FOR
ITEM 248 AND 265. BOTH HAVE
SUPPORT. SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES.
FIRST UP 248. AB 274. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 274
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYANT. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC, SOCIAL
SERVICES. SENATOR ASHBY. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 274 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ISAAC BRYANT.
274 CLARIFIES THAT SCHOLARSHIPS,
GRANTS AND FELLOWSHIPS FOR
STUDENTS WILL BE EXEMPT FROM
INCOME CALCULATIONS UNDER
CALFRESH AND CALWORKS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THE MEASURE. ANY DISCUSSION. IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES
38. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS ITEM 265 AB
2346. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2346 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE. AN ACT RELATING TO
SOLID WASTE. SENATOR ASHBY.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2346 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALEX LEE. AB
2346 CREATES GREATER FLEXIBILITY
FOR JURISDICTIONS TO MEET THEIR
MANDATED ORGANIC WASTE
COLLECTION TARGETS. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE, THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 30 800. THE
MEASURE PASSES. ALL RIGHT. THE
NEXT THREE ITEMS ON THE SCHEDULE
ARE AS FOLLOWS. BILL ITEM 162,
183, AND 225. WE'LL BEGIN WITH
ITEM 162. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2975. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2975 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON. AN ACT RELATING
TO EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. SENATOR
ROTH. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO IMPROVE
HOSPITAL SAFETY BY REQUIRING
WEAPONS DETECTION SCREENINGS AT
SELECT HOSPITAL ENTRANCES
CONDUCTED BY TRAINED PERSONNEL.
AS FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NHIÀU. OCHOA
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO SEYARTO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER WILK. AYE JONES. AYE
WIENER. AYE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL. DALY GROVE. AYE.
MCGUIRE. NGUYEN. NHIÀU. OCHOA
BOG. RUBIO. AYE SEYARTO. ON A
VOTE OF 33 TO 0, THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP. FILE OUT OF 183
AB 2297. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2297 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALTH CARE. SENATOR LEHMAN.
HOW MANY BILLS IS THIS TODAY? I
BELIEVE IT WOULD BE ABOUT SIX,
SEVEN. EIGHT, MAYBE. OKAY.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT. YOU CAN
PRESENT THE BILL. THANK YOU. AB
2297 WOULD ENHANCE PROTECTIONS
FOR PATIENTS AND ENSURE THAT
HOSPITALS ARE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
CHARITY CARE AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PRACTICES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR LEHMAN,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THE MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION? MEMBERS SEEING
NO MICROPHONES UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY. NO. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE
NEUMANN. AYE. NGUYEN. NØ. NHIÀU.
OCHOA NIELSEN. NO. OCHOA.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK.
NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL. MCGUIRE
OCHOA. UMBERG AYE. ON A VOTE OF
30. IN FAVOR, SEVEN AGAINST. THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM TWO. TWO
FIVE. ASSEMBLY BILL 2235.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2235 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWENTHAL. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC CONTRACTS. MEMBERS,
PLEASE GIVE SENATOR GONZALEZ
YOUR ATTENTION. MEMBERS, PLEASE
GIVE SENATOR GONZALEZ YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU. MISTER
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2235 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL. THIS
PROVIDES THE CITY OF LONG BEACH
AND THE PORT OF LONG BEACH WITH
THE ABILITY TO ENGAGE IN
CONTRACTS SPECIFICALLY RELATING
TO PIER, WIND, AND DETAILS THE
PROJECT DELIVERY METHODS THROUGH
WHICH THOSE CONTRACTS CAN BE
PROCURED. I'M HAPPY TO SHARE
THAT THE AUTHOR WAS ABLE TO WORK
OUT AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
ILWU AND THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES, WHICH IS REFLECTED IN
THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL,
AND THAT REMOVED ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE
HEARD? SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GIL. GROVE. JONES AYE.
MCGUIRE. SEYARTO GROVE. AYE ON A
VOTE OF 37 TO 0, THE MEASURE
PASSES.
OKAY, MEMBERS, WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO OUR SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
NUMBER ONE. MEMBERS SHOULD ALL
HAVE THAT AT THEIR DESKS. THE
STAFFS HAVE BEEN GIVEN IT TO
THEM EARLIER IN THE DAY. YOU
DON'T HAVE A SUPPLEMENTAL FILE.
PLEASE. SO INDICATE SO WE CAN BE
SURE YOU HAVE ONE PHYSICALLY AS
WELL AS IN YOUR SYSTEM. OUR PLAN
IS TO GO THROUGH THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE FINAL TWO
MEASURES, WHICH ARE NOT SLATED
TO BE TAKEN UP AT THIS MOMENT.
THAT'S THE FILE ITEM 415 AND
416. BUT WE'RE PLANNING TO GO
AND DO THE OTHERS. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF THEM THAT ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. AND
THAT IS WHERE WE BEGIN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM 394, SENATE BILL
NUMBER 26 BY SENATOR UMBERG.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 26 BY SENATOR UMBERG. AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
PROFESSIONS. SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. SB 26 CONCERNS CARE
COURT SCHOLARSHIPS, MINOR
AMENDMENTS URGE AND I VOTE
MEMBERS. THIS IS THERE A
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTION. AYES 38. NO ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 395. SENATE
BILL 483 BY SENATOR CORTESE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 483 BY SENATOR CORTESE. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUPIL RIGHTS.
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SENATORS, SB 43 IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
RENAME THE BILL MAX BENSON'S LAW
IN HONOR OF A STUDENT WHO LOST
HIS LIFE OVER IN DAVIS AT THE
HANDS OF PRONE RESTRAINT. I WANT
TO TAKE THE TIME TO ACKNOWLEDGE
AND THANK DAVID FOR A
CONSTITUENT FROM MY DISTRICT WHO
COURAGEOUSLY SHARED WITH ME HIS
LIVED EXPERIENCE WITH PRONE
RESTRAINT. THANK YOU, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR. IS
THERE A DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS MEASURE? DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL, SEEING NO
OBJECTION. AYES 38. NÓ ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 396. THIS
IS SENATE BILL 611. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 611 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. AN ACT
RELATING TO TENANCY. SENATOR
MENGIBAR. COLLEAGUES SB 611 IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. IT WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY NARROWED IN THE
ASSEMBLY. ALL OPPOSITION HAS
BEEN REMOVED, RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NO MICROPHONES
UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN AYE. ALVARADO, GIL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY. NØ.
DODD AYE. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NO.
NILO NO. OCHOA. BOGH PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
GROVE. NODA. I MEAN, I DON'T
KNOW. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'RE JUST GOING
THROUGH ONE MORE TIME. OKAY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE. WHEN YOU'RE
READY, CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GIL. BLAKE. SPEER
EGGMAN. MCGUIRE OCHOA. BORG
EGGMAN I. ON A VOTE OF 30 IN
FAVOR. SIX AGAINST THE ASSEMBLY.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 397. THIS IS SENATE BILL
937 BY SENATOR WIENER. BY
SENATOR WIENER SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 937 BY SENATOR
WIENER. AN ACT RELATING TO LAND
USE. SENATOR WIENER, I THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES.
SB 937 IS BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY
ON CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL
RECEIVED AN OVERWHELMING SUPPORT
IN THIS BODY, THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY AT A FIVE YEAR SHOT
CLOCK FOR DEVELOPERS TO START
CONSTRUCTION BEFORE LOSING THEIR
FEE DEFERRAL. REMOVE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL RELATED TO HOUSING
ENTITLEMENT EXTENSIONS. NARROW
WHEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
REQUIRE IMPACT FEES TO BE PAID
EARLIER. IF THE FUNDS WILL PAY
FOR SPECIFIED INFRASTRUCTURE OR
PUBLIC IMPROVEMENTS, AND GIVE
DEVELOPERS THE OPTION OF
PROVIDING A BOND OR LETTER OF
CREDIT AS FISCAL SURETY. AND IF
THEY DON'T DO SO, THEN THE
AMOUNT BECOMES LIABLE ON THE
PROPERTY, IN ADDITION TO OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES, THIS HAS
RECEIVED BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. AND I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR WIENER,
WE HAVE MICROPHONES UP FROM
SENATOR STERN AND SENATOR DOLE.
SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, I RISE WITH SOME
CONCERNS. I WASN'T ON MY RADAR,
SO I KNOW THERE'S A LOT, LOT OF
THINGS MOVING ALL AT ONCE. THE
CENTRAL CONCERN I HAVE IS
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR PARKS
DISTRICTS, BUT ALSO FOR SCHOOLS
AND OTHERS, THE PACING OF THE
FUNDS I'VE TALKED WITH THE
AUTHOR ABOUT IT, SOUNDS LIKE
ESPECIALLY FOR PARKS DISTRICTS
OR OPEN SPACE, THERE'S A
DIFFICULTY IN TERMS OF THE
TIMING OF RECEIVING FUNDS. SO A
LOT OF AT LEAST MY LOCAL PARKS
FINANCE THEIR PROJECTS BASED ON
THE DEVELOPMENTS GOING ON IN THE
AREA AND THERE'S SOME AMBIGUITY,
I THINK, IN THE LANGUAGE RIGHT
NOW ABOUT, WHETHER THEY CAN BE
ELIGIBLE TO STILL RECEIVE THAT
IF IT'S RELATED TO THE PROJECT
ITSELF, WOULD THE AUTHOR TAKE A
QUESTION? YEAH. JUST TO BE
CLEAR, THIS BILL DOES NOT
ELIMINATE ANY IMPACT. JUST A
MOMENT, PLEASE. I KNOW CROSSTALK
HERE. LET'S GO THROUGH THE
CHAIR. OKAY. YOU'RE ASKING TO
POSE A QUESTION. YES, SURE.
SENATOR WIENER, WILL YOU TAKE A
QUESTION? YES. MY APOLOGIES,
SENATOR STERN. WHAT IS YOUR
QUESTION, OUR OUR PARKS
DISTRICTS ELIGIBLE FOR UPFRONT
FUNDING LIKE SEWERS AND ROADS
AND SOME OF THE EXCEPTIONS.
YEAH. SO JUST TO BE CLEAR, ALL
FEES GET PAID. THIS BILL DOES
NOT REDUCE OR ELIMINATE ANY
IMPACT FEES. THIS IS JUST ABOUT
WHICH FEES GET GET PAID WHEN THE
PERMIT IS PULLED AT THE
BEGINNING AND WHICH FEES GET
PAID AT THE END OF THE PROJECT,
EVERYTHING GETS PAID, UNDER THIS
BILL, SO SCHOOL FACILITIES FEES
GET PAID UP FRONT AS LONG AS
THERE'S LIKE A CAPITAL PLAN FOR
SCHOOL FACILITIES, ANY KIND OF
SEWER UTILITY, SIDEWALK, ETC.
INFRASTRUCTURE FEES THAT ARE IN
ANY WAY RELATED TO THE PROJECT
GET PAID UP FRONT. OTHER ITEMS
WILL GET PAID AT THE END, I ALSO
WILL NOTE THAT IF A PROJECT
STARTS AND FAILS, CITIES AND
DISTRICTS ARE REQUIRED TO
REIMBURSE REFUND THE FEES SO
IT'S UNWISE TO SPEND THOSE FEES
BEFORE A PROJECT ACTUALLY
HAPPENS. SO WE DID WORK
EXTENSIVELY AND WE HAD EXTENSIVE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ASSOCIATIONS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND MADE SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL AS A PART
OF THOSE NEGOTIATIONS. THERE'S
GOING TO BE ONGOING DIALOG ABOUT
SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES, FOR
EXAMPLE, WITH THE WATER
DISTRICTS, AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
TALK TO THE PARK DISTRICTS AS
WELL. SENATOR STERN, ON YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT COMMITMENT
FROM THE AUTHOR. SHOULD THE BILL
MOVE FORWARD, WE'RE JUST HOPING
TO GET SOME CLARITY THAT, THOSE
WHO ARE COLLECTING A FEE AND
HAVE TO WAIT FOR A PROJECT TO BE
COMPLETE, THAT THEY'RE NOT SORT
OF DISADVANTAGED IN TERMS OF THE
IMPACT OF THAT PROJECT, WHERE
IT'S THEY MAY HAVE ONE
DEVELOPMENT FEE AMOUNT, SAY, IN
2024. AND THEN BY THE TIME THE
PROJECT'S DONE IN 2029 OR 2030,
COSTS HAVE GONE UP, CONSTRUCTION
COSTS HAVE GONE UP, THE VALUE OF
MONEY HAS GONE UP. SO THERE'S AN
INABILITY TO SORT OF INDEX THAT
LOST MONEY RIGHT NOW. SO JUST IF
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
WILLINGNESS TO CONSIDER THAT
GOING FORWARD, I'LL BE LAYING
OFF THE BILL TODAY, BUT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR STERN. SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I ALSO SAW THIS BILL IN
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOE
PATTERSON HAD A VERY SIMILAR
BILL THAT WE ON OUR SIDE OF THE
AISLE HAD A SUPPORT. WE HAVE A
NONE ON THE BILL FOR THOSE
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL, BY THE WAY.
LOOK, I THINK AT THE END OF THE
DAY, WE'RE TRYING TO GET HOUSING
BUILT. WE'RE TRYING TO GET
PROJECTS DONE, AND WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE ANY LOCAL COMMUNITY
SERVICE DISTRICTS OR THOSE FOLKS
SCHOOLS LOSE OUT ON THEIR
FUNDING. BUT AT THE END, BUT YOU
CAN GET THE PROJECT STARTED UP
FRONT AND USE THOSE MONIES TO
GET UP FRONT. THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO BE MISSING OUT ON THOSE
FUNDS. THEY'LL BE FULLY PAID.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SB 937. ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SENATOR SECRETO? YEAH.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I TOO
ARE GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THIS
THIS BILL. UNDERSTANDING HOW
THESE FEES, THESE ESPECIALLY THE
IMPACT FEES GET PAID IN A
COMMUNITY, USUALLY THEY'RE A
COLLECTIVE FEE FROM SEVERAL
DIFFERENT PROJECTS. AND SO
YOU'RE NOT THE CITY IS NOT
DEPENDING ON ONE FEE COLLECTION
FROM ONE PROJECT TO PAY FOR AN
ENTIRE, IMPROVEMENT. AND SO THEY
COLLECT THESE FEES, THEY PUT
THEM IN AN IMPACT FEE ACCOUNT.
AND WHEN THERE'S ENOUGH MONEY IN
THAT ACCOUNT AND THEY'VE GONE
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF PLANNING
THAT, THAT THAT OTHER PROJECT,
THAT'S WHEN THAT MONEY ACTUALLY
GETS USED AND IT'S USUALLY WELL,
AFTER THE INDIVIDUAL PROJECT
GETS DONE. IN THE CASE WHERE
THERE IS AN ONGOING PROJECT,
THERE'S ALREADY LANGUAGE IN
PLACE THAT THEY WOULD PAY THAT
UP FRONT. SO THIS MAKES SENSE.
THIS IS A GOOD WAY FOR IT'S A
GOOD COMPROMISE BETWEEN THE
CITIES AND THE DEVELOPMENT TO
HELP ENCOURAGE THE DEVELOPMENT
TO GET DONE AND ENABLE THEM TO
GET DONE. AND SO IT WILL FURTHER
OUR HOUSING PLANS ALONG THE
CITIES, AND THE AGENCIES WILL
STILL GET THEIR IMPACT FEES.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF WHEN THOSE
FEES COME IN AND SIT IN AN
ACCOUNT. AND SO WE'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. AND I
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO VOTE AYE
ON IT. THANK YOU SENATOR.
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MAY I ASK A QUESTION
OF THE AUTHOR? WELL, LET ME MAKE
A STATEMENT AND THEN I'LL ASK A
QUESTION. I RECEIVED A LETTER OF
CONCERN FROM ONE OF MY WATER
DISTRICTS IN MY AREA, EXPRESSING
SOME CONCERNS ON THE NEW
AMENDMENTS ON THIS BILL. SO IF I
COULD ASK THE AUTHOR TO CLARIFY
IF HE'S ABLE TO 1 OR 2 OF THOSE
CONCERNS. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
WIENER, WILL YOU TAKE A
QUESTION? YES. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THE CONCERN IS THAT
ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS MOVES SOME
OF THE LANGUAGE INTO WHAT'S
BEING ARGUED AS AN INAPPROPRIATE
SECTION OF GOVERNMENT CODE
REGARDING SEWER CONNECTION AND
CAPACITY FEES AND SETTING A NEW
STANDARD ON THOSE FEES, DO YOU
HAVE A I I'M WHAT I KNOW THROUGH
THE CHAIR, WHAT I KNOW IS THAT
WE THE LANGUAGE ABOUT THE SEWER
HOOKUPS, WATER, ETC. WAS
NEGOTIATED EXTENSIVELY WITH THE
VARIOUS COMMITTEES OF
JURISDICTION AND WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT GROUPS. AND SO I
DON'T KNOW WHAT EXACTLY WHAT
EXACT SECTION YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT, BUT THAT WAS VERY
EXTENSIVELY NEGOTIATED. SO THAT
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT NEW
HOUSING AND OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
SEWER CONNECTIONS, ETC, THAT
SERVE THAT NEW HOUSING, THOSE
FEES NEED TO BE PAID UP FRONT,
BECAUSE THAT'S WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING AT THAT POINT IN TIME.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE BILL DOES.
OKAY ONE ADDITIONAL, CONCERN.
MR. PRESIDENT, IF I CAN ASK A
SECOND QUESTION. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR WIENER WOULD YOU TAKE A
SECOND QUESTION? OKAY. HE SAYS
YES, THE SAME. THE SAME DISTRICT
IS ALSO RAISING QUESTIONS
REGARDING PROPOSITION 218 AND
PROP 26 REGARDING THE FEES AND
TAXES, HAVE YOU HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THAT,
THIS DOES NOT IN ANY WAY IMPACT
THAT CITIES ARE ALLOWED TO
ASSESS IMPACT FEES, UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION. AND SO THIS BILL
SIMPLY HAS TO DO WITH WHEN THOSE
ARE PAID AND IT WILL PROVIDE
THAT SOME ARE PAID UP FRONT,
SOME AT THE END. SO THE BILL IS
REALLY ONLY ABOUT THE TIMING OF
THE PAYMENT. IT DOESN'T AFFECT
WHAT THE FEES ARE. OKAY. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL THIS
EVENING. I WOULD SUGGEST TO THE
AUTHOR AND THE ASSEMBLY AUTHOR
THAT THEY BE OPEN TO FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS ON THESE ISSUES AND
IF YOU KNOW, FURTHER CLEANUP ON
THIS IS NECESSARY NEXT YEAR THAT
WE HAVE THAT CONVERSATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR JONES.
SENATOR SKINNER, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I STAND AS
THE CHAIR OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL, I THINK OUR AUTHOR HAS
EXPLAINED SOME OF THIS, BUT I
JUST WANTED TO BE CLEAR. WE KNOW
THAT ONE OF THE MAIN THERE'S
MANY REASONS, BUT ONE OF THE
REASONS WE HAVE, EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE DONE A LOT TO STREAMLINE
AND FACILITATE CONSTRUCTION OF
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA, WE ARE
STILL NOT GETTING IT BUILT AT
THE RATE WE WANT. WHY THE COST?
THE COST IS SO HIGH NOW. ONE OF
THE COSTS IS THESE KINDS OF
FEES. NOW WE KNOW THAT THESE
FEES ARE NECESSARY TO SUPPORT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THE
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT IS GOING
TO RELY ON. HOWEVER, IF THE
DEVELOPER HAS TO PAY THEM IN
ADVANCE THAT IT INCREASES THAT
AMOUNT, THAT THEY HAVE TO
FINANCE RIGHT AWAY AND PUTS A
HUGE BURDEN WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO
DELIVER HOUSING, IF THE FEES ARE
COLLECTED AT THE POINT THAT THE
HOUSING IS READY AT THE
CERTIFICATE OF OCCUPANCY, IT
JUST MAKES SO MUCH MORE SENSE
BECAUSE IT'S COLLECTED. THEN AT
THE TIME THAT WE KNOW THE
HOUSING WILL BE OCCUPIED, AND
THUS WHEN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
WILL REALLY BE NEEDED. SO I
STRONGLY STAND IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL. IT MAKES SENSE. WE NEED TO
DO LITTLE FIXES LIKE THIS TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HELP REDUCE
THOSE COSTS AND HELP PROMOTE THE
BUILDING OF HOUSING. WITH THAT,
I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. I DON'T
SEE ANY FURTHER MICROPHONES UP.
SENATOR WIENER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. CHAIRMAN, AND I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL DEBATE, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS TO ME, THIS BILL IS A
WIN WIN. IT MEANS IT MAKES IT
MORE LIKELY THAT THE HOUSING
ACTUALLY WILL PENCIL OUT AND
BUILD, ESPECIALLY IN A HIGH
INTEREST RATE ENVIRONMENT. AND
IT ENSURES THAT THE FEES ARE
PAID. CITIES, SPECIAL DISTRICTS
WILL ALL GET THEIR FUNDING,
WHICH THEY DESPERATELY NEED, AND
THE HOUSING WILL GET BUILT. THIS
BILL WAS EXTENSIVELY NEGOTIATED.
MONTHS AND MONTHS OF DIALOG AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR WIENER,
PRIOR TO THIS THOUGHTFUL DEBATE,
I HAD A NOTATION THAT THIS WAS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. BUT I'M GOING TO TAKE A
CHANCE AND ASK AGAIN. WE HAVE AN
OBJECTION. ALL RIGHT. ALL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO,
GIL ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DAILY. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. OKUBO AYE. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN. ALVARADO. GIL LEMON
MCGUIRE. AYE. WHEN NILO PADILLA
PORTANTINO RUBIO. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN NO. WAHAB. ALL
RIGHT. ON A VOTE OF THREE IN
FAVOR. ONE AGAINST. THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 398. THIS IS SENATE
BILL 940. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 940 BY SENATOR
UMBERG. AN ACT RELATING TO CIVIL
DISPUTES. MEMBERS, PLEASE GIVE
SENATOR UMBERG YOUR ATTENTION.
PLEASE GIVE HIM YOUR ATTENTION.
PLEASE SENATOR UMBERG, THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS TAKING THE ASSEMBLY
SIMPLY SPECIFIED PROCEDURES FOR
THE ISSUANCE OF SUBPOENAS AND
EXPAND THE CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
AT THE STATE BAR TO CERTAIN
OTHER ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION RESOLUTION PROVIDERS.
I URGE, AND I VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MATTER, ANY DISCUSSION. ALL
RIGHT. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESPEAR AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE.
LEMON. GROVE NO. LEMON. AYE
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
OCHOA PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO NO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE WILK. NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL.
DALLEY MEN. AYE OCHOA.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. ON A VOTE
OF 31 TO 6, THE ASSEMBLY.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 399. THIS
IS SENATE BILL 1075 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1075 BY
SENATOR BRADFORD. AN ACT
RELATING TO CREDIT UNIONS.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. 1075 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY REMOVED THE THREE
DAY GRACE PERIOD REQUIRED
NOTIFICATION TO BE SENT WHENEVER
AN OVERDRAFT OR NON-SUFFICIENT
FEE IS ASSESSED, AND DELAYS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FEE CAP
UNTIL JANUARY 1ST, 2026. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MATTER ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NO MICROPHONES, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN Ã.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS. I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER. I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALLEY I DODD I DURAZO
I EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE I HURTADO I JONES I LAIRD
I LEHMAN I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I
MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN NÓ NILO I
OCHOA I PADILLA I PORTANTINO
ROTH I RUBIO I SATO NO SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN, I
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER.
ALVARADO GILL. PORTANTINO. ON A
VOTE OF 36 TO 2. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 400. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1230 BY SENATOR RUBIO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1230 BY SENATOR RUBIO. AN
ACT RELATING TO TOBACCO SALES.
SENATOR RUBIO, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1230 THE STOP AND SEEK LEGAL
TOBACCO PRODUCTS ACT. THIS BILL
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE BECAUSE
IT WAS AMENDED IN THE ASSEMBLY
TO ALIGN WITH RECENT CHANGES TO
FEDERAL LAW REGARDING SALE OF
TOBACCO. THE BILL TOOK UP. THE
BILL ALSO TOOK CHAPTER N N
AMENDMENTS TO RESOLVE CONFLICTS
WITH ANOTHER BILL, AB 3218. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS. ANY MEMBER
WANT TO BE HEARD ON THIS BILL.
ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I ALVARADO.
GILL. ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS, I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DALLEY DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE
HURTADO I JONES NØ. LAIRD I
LIMON I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MIN
I NEWMAN I NGUYEN NILO NØ OCHOA.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO. NÓ. SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN I
UMBERG I WAHAB, I WIENER I WILK
KNOW. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL. DALLEY.
NO GROVE. NGUYEN OCHOA. BOGUE ON
A VOTE OF 31 TO 5, THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 401. THIS IS SB 1238 BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1238 BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. AN ACT RELATING
TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. SENATOR
EGGMAN, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. 1238 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE ASSEMBLY. WE CREATED
AN ENGAGEMENT PROCESS BETWEEN
DHS AND STAKEHOLDERS. I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
EGGMAN. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MATTER? ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
AMENDMENTS? THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. AYES 39. NÓ ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 402. THAT'S PASSED
TEMPORARILY MOVING NEXT TO 403.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1289 BY
SENATOR ROTH. NOT AT HIS DESK
UP. HE IS HERE IN THE CHAMBER.
SO WE WILL HEAR THAT BILL.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1289. SENATE BILL 1289 BY
SENATOR ROTH. AN ACT RELATING TO
MEDI-CAL. SENATOR ROTH. WELL,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS
BILL IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT REQUIRES
COUNTIES TO REPORT THEIR DATA ON
CALLS TO COUNTY CALL CENTERS
FROM MEDI-CAL APPLICANTS AND
RECIPIENTS. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS REMOVE REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO SET STANDARDS
FOR COUNTY CALL CENTERS, BUT
SIMPLY COLLECTING AND REPORTING
THE DATA WOULD BE A STEP FORWARD
TO ENSURE THAT MEDI-CAL
RECIPIENTS GET THE HELP THEY
NEED TO STAY ON THE PROGRAM. AS
FOR AN AYE VOTE MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTION. AYES
39. NÓ ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NEXT UP IS FILED ITEM 404. THIS
IS SENATE BILL 1329 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1329 BY THE
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION. AN ACT
RELATING TO ELEMENTARY AND
SECONDARY EDUCATION. SENATOR
NEWMAN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL IS AN
EDUCATION COMMITTEE OMNIBUS BILL
THAT MAKES A NUMBER OF TECHNICAL
CHANGES THE ED CODE. THERE HAVE
BEEN NO NO OPPOSITION
THROUGHOUT. NO NO VOTES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AYES 39. NO. ZERO. THE. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING NOW TO FILE
ITEM 405, SENATE BILL 1342 BY
SENATOR ATKINS. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1342 BY
SENATOR ATKINS. AN ACT RELATING
TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
SENATOR ATKINS. THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES. 1342 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE BILL PROVIDES
SEQUA STREAMLINING FOR TWO VERY
IMPORTANT PROJECTS IN THE SAN
DIEGO AREA THE SAN VICENTE PUMP
STORAGE PROJECT AND THE SOUTH
BAY INTERNATIONAL WASTEWATER
PLANT. AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY TO ADDRESS CHAPTERS
ABOUT ISSUES IT'S ENJOYED,
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ATKINS. SENATOR JONES. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THESE TWO
PROJECTS ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO AND THE
CONSTITUENTS THERE. I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
JONES, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SENATOR ATKINS, YOU MAY
CLOSE. SHE. SHE IS CLOSED.
MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 39. NÓ ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING NOW TO FILE
ITEM 406. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1354 BY SENATOR WAHAB.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1354 BY SENATOR WILL HAVE
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
FACILITIES. SENATOR WAHAB. THANK
YOU, CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. SB 1354
CODIFIES REGULATIONS REGARDING
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
PROTECTS THE RIGHTS OF RESIDENTS,
REGARDLESS OF THEIR PAYMENT
SOURCE. THIS BILL HAS RETURNED
FROM THE ASSEMBLY, AND I WOULD
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR WAHAB,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE DALY. AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO. AYE. OCHOA. BOGH. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO ACIERTO. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE ALL RIGHT. ON A VOTE
OF 39 TO 0, THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 407. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1336 BY SENATOR ARCHULETA.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1336 BY SENATOR ARCHULETA.
AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
PROPERTY. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL 1336, WHICH IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE. THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY ADD A
COAUTHOR AND ARE CLARIFYING IN
NATURE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THAT WAS A VERY
CONCISE PRESENTATION. MEMBERS,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS THIS
MEASURE? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTION.
AYES 38. NO. ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON TO ITEM 408. THIS IS
SENATE BILL 1423 BY SENATOR
DAWLEY. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
DAWLEY. AN ACT RELATING TO
MEDI-CAL. SENATOR DAWLEY, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS 1423 IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE. THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY ADDED.
COAUTHORS CHANGES THE BILL TO
FORM A RURAL HOSPITAL TECHNICAL
ADVISORY GROUP, CONSISTING OF
VARIOUS INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS,
WHICH WILL BE TASKED WITH
ANALYZING THE EXISTING MEDI-CAL
REIMBURSEMENT METHODOLOGIES,
INCLUDING SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
AND FEE FOR SERVICE
REIMBURSEMENTS. AND THOSE
METHODOLOGIES COULD CHANGE TO
BETTER PROTECT OUR FINANCIAL
VIABILITY OF OUR HOSPITALS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR DAWLEY.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. THAT OBJECTION. AYES
38. NÓ ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON TO ITEM 409. THIS IS
SENATE BILL 1441 BY SENATOR
ALLEN. HE SEEMS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1441 BY SENATOR
ALLEN. AN ACT RELATING TO
PETITIONS. SENATOR ALLEN. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS WOULD
PROVIDE CLEAR TIMELINES IN THE
ELECTION PETITION REVIEW PROCESS
AND HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HANDLE COSTS FROM EXTREME ADDED
WORKLOAD. IT'S BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY LIMITED WHEN COUNTIES
WOULD BE ABLE TO RECOVER COSTS
ABOVE AND BEYOND THEIR GENERAL
OPERATIONS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
REVIEW TO ONLY AFTER THE FIFTH
BUSINESS DAY OF THE REVIEW,
MEANING THAT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF CASES PROPONENTS WOULD NOT
OWE ANY MONEY AT ALL. ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS WOULD ALSO BE REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY FOR THE EXAMINATION TO
OCCUR IN A TIMELY MANNER. THIS
BILL WILL HELP COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS BETTER ALLOCATE
RESOURCES FOR FREE AND FAIR
ELECTIONS, WILL ENSURE THAT
PROPONENTS DO NOT ABUSE THE
REVIEW PROCESS, WHILE STILL
PROTECTING THIS CRITICAL
TRANSPARENCY OPPORTUNITY. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR ALLEN
MEMBERS. ANYONE WISH TO BE HEARD
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY SENATOR
WISHED TO BE HEARD. SEEING NØ
MICROPHONES UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DELHI NÓ. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO.
OCHOA PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH RUBIO. SEYARTO. NO.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
NO. OCHOA. NO HOLD ON. PLEASE
HOLD ON. PLEASE SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL. MCGUIRE. NILO
NO. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE PAUSE.
HEARING NOTHING FURTHER ON A
VOTE OF 30 TO 8, THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING
TO PASS ON FILE ITEM FOR TEN.
FOR NOW. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM FOR 11. THIS IS SENATE
BILL 1463 BY THE SENATOR FROM
FAIR OAKS, SENATOR NILO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1463 BY SENATOR NILO. AN
ACT RELATING TO DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. SENATOR NILO. THANK
YOU AND GOOD EVENING, MR.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. I AM THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ON SB. I
NEVER AM GOOD AT NUMBERS 1463.
THEY ARE TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND
ADDRESS POTENTIAL CONFLICTS WITH
ANOTHER BILL, SB 1281 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROVISIONS OF EACH BILL REMAIN
INTACT. SHOULD THE GOVERNOR SIGN
BOTH BILLS, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR ANY SENATOR WANT TO BE
HEARD ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
SENATOR WANT TO BE HEARD. SEEING
NONE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. DESPITE THE
AUTHOR SEEING NO OBJECTION. AYES
38. NÓ ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 412. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1490 BY SENATOR DURAZO.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1490 BY SENATOR DURAZO. AN
ACT RELATING TO FOOD DELIVERY.
SENATOR DURAZO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SB 1490 IS BACK FROM
CONCURRENCE AND RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. THE AMENDMENTS ARE
PART OF AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND OUTLINE
DISCLOSURES BY FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORM TO A RESTAURANT PRIOR
TO SIGNING A CONTRACT. IF THERE
ARE ANY MATERIAL CHANGES IN THE
CONTRACT WITH THESE AMENDMENTS,
ALL OPPOSITION WAS REMOVED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THE MEASURE? ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLY NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO.
OCHOA. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. NO I THINK
EVERYBODY'S HERE RIGHT? ON A
VOTE OF 30 IN FAVOR? EIGHT
AGAINST THE ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO
ITEM 413. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1511 BY THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1511 BY THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH AND ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH. SENATOR ROTH, OUR
ESTEEMED CHAIR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. HEALTH COMMITTEE'S
ANNUAL OMNIBUS BILL ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE. DELETE A
PROVISION THAT WAS INCLUDED IN
THE ANNUAL BUDGET BILL. AS FOR
AN I VOTE, THANK YOU, SENATOR
ROTH. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
COMMITTEE BILL? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 30 800. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM 414. THIS IS SB
14 1523 BY THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1523 BY THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION AND
ACT RELATING GAMBLING. WE'LL
TURN TO OUR GRIZZLED CHAIR OF
C , SENATOR DODD. MR. PRESIDENT,
MEMBERS ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
COMMITTEE BILL? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 38. NO. ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
NEXT UP IS ITEM 402 BY SENATOR
GLAZIER. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL 1287 BY SENATOR
GLAZER. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR GLAZER, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
SB 1287 IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
CONSTITUTIONAL CONCERNS AND
ALIGN THE BILL WITH THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
RULEMAKING AROUND TITLE SIX
COMPLIANCE. THE BILL NOW DOES
FOUR THINGS. MEMBERS. FIRST, IT
REQUIRES PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES TO
ADOPT AND ENFORCE POLICIES IN
STUDENT CODE OF CONDUCT THAT
PROHIBIT VIOLENCE, HARASSMENT,
INTIMIDATION, AND
DISCRIMINATION, INTERFERING WITH
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS THROUGH
FORCE OR INTIMIDATION. SECOND,
WITH COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, IT
REQUIRES THEM TO DEVELOP OR
ENFORCE REASONABLE AND CONTENT
NEUTRAL TIME, PLACE AND MANNER
RESTRICTIONS. THIRD, IT REQUIRES
THE DEVELOPMENT OF MANDATORY
TRAINING PROGRAMS ON HOW TO
ENGAGE RESPECTFULLY AND ANNUAL
REPORTING TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
PROGRAMS. AND LASTLY, THE BILL
ASKS EACH STUDENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE CODE OF CONDUCT BY ADOPTING
THESE PROVISIONS. THIS BILL
AFFIRMS THE ROLE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
MUST TAKE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO EXERCISE
THEIR FREE SPEECH RIGHTS AND
EXCHANGE VIEWS RESPECTFULLY,
CONSISTENT WITH THEIR
EDUCATIONAL MISSION. THIS BILL
ALIGNS WITH THIS MISSION BY
REQUIRING CAMPUSES TO INSTITUTE
POLICIES THAT EXPLICITLY
PROHIBIT ACTIONS THAT LEAD TO
HOSTILE ENVIRONMENTS ON CAMPUSES
THAT PREVENT THE EXCHANGE OF
IDEAS THAT IS SO VALUED ON OUR
COLLEGE CAMPUSES. I BELIEVE THIS
LEGISLATION WILL HELP RESTORE
OUR GOAL OF FOSTERING CIVIL
DISCOURSE ON OUR CAMPUSES. AND
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING SEEING. NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON. FINAL ITEM 402. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ.
AYE. DALY AYE. DODD. AYE.
DURAZO. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEUMANN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE.
OTTOBOCK. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
NØ. WIENER. AYE. WILK PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL CABALLERO. DURAZO
MCGUIRE. AYE. WILK. AYE CUEVAS.
I DON'T KNOW. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ONE MORE TIME.
ALVARADO. GILL. CABALLERO.
DURAZO DURAZO. NO AYES. 35. NOES
THREE. THE MEASURE PASSES. THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM 129.
SENATOR AB 220 91. SENATOR
GLAZIER, HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 2091 BY ASSEMBLY. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2091 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON. AN ACT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. SENATOR.
GLAZIER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL, ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON,
WOULD HELP EXPEDITE PUBLIC
ACCESS TO OPEN SPACE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND HELP SAVE PARK
DISTRICT IMPORTANT RESOURCES. IT
WILL EXEMPT THE OPENING OF
EXISTING ROADS AND TRAILS FOR
SPECIFIED, NON-MOTORIZED
RECREATIONAL USES TO THE PUBLIC.
ON OPEN SPACE PROPERTIES OWNED
AND OPERATED BY AN INDEPENDENT
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT. THE BILL
WOULD HAVE NO IMPACT ON EXISTING
LAND COVENANTS, AND THE PARK
DISTRICT WOULD STILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENFORCING
MANAGEMENT POLICIES THAT PROTECT
SPECIES, HABITAT AND TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? SEEING AND
HEARING. NONE. AYES 39. NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
OKAY OKAY. ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS,
HERE'S THE. WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH TWO UNFINISHED BUSINESS
MEASURES. AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO DEAL WITH ABOUT A DOZEN
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING ITEMS,
WHICH I'LL RELATE TO YOU WHEN WE
GET THERE. THE FIRST TWO
UNFINISHED BUSINESSES ARE FILE
ITEM 12 AND FILE ITEM 23 BY
SMALLWOOD, CUEVAS AND NEWMAN.
WE'LL START WITH FILE ITEM 12.
THIS IS SB 1137. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1137 BY
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AN ACT
RELATING TO DISCRIMINATION.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS,
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SB 1137.
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE CALIFORNIA
THE PIONEERING STATE TO
RECOGNIZE INTERSECTIONALITY IN
OUR CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS BY
CLARIFYING THAT DISCRIMINATION
IS PROHIBITED, NOT ONLY BECAUSE
OF ONE PROTECTED TRAIT, BUT ALSO
BECAUSE OF ANY COMBINATION OF
TWO OR MORE PROTECTED TRAITS. SB
1137 WAS AMENDED IN THE ASSEMBLY
TO MAKE TECHNICAL MINOR CHANGES
WHEN REFERRING TO PROHIBITED
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON THE
INTERPLAY BETWEEN MULTIPLE
PROTECTED CHARACTERISTICS, AND
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING
NO MICROPHONES UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY. NØ DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD AYE. LEMON. AYE
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NO.
NILO. NO. OCHOA. NO. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. NO. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL ON A VOTE OF 31
TO 8. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 23. THIS
IS SB 907 BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 907 BY SENATOR NEWMAN. AN
ACT RELATING TO COUNTY BOARDS OF
EDUCATION MEMBERS. PLEASE GIVE
SENATOR NEWMAN YOUR ATTENTION.
SENATOR NEWMAN THAT'S RIGHT.
OKAY SEN. NEWMAN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
907, WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THIS IS A DISTRICT
BILL WHICH WILL IMPROVE CIVIC
PARTICIPATION AND PARENTAL
ENGAGEMENT BY ADDING TWO
ADDITIONAL SEATS TO THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION, WHILE
SHIFTING THE ELECTION FOR THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION
FROM THE PRIMARY TO THE GENERAL
ELECTION CYCLE. AMENDMENTS TAKEN
IN THE ASSEMBLY SPECIFY THAT THE
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
TRUSTEES WILL HAPPEN AS PART OF
THE NEXT DECENNIAL REDISTRICTING
PROCESS, WHICH STARTS IN 2030. I
AM RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THIS EVENING. WELL,
FIRST TO TURN TO SENATOR JONES
AND THEN SENATOR MIN. SENATOR
JONES, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO SB 907,
AND IT COMES WITH SOME SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SCHOOL
BOARDS. AND THIS LEGISLATURE
INTERFERING WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND BASICALLY
LEGITIMATE LOCAL CONTROL OF
THESE SCHOOL BOARDS. IT SEEMS
LIKE TO ME THAT THIS BILL IS
BORN OUT OF A SENSE OF A FALSE
SENSE OF CONCERN THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE, THE MAJORITY PARTY,
DON'T APPRECIATE THE DECISIONS
THAT THIS SCHOOL BOARD IS
MAKING. SO RATHER THAN PROTECT
THE DEMOCRACY THAT'S SET UP IN
THAT LOCAL CONTROL, WE WANT TO
UNDERMINE THAT DEMOCRACY AND
REWRITE IT IN THE CONTEXT OF
WHAT THIS LEGISLATURE SEEMS
APPROPRIATE UP HERE, RATHER THAN
HAVING THE LOCAL CITIZENS THAT
VOTE FOR THOSE SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS DECIDE IT FOR
THEMSELVES, I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR JONES.
SENATOR MIN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I RISE
AS A COAUTHOR AND STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL AND WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FULLERTON FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. I AUTHORED A VERSION OF
THIS BILL TWO YEARS AGO, WHICH
PASSED OUT OF THIS BODY AND THEN
DIED ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. AND
I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT DEMOCRACY,
THIS BILL IS VERY PRO-DEMOCRATIC
BECAUSE ALL IT TRIES TO DO IS
HARMONIZE THE BOARD OF EDUCATION
IN ORANGE COUNTY WITH EVERY
OTHER ELECTION IN ORANGE COUNTY.
THIS IS THE ONLY BOARD, THE ONLY
ELECTION IN ORANGE COUNTY THAT
IS DECIDED AS A ONE AND DONE IN
THE PRIMARY. AND THAT LEADS TO
RAMPANT CONFUSION AMONG VOTERS.
I KNOW MANY, MANY CONSTITUENTS
OF MINE WHO THINK THAT WHEN THEY
VOTE OR DON'T VOTE IN THE
PRIMARY, THAT THEY WILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO VOTE FOR THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION IN THE
GENERAL ELECTION. I THINK THIS
BILL IS VERY APPROPRIATE MEASURE
TO TRY TO INCREASE TURNOUT, TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT VOTERS
ACTUALLY HAVE A SAY IN WHO
REPRESENTS THEM IN THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. SO I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE, SENATOR NEWMAN, YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU. AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY.
AND HE IS RIGHT. THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY ABOUT NOTHING OTHER
THAN DEMOCRACY. THIS BILL BY BY
REPLACING THIS ELECTION IN THE
GENERAL ELECTION ACTUALLY WILL
BE MORE DEMOCRATIC. WE WILL HAVE
A HIGHER LEVEL OF PARTICIPATION
AND AS A RESULT, A MORE
REPRESENTATIVE BOARD. MOREOVER,
BY BY EXPANDING THIS BOARD BY
TWO MEMBERS, WE WILL HAVE A MORE
RESPONSIVE AND MORE
REPRESENTATIVE BOARD OVER TIME.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ADRIN ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DADDY NO. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR I'M IN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NILO.
NO OCHOA. EBCLC. NØ. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH RUBIO.
AYE. SATO NO. SKINNER. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN. ALVARADO. GILL
NGUYEN. PADILLA ROTH. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. AYE WILK. ROTH. AYE ON A
VOTE OF 29 IN FAVOR. SIX AGAINST
THE ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS. WE'RE
GOING TO NEXT MOVE TO ASSEMBLY.
THIRD READING, AND I'LL GIVE YOU
THE ORDER IN WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR BILLS. WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH ITEM 101, FOLLOWED BY
133 173, 177. CAN I GET
ATTENTION THERE ON THE NORTH
SIDE OF THE CHAMBER? AFTER FILE
ITEM 177, WE'LL HEAR 186 199 244
249, 263 AND 267. I KNOW THEY'RE
PAYING ATTENTION. WILL BE READY
TO VOTE ON THESE ITEMS. WE'LL
BEGIN AT 101. THIS IS AB 2357.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2357 BY SENATE MEMBER
BAINS. AN ACT RELATING TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THE
FLOOR MANAGER AND THIS IS
SENATOR NEWMAN. AND WHILE HE
GETS PREPARED, I WANT TO MENTION
THE OTHER FLOOR MANAGERS ON
THESE MEASURES SO THAT THEY WILL
BE PREPARED. THEY ARE SENATOR
DOLLY NEWMAN, OCHOA, BOGH WILK
AND BLAKE SPEER. FOR THE NEXT
TEN OR SO MEASURES. SO JUST BE
PREPARED. SENATOR NEWMAN, YOU
WANT TO PASS TEMPORARILY. ARE
YOU READY? YOU WANT TO PRESENT?
OKAY. I'D LIKE NOTHING MORE THAN
TO PRESENT, SIR. ALL RIGHT. SIR,
THE ITEM HAS BEEN READ, AND IT
IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY. EXCELLENT
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MEMBER DOCTOR JASMEET BAINS TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2357,
WHICH WILL CREATE, SUBJECT TO AN
APPROPRIATION AND ENDOWMENT FUND
WITHIN THE STATE TREASURY AS A
FOUNDATIONAL FIRST STEP TOWARD
ESTABLISHING A UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL SCHOOL IN
KERN COUNTY BY BETTER RECRUITING
AND TRAINING THE NEXT GENERATION
OF PHYSICIANS FROM UNDERSERVED
AND UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES, WE CAN ENSURE THAT
OUR PHYSICIAN WORKFORCE MORE
CLOSELY REFLECTS THE DIVERSITY
OF THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY
WILL SERVE AND WHERE THEY ARE SO
DESPERATELY NEEDED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NEWMAN, FOR A
FINE PRESENTATION. MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES
39. NØ ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 133. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2549. FLOOR MANAGER. SENATOR.
DOLLY SECRETARY. PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2549 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER. AN ACT
RELATING TO PATIENT VISITATION.
SENATOR DOLLY, YOU LOOK VERY
PREPARED. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE TO
REPRESENT AB 2549 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER. PROTECTING
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF PATIENTS
AND HEALTH FACILITIES IS
IMPORTANT, BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE THE
FUNDAMENTAL ROLE THAT VISITATION
PLAYS IN THE PATIENT'S RECOVERY,
COMFORT AND OVERALL WELL-BEING.
STUDIES SHOW THAT THE
FLEXIBILITY VISITATION POLICIES
REDUCE PATIENT STRESS AND
IMPROVE EXPERIENCES AND
CONTRIBUTE TO BETTER OUTCOMES.
FAMILY MEMBERS OFTEN SERVE AS
CRITICAL CARE PARTNERS, HELPING
WITH COMMUNICATIONS AND PATIENTS
RECOVERIES. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT FOR UNDERSERVED AND
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS, THE
ELDERLY, AND PATIENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. AB 25, 49 BUILDS
ON EXISTING LAW ENSURING
VISITATION RIGHTS FOR SPECIFIC
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS.
FACILITIES MUST DEVELOP
ALTERNATIVE VISITATION PROTOCOLS
IF RESTRICTIONS ARE NEEDED FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY, AND
ACCOMMODATE IN-PERSON VISITS
DURING END OF LIFE SITUATIONS.
THIS BILL IS A CRUCIAL STEP
TOWARDS PROTECTING AND PROMOTING
PATIENT CARE IN HEALTH
FACILITIES STATEWIDE, AND THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DONNELLY. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE? IT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. I KNOW YOU WERE ALL
PERSUADED BY THAT ARTICULATE
SPEECH. SEEING NO OBJECTION.
AYES 39. NO, ZERO. THE MEASURE
CARRIES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 173. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 1971. SENATOR
NEWMAN IS THE FLOOR MANAGER AND
HE IS READY. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1971 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ARDIS. AN ACT
RELATING TO PERSONAL
INFORMATION. SENATOR NEWMAN,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARDIS TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL, 1971, WHICH WILL
SAFEGUARD THE PRIVACY OF
STUDENTS PERSONAL DATA IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS. WHILE
CALIFORNIA LAWS CURRENTLY
PROTECT MANY ASPECTS OF STUDENT
DATA, THERE ARE ESSENTIALLY NO
CURRENT SAFEGUARDS WHEN STUDENTS
PARTICIPATE IN STANDARDIZED
TESTS. MANY OF THESE TESTS ARE
CONNECTED TO THE INTERNET AND
THE COMPANIES DEPLOYING THEM
GATHER, STORE, USE, AND SELL
THAT STUDENT DATA SO THERE IS A
NEED TO CLOSE GAPS AROUND
CURRENT LAW ABOUT HOW THAT DATA
IS TREATED. AB 17 1971 HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
RECENT AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED
ANY REMAINING OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR NEWMAN,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY SENATOR WANTING TO BE HEARD?
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. NO MICROPHONES
UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO. GIL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BREAKSPEARE. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. ECKMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA.
BOGH. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO ACIERTO. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GIL. JONES. AYE LIMON.
AYE A VOTE OF 39 TO 0. THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 177, THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 1971. NØ 2906. EXCUSE ME,
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2906 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN. AN ACT TO FOSTER CARE.
SENATOR OCHOA BOGH. MR.
PRESIDENT MEMBERS, I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 2906 WHICH WILL
REDIRECT THOUSANDS OF FEDERAL
DOLLARS TO OUR STATE'S MOST
VULNERABLE YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA,
FOSTER YOUTH WHO HAVE LOST A
PARENT AND ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL SURVIVOR BENEFITS DO NOT
RECEIVE THESE BENEFITS DIRECTLY.
INSTEAD, COUNTIES APPLIED TO USE
THE FUNDS TO COVER THE COST OF
THE CHILD'S FOSTER CARE. BY
ENACTING AB 2906, CALIFORNIA
WILL JOIN SEVERAL STATES IN
RECOGNIZING THAT SURVIVOR
BENEFITS BELONG TO THE SURVIVOR.
THE BILL HAS PASSED BOTH HOUSES
WITH NO NØ VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. AYES 39. NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL MOVE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM 186. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 3034. SENATOR WILK
IS THE FLOOR MANAGER OF THAT
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3034 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWE. AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
MEMBERS, PLEASE GIVE SENATOR
WILK YOUR ABSOLUTE ATTENTION.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. YOU'RE
DOING A GREAT JOB. AB 3034 WILL
ALLOW A CONSERVATION CORPS
MEMBER WHO COMPLETED A YEAR OF
SERVICE TO HAVE THEIR FIRST TWO
YEARS OF TUITION WAIVED AT A CSU
OR UC. THIS MEASURE ENSURES THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE DEDICATED
THEMSELVES TO PUBLIC SERVICE IN
THE CONSERVATION CORPS CAN
PURSUE A HIGHER EDUCATION
WITHOUT THE SIGNIFICANT BURDEN
OF STUDENT TUITION. THIS BILL
WILL EMPOWER CIVIC MINDED YOUTH
AND HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
WILK, ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ADRIN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BREAKSPEARE AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR MEN. AYE. NEWMAN.
MENGIBAR. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. MENGIBAR. NO NGUYEN.
NILO OCHOA. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL. DOLLY
GROVE. AYE NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA.
BOGH. ON A VOTE OF 34 TO 1, THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 199. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 359. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ THE ASSEMBLY BILL
359 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN.
AN ACT RELATING TO PUPIL
INSTRUCTION. SENATOR OKOBOJI,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. SORRY. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 359 WHICH MARKS PHASE
ONE OF DUAL ENROLLMENT REFORM
AND IS NECESSARY TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS RECEIVE THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO GRADUATE
WITH COLLEGE CREDITS.
SPECIFICALLY, THE BILL PROVIDES
CHANGES NEEDED TO REMOVE
BARRIERS SURROUNDING THE COLLEGE
AND CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM. IT
WILL DO THIS BY STREAMLINING
STUDENT ENROLLMENT AND
PARTICIPATION, BY ALLOWING LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO PARTNER
WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES OUTSIDE
OF THEIR SERVICE AREA. IT ALSO
REMOVES A REQUIREMENT FOR A
PRINCIPAL'S RECOMMENDATION TO
PARTICIPATE AND PERMIT SCHOOLS
TO OFFER COURSES ONLINE, IMPROVE
ACCESS TO THE COLLEGE AND CAREER
PATHWAYS PROGRAM WILL HELP
STREAMLINE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
ENTRANCE INTO HIGHER EDUCATION
AND THE WORKFORCE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES 30 900.
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 244. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2247. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2247
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE AND
ACT RELATING TO MOBILE HOMES.
SENATOR NEWMAN, YOU'RE A POPULAR
MAN. TODAY IS YOURS. YES. THANK
YOU. I RISE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE TO
PRESENT AB 2247, WHICH WILL
EXTEND THE SUNSET ON
CALIFORNIA'S MOBILE HOME PARKS
ACT TO JANUARY FIRST OF 2030 AND
IMPROVE NOTICES OF VIOLATIONS IN
THE EVENT OF A NOTICE REGARDING
HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES. AB
2247 WILL REQUIRE HCD TO PROVIDE
RELEVANT INFORMATION TO TENANTS
ABOUT ADDITIONAL LOW INCOME
PROGRAMS WHICH CAN ASSIST WITH
HOME REHABILITATION AND REPAIR.
AB 2247 HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
AND THERE'S CURRENTLY NO
OPPOSITION. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, ANY
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
DODD. DALY. AYE. DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE
NILO. AYE. OKUBO. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
ACIERTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL. PORTANTINO AYE.
ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 249. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 810. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 810
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. AN
ACT RELATING TO POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION. THIS HAS SUPPORT
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES. SENATOR
OCHOA BOGH. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 810 WHICH WILL ALLOW
HIGHER EDUCATION HR PERSONNEL TO
ENGAGE WITH PROSPECTIVE FACULTY
MEMBERS, PRIOR EMPLOYERS. THIS
WILL PREVENT FACULTY GUILTY OF
MISCONDUCT FROM SIMPLY RESIGNING
AND SEEKING EMPLOYMENT AT
ANOTHER INSTITUTION. THE BILL
HAS PASSED THROUGH BOTH HOUSES,
WITH NO NO VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE? SEEING NONE, THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES 30
900. THE MEASURE PASSES AND I
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 263. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2597.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2597 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD. AN ACT TO HOUSING. SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES. I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB 2597,
WHICH WILL HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND HCD HAVE MORE
CAPACITY AND TIME TO PRODUCE,
EDIT AND REVIEW THE CLOSE TO 200
HOUSING ELEMENTS THAT ARE
SIMULTANEOUSLY Dð FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITHIN THE SCAG
REGION. THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS
REGION. THIS BILL DOES THIS BY
CREATING TWO PHASES OF HOUSING
ELEMENTS WITH DUE DATES FOR SCAG
THAT ARE SIX MONTHS APART, SO
THAT THE WORKLOAD SPIKE IS MUCH
MORE MANAGEABLE FOR ALL PARTIES,
AND GOOD QUALITY HOUSING
ELEMENTS CAN BE DRAFTED,
REVIEWED BY HCD AND ADOPTED WITH
LESS STRAIN AT THE SUGGESTION OF
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES. THE BILL
ALSO INCORPORATES SOME CHANGES
THAT WOULD STREAMLINE THE
APPEALS PROCESS. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT CREATING EFFICIENCIES AND
IMPROVING TIMELINES FOR HOUSING
ELEMENTS TO HELP OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS MEET THEIR HOUSING
NEEDS. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. MEMBERS. DISCUSSION.
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. ALVARADO. GIL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAESER.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA.
NO PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. GLAZER GROVE.
WILK ON A VOTE OF 30. IN FAVOR.
SIX AGAINST. THE MEASURE PASSES
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 267.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3093. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3093
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD. AN ACT
TO LAND USE. SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES.
MR. PRESIDENT, I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB 3093. THIS BILL
REFINES AND ENHANCES THE RENA
PROCESS TO INCLUDE THOSE
EXPERIENCING OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS BY ADDING TWO NEW
INCOME CATEGORIES ACUTELY LOW
INCOME AND EXTREMELY LOW INCOME.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER, ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLY DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NILO. NO. OCHOA.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL. BRADFORD. AYE.
DALLEY LAIRD. AYE. WHEN OCHOA.
PORTANTINO. AYE IT'S A VOTE OF
31. IN FAVOR AND FIVE AGAINST.
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS. I
HAVE TWO ADDITIONAL BILLS ON THE
DOCKET I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU.
FIRST, JUST FILE ITEM 138 BY
SENATOR BLAKE SPEER AND FILE
ITEM 83 BY SENATOR WILK. WE'LL
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 138. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2236.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2236 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
SOLID WASTE I MISSPOKE. THE
FLOOR MANAGER IS SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. SEN. BLAKE. SIR, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MR. PRESIDENT, MAY I
PLEASE HAVE PERMISSION TO USE A
DECORUM SUPPORTING PROP FROM. AN
OCTOPUS. OCTOPUS? IT DOES NOT
INVOLVE AN OCTOPUS. WHAT ABOUT A
CONDOM? OH. BIG DEBATE. IF IT'S
OKAY WITH THE FLOOR MANAGER,
LET'S TAKE A PAUSE. TEMPORARILY.
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT BILL
AND COME BACK TO IT. OKAY, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
83. THIS IS.
OKAY. SO FILE ITEM 138 HAS BEEN
READ. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
FLOOR MANAGER SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. AND PERMISSION GRANTED
OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES. SO
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB
2236 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN, WHICH JUST
LIKE MY MIRROR BILL ON THIS
TOPIC, WILL ELIMINATE PLASTIC
BAGS AT THE GROCERY STORE
CHECKOUT. SO INSTEAD OF BEING
ASKED, WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE
PAPER OR PLASTIC, YOU WILL BE
ASKED IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
PAPER, OR YOU COULD BRING IN
YOUR REUSABLE CANVAS BAG TO TAKE
YOUR GROCERIES HOME. PLASTIC
BAGS ARE A PARTICULAR
ENVIRONMENTAL SCOURGE. THEY ARE
USED FOR AN AVERAGE OF 12
MINUTES AND THEN ARE DISCARDED,
ENDING UP IN OUR OCEANS, OPEN
SPACES, FILLING UP OUR
LANDFILLS, AND RARELY BEING
RECYCLED OR REUSED. THEY
DEGENERATE INTO TOXIC
MICROPLASTICS THAT FESTER IN OUR
BODIES AND IN EVERY PART OF OUR
PLANET. THIS BILL WILL FINALLY
ELIMINATE PLASTIC CARRYOUT BAGS
FROM STORE CHECKOUTS, WHICH
VOTERS ASKED FOR IN A BALLOT
INITIATIVE PASSED IN 2016. THIS
IS A BIPARTISAN BILL, AND
SUPPORTERS INCLUDE STRONG
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS, THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
AND MANY OTHERS WHO WANT TO DO
BETTER FOR OUR ENVIRONMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
BLAKESPEAR, AND FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN PRESENTING THAT
BILL. MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ANY MEMBER WISHES TO BE
HEARD ON THIS MEASURE. SENATOR
LAIRD. THANK YOU. MR. PRESIDENT.
I THOUGHT I'D SAY TWO THINGS.
ONE IS, AS A SIGNER OF THE
BALLOT ARGUMENT OF THE 2016
BALLOT MEASURE, THAT WAS JUST
REFERRED TO, THIS REALLY TAKES
IT TO THE NEXT STEP AND IT IS
APPROPRIATE. THE OTHER THING I'D
SAY IS THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
REALLY STRONG ADS ON SOCIAL
MEDIA AGAINST THESE BILLS, AND
IT'S CLEARLY FUNDED BY THE
OUT-OF-STATE PLASTIC BAG PEOPLE
TRYING TO TWIST THE ISSUE. AND
IT'S BEEN TARGETED AGAINST A
NUMBER OF MEMBERS ON THIS FLOOR,
AND IT'S BEEN NOT FAIR. AND I
DON'T THINK TRULY ACCURATE. I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD BILL TO
RECOMMEND, AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR LAIRD. SENATOR
WIENER. AYE, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. PLASTIC
BAGS ARE SO INCREDIBLY
DESTRUCTIVE TO THE ENVIRONMENT
ON SO MANY DIFFERENT LEVELS. AS
THE AUTHOR MENTIONED, THEY LIKE,
INCORPORATE INTO OUR BODIES.
THEY ARE TOXIC TO PEOPLE IN
GENERAL. AND PARTICULARLY TO
CHILDREN WHO ARE DEVELOPING.
THEY GET INTO OUR WATERWAYS AND
THERE'S NO WAY TO EFFECTIVELY
KEEP THEM OUT. AND THEY DESTROY
ECOSYSTEMS AND STRANGLE BIRDS.
AND, YOU KNOW, I THINK WHAT
HAPPENED WAS WE STARTED MOVING
TOWARDS GETTING RID OF THOSE
REALLY SHODDY THIN BAGS THAT
JUST, LIKE, FALL APART AND, AND,
AND BUSINESSES JUST WENT TO
THESE THICKER BAGS, WHICH PEOPLE
DON'T REALLY REUSE. PEOPLE REUSE
PAPER BAGS. THEY DO NOT REUSE
PLASTIC BAGS IN ANY MEANINGFUL
WAY. AND SO THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT IT AND URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR WIENER, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MATTER? SENATOR STERN? THANK YOU.
UNDER THE GUN. MADE IT UNDER THE
GUN. YES. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN FAVOR OF
THIS MEASURE. I WANT TO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK ON
THIS, AS WELL AS THE COMPANION
MEASURE FROM HER FLOOR JOCKEY.
LOOK, WE KNOW SOMETIMES IT FEELS
POLITICAL, AND ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE WORD WORDS LIKE
BAN. BUT THE FACT IS, THIS BILL
STILL OPERATES WITHIN THE
BROADER FRAMEWORK THAT WE THINK
IS GOING TO ALLOW FOR INDUSTRIES
TO PROVIDE ALL KINDS OF
PACKAGING OPTIONS. THIS BILL IS
REALLY ABOUT A CERTAIN KIND OF
FILM BAG, FROM NOT BEING SORT OF
ABLE TO END AROUND STATE
REGULATIONS. SO YOU KNOW, THERE
WILL BE A LOT SAID ABOUT THESE
KIND OF MEASURES, I'M SURE OF,
BUT BUT WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
IT, THE OVERALL SB 54 FRAMEWORK
IS STILL IN PLACE AND WE THINK
THIS IS GOING TO ACTUALLY
AUGMENT THAT FRAMEWORK BY ADDING
SOME CLARITY AROUND CERTAIN
KINDS OF BAGS SOLD AT THE POINT
OF SALE. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR STERN.
SENATOR ALLEN. AS WE WAIT FOR
SOMETHING COMING OVER FROM THE
ASSEMBLY, I WANT TO JUST
PERSONALLY THANK THE FLOOR
JOCKEY, SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR, WHO
HAS BEEN A FANTASTIC
ENVIRONMENTAL CHAMPION IN THIS
BODY, HAS BEEN WORKING A LOT ON
INTERNAL ENVIRONMENTAL
PRACTICES. AND THIS HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE, THIS
JOINT EFFORT WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN HAS BEEN IS
REFLECTIVE OF HER BROADER GOALS.
THIS IS A THIS IS A BILL OF
COURSE, THAT ULTIMATELY IS ABOUT
MEETING THE SPIRIT AND THE
PROMISE OF THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION THAT SENATOR PADILLA,
NOW US SENATOR PADILLA PUSHED,
AND THAT THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA VOTED FOR. AND
THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
THE PROMISE AND THE SPIRIT OF
THAT WORK IS EFFECTUATED. SO
THANK YOU, SENATOR FROM
ENCINITAS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. YOU'RE DOING A
FANTASTIC JOB TODAY. AND IF
OTHERS WANT TO WEIGH IN ON THIS
IMPORTANT MATTER, I'D BE LOVE TO
HEAR FROM YOU. THANK YOU.
SENATOR ALLEN. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
NEWMAN? I'VE BEEN ASKED TO KILL
SOME TIME BY MY COLLEAGUES, SO I
JUST WANT TO WEIGH IN AND SALUTE
THE. OTHERWISE, EVERYBODY WOULD
HATE ME. SO I WANT TO SALUTE THE
WORK OF OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SOCAL
AS WELL AS THE AUTHOR. THIS IS
GOOD WORK. DESPITE THE PRESSURES
STILL WATCHING AND URGING, I
VOTE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NEWMAN. ALL
RIGHT. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SENATOR LIMÓN. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS I ALSO WANT TO
COMMEND BOTH AUTHORS WHO HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS DILIGENTLY
FOR A VERY LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
I THINK THAT WHAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO DO IS REALLY MOVE FROM
THE ORIGINAL LAW, AND
LEGISLATION TO MAKE SOME
CHANGES. WE KNOW THAT PLASTIC
BAGS LAST A VERY LONG TIME, BUT
ALSO CONTAMINATE AND DON'T
DECOMPOSE IN A WAY THAT WE NEED
THAT'S FRIENDLY FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. SO I THANK THEM FOR
THEIR DILIGENT WORK, AND I AM
EXCITED TO SEE THEIR LEGISLATION
MOVE FORWARD, AND I HOPE THAT WE
CAN SUPPORT IT TODAY. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR CIERTO. THANK
YOU MR. PRESIDENT. MAY I POSE A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR SENATOR
THE FLOOR MANAGER. THAT WOULD BE
THE CORRECT DESIGNATION. SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TAKE A QUESTION FROM SENATOR
CIERTO? I WOULD LIKE TO SENATOR
CIERTO, WHAT IS YOUR QUESTION?
DOES THIS MEASURE PREVENT PEOPLE
FROM GOING TO COSTCO AND BUYING
THE EXACT SAME BAGS IN DIFFERENT
SIZES? ONE FOR DOG WASTE AND ONE
FOR YOUR GROCERIES? IF YOU WANT,
AND TAKING THEM TO THE STORE.
MAY I ANSWER THE QUESTION? YES,
YOU MAY, OR YOU CAN ANSWER IT ON
YOUR CLOTHES. THAT IS AN OPTION.
THAT IS THERE FOR YOU. I WOULD
LIKE TO ANSWER IT NOW. SO THE
BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT WHAT YOU
BUY AT THE GROCERY STORE AT ALL.
YOU CAN BUY PET WASTE BAGS. YOU
CAN BUY ZIPLOC BAGS, YOU CAN BUY
BACKPACKS. YOU CAN BUY
EVERYTHING YOU COULD NORMALLY
BUY. THIS IS WHEN YOU ARE TAKING
YOUR GROCERIES HOME. WHAT IS
BEING OFFERED TO YOU AT
CHECKOUT, AND IT'S THE BILL SAYS
THAT WHAT IS OFFERED IS PAPER
ONLY IN THE SAME WAY THAT THAT'S
NOW ONLY OFFERED AT TRADER JOE'S
AND WHOLE FOODS AND OTHER
STORES, THAT THIS WILL BE ACROSS
ALL SUPERMARKETS WOULD BE ONLY
OFFERING PAPER AT CHECKOUT. SO I
CAN OFFER MY SMALL DOG AT HOME
THAT WE CONTINUE WITH OUR WALKS
ON YOUR OWN TIME. NOW, THE
QUESTION HAS BEEN ANSWERED. NOW
IT'S ON YOUR OWN TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ADDRESS THAT, MR.
PRESIDENT. PRESIDENT. THANK YOU.
SO I WOULD SAY THAT MY DOG, MY
SMALL DOG WILL APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE WITHOUT THESE PLASTIC
BAGS, THAT DOG WASTE, AND
ESPECIALLY IN THE AREAS WHERE WE
WALK THROUGH TOWN, WE HAVE MANY
DOG WALKERS. THAT'S WHAT THEY
USE TO PICK UP THE BAGS BECAUSE
THEY'RE MORE SANITARY. THEY
DON'T BLEED THROUGH ON A PAPER
BAG. AND I FEAR WITH THE
COMPLETE ELIMINATION WHERE I
THINK THIS WOULD BE HEADED,
PEOPLE WOULD JUST STOP PICKING
UP THEIR, THEIR PET WASTE. AND
MAY I RESPOND, MR. PRESIDENT?
NO, PLEASE. THERE'S NO QUESTION
HERE. I HAVE NO RESPONSE. YOU
CAN YOU CAN RESPOND IN A CLOSE.
SO, SO THAT THAT IS MY CONCERN
IS, IS THIS MEASURE OR THESE
TYPE OF MEASURES KEEP CREEPING
INTO OUR LIVES FURTHER AND
FURTHER IS THAT I WOULD LIKE A
LINE DRAWN AT SOME POINT. SO
THAT COMMON SENSE AND, AND YOU
KNOW, FOR US THE ABILITY TO, TO
LIVE OUR LIVES IN A MANNER THAT
IS BOTH RESPECTFUL TO OUR
NEIGHBORS BY CLEANING UP AFTER
OUR DOG WASTE AND THINGS LIKE
THAT, BUT ALSO YOU KNOW, PLASTIC
BAGS DO SERVE A PURPOSE. AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT AS
PERMEABLE. AND YOU CAN CARRY
YOUR GROCERIES HOME IN THEM IF
YOU WANT. I GUESS IF YOU TAKE
THOSE BAGS IN. SO I THINK IT
DOES A LITTLE BIT OF HELP FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT, BUT IT DOES NOT
ELIMINATE THE PROBLEM. THANK YOU
SENATOR. THANK YOU SENATOR.
SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB 2236 WITH SOME KIND OF
SOME CONCERNS AND SOME
OBSERVATIONS I'VE NOTICED IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY THAT
OFTENTIMES THINGS AND IDEAS
BECOME FULL CIRCLE. I DON'T KNOW
HOW LONG AGO IT WAS MAYBE A
DECADE OR TWO THAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY WAS ALL
UP IN ARMS ABOUT GETTING RID OF
PAPER BAGS AND SWITCHING TO
PLASTIC BAGS BECAUSE OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES, ENERGY AND
WATER AND CHEMICALS IT TOOK TO
PRODUCE THE PAPER BAGS. NOW, IN
2024, WE'VE COME AROUND TO,
ARGUING THAT THE PAPER BAGS ARE
GOING TO SAVE THE PLANET AND
THESE PLASTIC BAGS ARE RUINING
THE PLANET. NOW, LOOK, I AGREE
THAT THE LITTER OF THESE BAGS IS
A PROBLEM AND NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. I'M NOT SURE THAT
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THAT CONCERN
OR MOVES US IN THAT DIRECTION. I
DO HAVE AN ADDITIONAL CONCERN. I
WOULD LIKE THE AUTHOR TO ADDRESS
IF THAT WOULD BE OKAY. MR.
PRESIDENT, IF I MAY ASK A
QUESTION OF THE FLOOR MANAGER,
PLEASE. SENATOR JONES WOULD LIKE
TO ASK A QUESTION TO THE FLOOR
MANAGER. WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE
A QUESTION? I WOULD BE
DELIGHTED. OKAY. SENATOR JONES,
WHAT IS YOUR QUESTION? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS BEFORE 2014 AND
SINCE 2014, MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE PASSED THEIR
OWN PLASTIC BAG BAN OF DIFFERENT
SORTS THROUGH DIFFERENT
MUNICIPALITIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HOW DOES THIS BILL ADDRESS THAT
DIFFERENT, AMOUNT, YOU KNOW,
DIFFERENT, VARIOUS TYPES OF BANS
THAT ALREADY EXIST IN THE STATE.
ALL RIGHT, SENATOR JONES, LET'S
SEE IF THEIR QUESTION IS GOING
TO BE ANSWERED NOW OR IN HER
CLOSE. SENATOR SHAKESPEARE, IT
IT DOES NOT AFFECT ANY LOCAL
BANS THAT MIGHT BE SOMEHOW MORE
SEVERE. ALL IT DOES IS ELIMINATE
THE OPTION FOR PLASTIC BAGS. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SENATOR SHAKESPEARE.
SENATOR JONES, ON YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I
APPRECIATE THAT, I STILL REMAIN
OPPOSED AND WILL BE VOTING NO ON
AB 2236. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR JONES. SENATOR EGGMAN,
YOUR MICROPHONE IS UP VERY TALL.
MICROPHONE. I THINK IT'S A VERY
IT'S A VERY TALL MICROPHONE.
IT'S A VERY SPECIAL MICROPHONE.
AND I'M GLAD TO HAVE IT, I
WANTED TO I WANTED TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO THE DOG WASTE ISSUE
BECAUSE THERE IS GOOD NEWS TO
QUESTION THE AUTHOR. I'M NOT
SURE IF THE AUTHOR KNEW THAT
THERE IS GOOD NEWS THAT A FEW
YEARS AGO, I PASSED A BILL THAT
GROCERY STORE BAGS, WHICH I
OFTEN USE THAT YOU MIGHT PUT
YOUR YOUR GREENS IN TO MAKE ALL
OF THOSE BIODEGRADABLE
COMPOSTABLE. IN FACT, FOR THE
VERY ISSUE THAT WAS MENTIONED
BEFORE. AND ALSO WHEN YOU BUY
THOSE THINGS FOR YOUR DOGS, MOST
OF THEM ARE NOW COMPOSTABLE. SO
THAT'S THE GOOD NEWS. THEY MAY
NOT HOLD YOUR GROCERIES, BUT
THEY'LL HOLD THAT OTHER THING
THAT YOU'RE CARRYING UNTIL YOU
GET TO THE PROPER RECEPTACLE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER, YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU, I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL, COMMITMENT AND
THE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AND
OTHER IMPORTANT PLASTIC
REDUCTION EFFORTS THAT WE HAVE.
AND I WANT TO ADDRESS,
PARTICULARLY THE ISSUE ABOUT PET
WASTE. SO MANY PEOPLE, IDEALLY,
THE BAG IS COMPOSTABLE. AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAID. BUT IF PEOPLE
ARE BUYING FRUIT AND VEGETABLES,
THEY ARE PROBABLY USING A
PLASTIC BAG FOR THOSE THINGS,
AND THEY COULD USE THAT TO PICK
UP THEIR PET WASTE. AND I THINK
THERE'S A REALITY TO THE FACT
THAT MANY PEOPLE ARE USING THEIR
BAGS TO LINE THEIR TRASH CANS IN
THEIR BATHROOMS OR PICK UP THEIR
PET WASTE, BUT THERE ARE STILL A
LOT OF BAGS. THE VAST MAJORITY
OF BAGS THAT ARE NOT BEING
RECYCLED ARE NOT BEING REUSED,
AND HAVE AN AVERAGE LIFESPAN OF
12 MINUTES. AND WHAT WE NEED TO
DO IS REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
PLASTIC THAT WE ARE PRODUCING
ACROSS A WHOLE VARIETY OF
SECTORS, AND THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT START. SO WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE FACT THAT THE VOTERS
ACTUALLY PASSED IN 2016, A
SINGLE USE PLASTIC BAG BAN, AND
IN THAT TIME, PLASTIC BAG WASTE
HAS DOUBLED. PLASTIC BAG WASTE
HAS DOUBLED SINCE THE BAN ON
SINGLE USE PLASTIC BAGS. BECAUSE
THE PLASTIC BAGS ARE DOUBLE THE
THICKNESS, WE REALIZE THAT THIS
LOOPHOLE NEEDS TO BE CLOSED. SO
I ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT THIS. I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT THAT WAS
EXPRESSED TODAY. AND THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT BILL THAT WILL
MOVE THE NEEDLE. THANK YOU. WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. WITH ALL
DEBATE HAVING CEASED, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ALVARADO GILL. ARCHULETA I ASHBY
I ATKINS I BECKER. BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLEY. NÓ DODD I DURAZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE NÓ HURTADO I JONES. NO
LAIRD I LEHMAN I MCGUIRE I
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO OCHOA. BOGH
NO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH
I RUBIO I SEYARTO. NO SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN, I
UMBERG I WAHAB, I WIENER I WILK.
NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO GILL. BECKER.
I BRADFORD I ON A VOTE OF 31 IN
FAVOR. EIGHT AGAINST. THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS TO GIVE
YOU A HEADS UP ON THREE
ADDITIONAL BILLS. WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR TONIGHT. I'VE ALREADY
MENTIONED THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FILE ITEM 83 NEXT, FOLLOWED
BY FILE ITEM 141, 241 AND 212.
WE'LL BEGIN NEXT WITH FILE ITEM
83. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1949
BY SENATOR WILK. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. YOU'RE PASSING ON
FILE. YOU'LL TAKE IT UP ON
SEPTEMBER 1ST. SURE ALL RIGHT,
LET'S READ THE BILL. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1949 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILKS. AND RELATING TO PRIVACY.
SENATOR WILK, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AB 1949 ESTABLISHES STRONGER
DATA PRIVACY PROTECTIONS FOR
MINORS UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT TO HELP
KEEP CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
18 SAFE ONLINE AND TO PREVENT
THEIR DATA FROM BEING COLLECTED
AND EXPLOITED WITHOUT CONSENT.
WHILE WE HAVE EXISTING FEDERAL
AND STATE PRIVACY LAWS THAT
PROVIDE LIMITED PROTECTIONS FOR
CHILDREN'S DATA, THERE ARE STILL
GAPS IN THE LAW THAT ALLOWS
BUSINESSES TO COLLECT, EXPLOIT
AND MONETIZE CHILDREN'S DATA ON
A MASSIVE SCALE. THIS BILL
EXPANDS CCPA PROTECTIONS TO
INCLUDE RESTRICTIONS ON THE
COLLECTION, USE, AND DISCLOSURE
OF CHILDREN'S DATA AND WOULD
ENSURE THAT THESE PROTECTIONS
APPLY TO YOUTH UP TO AGE 18.
ACROSS THE BOARD, AB 1949 IS
SPONSORED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, SUPPORTED BY CHILDREN'S
ADVOCATES, CONSUMER GROUPS, AND
THE CALIFORNIA PRIVACY
PROTECTION AGENCY, AMONG OTHERS.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND PASSED OUT OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON A
UNANIMOUS 11 ZERO VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR WILK.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE, ANY SENATOR WANTING TO
BE HEARD ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN MCGUIRE. AYE MENGIBAR.
MEN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
MENGIBAR. AYE NGUYEN. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE
CIERTO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL. DALLEY
JONES. LEMON. NGUYEN OCHOA. BORG
CIERTO. ON A VOTE OF 33 IN
FAVOR, ZERO AGAINST THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 141. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2085. FLOOR
MANAGER IS SENATOR ATKINS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. THE
ASSEMBLY BILL 2085 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN AND AQUILANTE
LAND USE. SENATOR ATKINS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
I RISE TO PRESENT AB 2085 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN. THIS STREAMLINES
THE PROCESS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF NECESSARY COMMUNITY CLINICS.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THESE CLINICS
ARE ALREADY IN AREAS ZONED FOR
OFFICE, RETAIL, HEALTH CARE OR
PARKING. THIS BILL SIMPLY
REQUIRES MINISTERIAL APPROVAL OF
CLINICS THAT MEET ALL OF THE
LOCALITY STANDARDS, ENDING THE
ARBITRARY OBSTRUCTIONS OF LIFE
SAVING CARE. IT HAS BECOME CLEAR
THAT WE, AS A STATE, NEED TO
ENSURE AND PROTECT BASIC ACCESS
TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
CLINICS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ADKINS. ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY FURTHER
DEBATE? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY. NÓ. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEMON AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR I MEAN
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NILO
WHEN? NO. NILO OCHOA. NO NILO.
NO. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO.
NO SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
WAHAB UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK NO. ON A VOTE
OF 31 IN FAVOR. EIGHT AGAINST.
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 241.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2488 FOR
MANAGED BY SENATOR WIENER
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2488 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TÍNH ENACTED INTO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. SENATOR WIENER I
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2488 ON BEHALF OF
SAN FRANCISCO, ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING. THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT ALLOWS SAN
FRANCISCO TO CREATE A DOWNTOWN
FINANCING DISTRICT TO HELP MAKE
OFFICE TO HOUSING CONVERSIONS IN
OUR CITY'S DOWNTOWN. PENCIL. WE
KNOW THAT SAN FRANCISCO'S
DOWNTOWN HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY
HARD HIT BY THE PANDEMIC, AND
THE SHIFT TO REMOTE WORK, AND
HAS BEEN SLOW TO RECOVER. THESE
CONVERSIONS ARE GOING TO BE
NECESSARY, AND WE KNOW THAT
ALLOWING THE CITY TO UTILIZE
THIS FINANCING TOOL WILL
FACILITATE THESE NEEDED
CONVERSIONS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR WIENER. SENATOR. SENATOR
CABALLERO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. FIRST, LET ME SAY
THAT I WANT TO I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT SAN FRANCISCO
NEEDS HELP TO REPURPOSE THEIR
COMMERCIAL AND OFFICE SPACE.
THIS IS A GOOD SOLUTION. I JUST
WANT TO REMARK THAT WE ALLOW
THIS FOR SAN FRANCISCO, BUT AT
SOME POINT WE'RE GOING TO NEED
TO EXTEND IT TO THE ENTIRE
STATE. WE ALL HAVE DOWNTOWNS
THAT ARE SUFFERING BECAUSE OF
THE NEW ECONOMY, WHERE PEOPLE
ARE BUYING THINGS ONLINE RATHER
THAN SPENDING MONEY IN STORES.
AND THIS IS A REAL GOOD TEST
PROJECT PROCESS FOR SAN
FRANCISCO. IF IT WORKS THERE, IT
CAN WORK IN OUR COMMUNITIES AS
WELL. THIS IS THE OLD RDA, AND
SO WE MAY NEED TO BRING IT BACK.
AND SO I WANT TO THANK THE FLOOR
MANAGER FOR BRINGING THIS UP AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SENATOR WIENER, YOU
MAY CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. NÓ. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLAZER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA.
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO.
NO. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL. GROVE.
JONES LEMON. AYE ON A VOTE OF 32
TO 5, THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 212. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2515 FOR MANAGED
BY SENATOR SKINNER. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2515
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPIN. AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS AB 2515 DOES
THREE KEY THINGS. IT BANS
INTENTIONALLY ADDED PFAS IN
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS. IT REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL TO DETERMINE A
THRESHOLD AMOUNT FOR
UNINTENTIONALLY ADDED PFAS. AND
IT REQUIRES MENSTRUAL PRODUCT
MANUFACTURERS TO REGISTER
COMPLIANCE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
BY 2029. INTIMATE AND REPEATED
EXPOSURE TO PFAS CAN COMPROMISE
A WOMAN'S HEALTH. REMOVING IT
FROM THESE PRODUCTS IS ONE OF
THE KEY WAYS WE CAN PROTECT
WOMEN'S HEALTH AND ALSO SAVE OUR
WATER DISTRICTS MONEY FROM
HAVING TO REMOVE PFAS FROM OUR
MUNICIPAL WATER SOURCES. WITH
THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR SKINNER, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, CALL THE ROLL,
PLEASE. ALAN ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY. DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
MIN. MIN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. AYE PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL DALY. GROVE
JONES. WHEN NELLO STATO. ON A
VOTE OF 33. IN FAVOR. NONE
AGAINST. THE MEASURE PASSES.
OKAY, MEMBERS, YOU CAN REMAIN
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS FOR JUST A
MOMENT. WE'RE GOING TO LIFT
CALLS. AND AS YOU KNOW, WE NEED
EVERYBODY IN THEIR CHAIRS AS WE
DO THAT SO WE CAN HAVE THE TOTAL
FOCUS ON THOSE REMAINING BILLS.
AND MEMBERS. VOICES CAN BE
HEARD. AND THEN WE MAY BE COMING
TO A GOOD CONCLUSION HERE, BUT
LET'S WAIT AND SEE. LET'S DO THE
MEASURES ON CALL JUST IN JUST A
MOMENT.
AND I SAT DOWN WITH THE CLERK.
OKAY, MEMBERS, HERE'S THE RUN OF
THE SHOW HERE. WE'RE GOING TO
LIFT CALLS. IT'S GOING TO TAKE
ABOUT TEN MINUTES TO GET THE
MACHINERY IN PLACE FOR THAT. SO
WE'RE GOING TO LET YOU GET UP
AND STRETCH, USE THE RESTROOMS
TEN MINUTES. AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO COME BACK AND WE HAVE
TWO CONSENT CALENDARS. SO WE'RE
GOING TO DO CALLS. AND THEN BACK
HERE AT 988 50 ON THE ON THE DOT.
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO DO THE
CONSENT CALENDARS. AND THAT
COULD BE IT. SO LET'S WE'LL STAY
TUNED ON THAT. BUT WE'RE GOING
TO GO IN RECESS FOR TEN MINUTES.
IN THE CHAMBER AND TO THEIR
SEATS. SO WE CAN FINISH OUR WORK
THIS EVENING AND CAN GET PEOPLE
HOME. SERGEANTS, PLEASE CALL ALL
THE MEMBERS BACK TO THE
CHAMBERS, PLEASE. DO YOU WANT TO
FURNISH? WE'RE GOING TO. CALL
OUR SENATE RECESS HAS ENDED 14
MINUTES. WE HAVE. YOU WERE LATE.
I KNOW. YOU ARE GOING TO THE
ASSEMBLY TO GET SKINNER, BECKER
AND GROVE OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY.
SERGEANTS, IF WE CAN INVITE ALL
THE SENATORS BACK HERE TO THE
CHAMBER SO WE CAN CONCLUDE OUR
OUR LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
MEMBERS. IT WOULD HELP US IF YOU
COULD RETURN TO YOUR DESK SO WE
CAN DO A COUNT OF MEMBERS. AND
WE CAN BEGIN MEASURES ON CALL TO
ASK ALL THE SENATORS TO COME
BACK TO THEIR DESKS. PLEASE.
WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS ON CALL.
MEMBERS, PLEASE BE PREPARED FOR
YOUR VOTES. IF YOU HAVE NOT CAST
A VOTE ON THESE MEASURES.
WE ARE WAITING FOR SENATORS
SKINNER AND BECKER. THEY COULD
RETURN TO THE CHAMBERS. PLEASE.
SENATORS SKINNER AND BECKER.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS, WE ARE
BACK IN SESSION. SENATOR JONES,
WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. A POINT OF
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY, PLEASE.
WHAT IS YOUR POINT OF
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY? FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE BODY. I'M TRYING
TO CALCULATE THE 72 HOUR RULE ON
BILLS AND AMENDMENTS BEING TAKEN
UP. AND IF MY CALCULATIONS ARE
CORRECT, WE ARE GETTING CLOSE TO
THAT PERIOD FOR THE MINUTE.
EXCUSE ME? THE MIDNIGHT HOUR ON
SATURDAY NIGHT. SO AM I CORRECT
IN IN UNDERSTANDING THAT ANY,
AMENDMENTS OR ANYTHING THAT IS
PUT IN PRINT AT ANY POINT
BETWEEN NOW AND MIDNIGHT
TONIGHT, THAT TIMESTAMP WILL BE
APPROPRIATE, WILL BE APPLIED TO
THAT SAME TIME ON SATURDAY.
SENATOR JONES, I THINK YOU ARE
CORRECT, BUT I INVITE YOU TO
CHECK IN WITH THE CLERK AND THE
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE FOR
CONFIRMATION, BECAUSE IT'S A
LITTLE BIT ABOVE MY RANK. ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR GONZALEZ, FOR
WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS,
THERE IS A RESOLUTION AT THE
DESK REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE 61 FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ALLOWING ASSEMBLY
BILL 3121 TO BE AMENDED AFTER
THE DEADLINE. THESE REQUESTS
HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. I SEE A MICROPHONE UP
FROM SENATOR CIERTO, SIR MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. IF
WE WERE OPPOSED TO THIS
AMENDMENT BEFORE, WE ARE REALLY
OPPOSED TO IT NOW, AT THE RISK
OF DOING A THREE HOUR AND TWO
MINUTE FILIBUSTER SPEECH SO THAT
WE WOULD NOT HAVE TO HEAR THIS,
WE WOULD ASK THAT 13 OF YOU
BRAVE SOULS STAND UP. THIS IS
YOUR MOMENT. WE HAVE NOT WON ONE
OF THESE ALL YEAR LONG. WE JUST
WANT TO WIN ONE. AND THIS IS IT.
ALL RIGHT, STAND WITH ME AND
OPPOSE THIS. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. THAT WAS A NON-DEBATABLE
MOTION. BUT WE'LL TAKE THAT AS A
NO VOTE. SENATOR GONZALEZ IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. WE'RE
GOING TO READ THE RESOLUTION AND
THEN WE WILL CAST A VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION. RESOLVE THAT JOINT
RULE 61 BE DISPENSED WITH. ALL
RIGHT. ALL DEBATE. HAVING CEASED
ON THIS NON-DEBATABLE MOTION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN, I ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA. I ASHBY I ATKINS, I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER. I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY NÓ
DODD. I DURAZO I EGGMAN GLASER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HURTADO I
JONES. NÓ. LAIRD I LIMON I
MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MIN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN NØ. NILO NÓ.
OCHOA NÓ. PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO I SATO. NÓ. SKINNER
I. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN, I
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK.
NÓ HE'S CALLED THE ABSENT.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROVE NØ. ALVARADO. GILL EGGMAN.
NO. ALL RIGHT. ON A VOTE OF 31
TO 8, THE. THE JOINT RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. SENATOR GONZALEZ,
MEMBERS, PLEASE GIVE SENATOR
GONZALEZ YOUR ATTENTION. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS,
THERE IS A RESOLUTION AT THE
DESK REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE 61 AND 62 A
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ALLOWING
ASSEMBLY BILL 3121 TO BE HEARD
IN POLICY AND FISCAL COMMITTEES
AFTER THE DEADLINE. THESE
REQUESTS HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GONZALEZ. SENATOR
SECRETO, AGAIN, WE WOULD ASK FOR
A NO VOTE ON THIS. WE WILL ALSO
BE OKAY WITH A SUBSTITUTE ROLL.
I BELIEVE MISS EGGMAN WOULD HAVE
TO AGREE TO AGAIN JOIN THE RIGHT
SIDE OF THE ROOM TO SAVE OUR
SATURDAY NIGHT. THAT'S WHAT IT'S
CALLED. FROM NOW ON, SAVE OUR
SATURDAY NIGHT. THANK YOU SIR.
THAT'D BE THE NORTH SIDE,
BECAUSE RIGHT WOULD BE DEPENDING
ON YOUR PERSPECTIVE. RIGHT? SO
YOU'RE RIGHT. YEAH. OKAY.
SENATOR GONZALEZ IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR SECRETO IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. WE'RE
GOING TO READ THE RESOLUTION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION. RESOLVE THAT JOINT
RULE 61 AND 62 BE DISPENSED
WITH. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE PREVIOUS ROLL CALL?
ALL RIGHT, SO WE WILL WE WILL.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I
BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY NÓ
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE NÓ HURTADO I
JONES NØ. LAIRD I LIMON I
MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I'M IN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO
OKUBO NO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO I SATO. NO. SKINNER
I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN, I
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER, I WILK
NO. ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 8, THE
JOINT RULES ARE SUSPENDED. ANY
OTHER MOTIONS, I CAN'T SEE
MICROPHONES BECAUSE THERE ARE
MEMBERS STANDING IN FRONT.
SENATE-TV PORTANTINO'S MIC IS
NOT UP. SENATOR BECKER, DO YOU
HAVE AN ITEM THAT YOU WANT TO
TAKE UP ON? MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS? YES THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO REMOVE AB
551 BENNETT FROM THE SPECIAL
CONSENT FILE. THE DESK WILL NOTE
SENATOR PORTANTINO. YES MR.
PRESIDENT, AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE PULL FILE ITEM
319, AB 2892 OFF OF SPECIAL
CONSENT. THE DESK WILL NOTE,
SENATOR MIN, AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR, PLEASE MOVE. AB
3139, FILE ITEM NUMBER 97 TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. THE DESK WILL
NOTE ANYTHING FURTHER MEMBERS ON
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. OKAY,
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE BILLS ON
CALL. AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THAT BEING THE
ORDER OF THE DAY, WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN NOW WITH BILLS ON CALL.
I'D LIKE TO ASK ALL MEMBERS TO
RETURN TO THEIR DESKS, PLEASE.
SENATORS, I'D LIKE TO ASK ALL
MEMBERS TO RETURN TO THEIR
DESKS. PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH FILE ITEM 15. THIS IS
SENATE BILL 310. I NEED TO CALL
THE SENATE.
MEMBERS, LET ME JUST UPDATE YOU
ON ON THE STATUS. WE'RE JUST
DOING A LITTLE MECHANICAL WORK
UP HERE. JUST TAKE ANOTHER
MINUTE OR TWO, AND THEN WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR. SO MEMBERS
SHOULD LOOK TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THEY WANT TO PULL FROM
THOSE CONSENT CALENDARS. BEFORE
WE VOTE ON THEM. OKAY. AND THAT
MAY BE THAT MAY CONCLUDE OUR
WORK FOR THE EVENING. CAN I BE
HEARD OUT THERE? I HEAR YOU,
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT. ALL RIGHT,
WE GOT THE PIXIE DUST. WE'VE
SPREAD IT OVER THE MACHINERY. IT
SEEMS TO BE BACK IN IN TIP TOP
SHAPE AS OUR MEMBERS, READY TO
GO. CAN I HEAR A YES? OUR
MEMBERS READY TO GO. ALL RIGHT.
I KNOW THE ENTHUSIASM IS GROWING
HERE.
SO FAR, THEY HAVEN'T COME OVER
TO YOU. ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'D
ASK MEMBERS TO RETURN TO THEIR
DESKS SO WE CAN CONCLUDE OUR
BUSINESS TONIGHT. MEMBERS,
PLEASE RETURN TO YOUR DESKS SO
WE CAN GET THROUGH OUR BUSINESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE GOING
TO GO WITH OUR MEASURES ON CALL.
THERE ARE FIVE OF THEM. WE'LL
BEGIN WITH ITEM 15. WE'D LIKE TO
ASK EVERYONE TO KEEP THEIR
VOICES DOWN HERE, SO THE CLERK
CAN HEAR THE VOTES. WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 15 SB
310. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL
PADILLA, I. ON A VOTE OF 39 IN
FAVOR, ZERO AGAINST THE
ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM
22. THIS IS SB 900. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO, GIL LIMON. AYE.
PADILLA AYE. AND A VOTE OF 39 TO
0. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP, FILE ITEM
25. THIS IS SB 936. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GIL PADILLA I ON A
VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 30. THIS
IS SB 1064 1064. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GIL. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. WHEN HURTADO. AYE. WHEN
PADILLA. AYE RUBIO. AYE. TO NO.
ON A VOTE OF 37. IN FAVOR. ONE
AGAINST THE ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN LAST UP. ITEM
34. THIS IS SB 1184 BY SENATOR
EGGMAN. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBER ALVARADO GIL
PADILLA A ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION, MEMBERS. ON THAT. WE
ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR READ. BUT
BEFORE WE DO THAT, IS THERE ANY
MEMBER WHO WANTS TO PULL ANY
ITEM FROM EITHER THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR, 45 AND SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR 48? ANY MEMBER WANT TO
BE RECOGNIZED.
THE SECRETARY PLEASE READ ALL
ITEMS ON BOTH CONSENT CALENDARS.
SECOND AMENDMENT ASSEMBLY BILL
1792, 1808, 1885, 1888, 1973,
1997, 2024, 2033, 2038, 2082,
2096, 21, 38, 21, 81, 22, 71,
23, 30, 2401, 24, OH SEVEN, 24,
34, 24, 69, 24, 75, 2525, OH
ONE, 25, 11, 25, 38, 25, 55, 25,
64, 26, 21, 26, 45, 26, 95, 27,
36, 28, 17, 28, 21, 28, 83, 29,
29, 29, 31, 29, 83, 29, 84, 29,
92, 30, 12, 30, 45, 38, 87, 31,
OH EIGHT, 32, OH THREE, 32, 45,
32, 51, 32, 80, 13, 16. SENATE
BILL 1369 909 708 1313 1445 42.
778 896 906 908 931 946 963 9729
89, 1043, 1091, 1098, 1099,
1101, 11, 19, 1138, 1146, 1183,
1207, 1225, 1248, 1270, 1288,
1317. THE SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 285 AND
THE BALANCE OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ADRIN I ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY I
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMON I MAGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN I NILO I OCHOA BOGG I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I CIERTO I SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I STERN I
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I.
THAT'S A VOTE OF 39 TO 0 ON FILE
ITEM 285. AND WE'LL APPLY THAT
VOTE TO THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
BOTH CONSENT CALENDARS. THANK
YOU MEMBERS. IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE THE
SENATE, SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. A FIRST OF ALL,
FANTASTIC WORK TO THIS BODY.
QUICK RECAP. WE STARTED THE WEEK
AT 570 ASSEMBLY BILLS. TONIGHT
WE'RE AT 109 LEFT. INCREDIBLE
PROGRESS 157 DONE TODAY. ANOTHER
66 SENATE BILLS. WE ACCOMPLISHED
223 TOTAL BILLS. THANK YOU. I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
FLOOR TEAM, TO OUR MAJORITY
LEADER, OUR ASSISTANT MAJORITY
LEADER AND THE ASSISTANT AND TO
THE ENTIRE FLOOR TEAM. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK,
FOR KEEPING US MOVING. THANK YOU
TO THE DESK STAFF. WE WILL BE IN
AT 10 A.M. TOMORROW. WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT WE'RE GOING TO WORK
REALLY LATE TOMORROW NIGHT, SO
WE'LL PROBABLY WORK 10 A.M. GET
OUT AROUND DINNERTIME TOMORROW.
ISH SO WE WILL NOT BE HAVING A
LATE NIGHT TOMORROW NIGHT. THANK
YOU ALL FOR THE INCREDIBLE WORK.
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED
FOR THURSDAY, AUGUST 29TH AT 10
A.M. WONDERFUL JOB, MR.
PRESIDENT. TODAY THE SENATE WILL
BE ADJOURNED. WE WILL WE WILL
REASSEMBLE TOMORROW, THURSDAY AT
10 A.M. THANK YOU. MEMBERS. THE
SENATE IS ADJOURNED.